So, ich drücke jetzt hier mal auf Rekord. Also auf Rekord hab ich schon gedrückt, aber jetzt drücke ich hier nochmal auf Pause. Mein Backup läuft. Das, was mir jetzt, was dafür sorgen soll. Ich hab hier extra 16 Gigabyte in dieses Scheiß Digital-Rekorderteil reingesteckt. Wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie wildes digitale Setup. Max macht den Livestream.
Und eine Aufnahme.
Und eine Aufnahme und ich mach hier Multi-Culti-Rekord mit vielen Kanälen. Und ich würde sagen, wir haben nur und zwei bis vier Stunden vor uns.
Die sind zugeschaltet, die sind zwei für zwei nachspielen müssen, falls das schief geht.
Genau, der Tank ist voll, die Blase ist leer und wir tragen Sonnenbrillen.
Genau und ich bin total übermüdet.
Hallo. Willkommen bei Mobile Max, Ausgabe Nummer 24. Wir quillen uns voran nach einer längeren Pause, die bedingt war durch viele Dinge, unter anderem Urlaub. Ich war so frei, auch mal ein bisschen auszutreten.
Du Sau.
Ich Sau. Ja, ich hatte nämlich vorab einen Tipp aus dem Internet bekommen, dass das Wetter total scheiße wird in Berlin in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Ach, das Internet war sowas? Auf wetter.com oder was?
Nee, du legst einfach das Internet auf deinen Tisch und legst irgendwo in der Mitte auf.
Ach so, ich dachte, dass denen hier einfach gefragt, der fürs Wetter zuständig ist.
Ja, naja, ich hab einen Tipp bekommen, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall war ich weg. Jetzt bin ich wieder da und alles wird gut. Aber diese Woche hatten wir auch nur diesen heutigen Tag Zeit gehabt. Oh Gott, ich hab noch diesen furchtbaren Twitterifick hier an. Und was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen? Was hat mich das hier ganz durcheinander gebracht?
Einen Tag Zeit für...
Ach so, ja, weil wir eine aufregende Woche vor uns haben. Denn es ist Republika. Du bist wieder engagiert, ne?
Ich hab die Nacht heute nicht geschlafen, um die SMS-Wand wieder auf Vordermann zu bringen.
Gleich sollte man noch sagen, was die Republika ist. Das ist so das Brustnippel-Zeigen der digitalen Elite.
Genau.
Die sitzen da unter aller und reiben sich dieselben.
Der digitalen Medienelite.
Medienelite, genau.
Der selbsterklärten digitalen Medienelite.
Der selbsterklärten digitalen Medienelite, genau. Die schwafelt gern, die bloggt gern.
Also eigentlich nur Leute, die gerne Twittern und Blogs haben.
Ja, Podcasts hören sie allerdings alle nicht. Manche produzieren manche, aber mögen tun sie sie alle nicht.
Das andere ist ein bisschen egetget.
Ja, das ist, Podcasting ist noch so ein bisschen das schwarze Schaf in der digitalen Medienelite. Ich muss sagen, da fühl ich mich sehr wohl.
In der Schreiberlänge, ja.
Ja, ja. Weißt du, nur Buchstaben zählen und so. Man muss es auch, ja, Copy und Paste. Das ist wie beim iPhone und so weiter. Die reden, ach, kein Copy und Paste.
Und ich mach mir jetzt schon total in die Hose. Es ist nämlich das erste Mal in meinem Leben so richtig auf so einem großen Panel.
Oh, und was machst du da?
In Friedrichstadt-Verlass. Auf der größten Theaterbühne der Welt.
Ja, das ist die was? Das ist die größte Theaterbühne der Welt.
Mit irgendwie 2100 Quadratmetern. Da hab ich in der Wikipedia gelesen.
Die ist groß, ich war auch drauf.
Ich bisher noch nicht. Ich hab sie bisher nur mal von Weitem gesehen.
Die ist wirklich groß.
12 oder so?
Ich wusste nicht, dass es die größte ist.
Und mit Cem Basman und der hier diese Microblogging-Konferenz gemacht hat und Marco Kaiser, der Twirl geschrieben hat, und es geht, ratet mal warum, um Twitter. Nee, um Dosenudeln. Nee, Quatsch natürlich im Twitter. Also um mobiles Microblogging.
Und du moderierst.
Politisch korrekt.
Du wirst befragt.
Ja, es wird so ein bisschen, es wird so eine Gesprächsrunde im Idealfall werden und ich bin mal sehr gespannt.
So wie hier oder was?
So wie hier, genau. Bloß halt vor vielen, vielen Leuten. Und falls ihr auf der Republika seid, kommt gerne vorbei. Mittwoch gleich um 18 Uhr im Friedrichstadt-Balast.
Wie heißt es denn offiziell eigentlich richtig? Wie spricht man denn das aus? Republika?
Republika.
Republika?
Ich sag mal Republika.
Was ist die Übermorgen?
Was hast du Republika gesagt? Was ist die? Ja, die geht Mittwoch los.
Mittwoch bis Freitag.
Diesen Mittwoch.
Genau, ich sitze auf keinem Panel.
Ausnahmsweise mal.
Ja.
Schaffst du das?
Ausnahmsweise, na ja.
Was?
Du meinst, ich stürme einfach. Irgendwann. Ich will Öffentlichkeit. Ich hab keiner gefragt. Also ich hab da, ich kann ruhige Kugeln schieben.
Ich wollte dich ja gern als Moderator haben für unser Ding, aber die anderen beiden wollten keinen Moderator haben. Also ich hab noch nicht mal, also war nicht wegen dir, ich hatte noch nicht mal einen Namen gesagt. Ich hatte so vorsichtig so, hey, ich könnte unter Umständen jemanden haben, wenn wir einen Moderator brauchen.
Ist nicht so schlimm, wir haben ja hier genug Mikrofone. Ich hab genug Mikrofone, die vor mir stehen, so jede Woche. Ich hab ja auch im Urlaub ganz fleißig aus meinem Archiv heraus gepostet, sodass keiner auch nur auf die Idee gekommen wäre, ich wäre eigentlich im Urlaub gewesen. Wie auch immer, es geht hier um McIntosh, Apple und es ist ja so viel passiert. Denn kaum haben wir eine Sendepause eingelegt, ist Apple aus seinem Dornröschenschlaf erwacht und hat gesagt, ey, jetzt gibt es wieder richtig viele neue Sachen. Und bam, bam, bam, haben irgendwie eine Sache nach der anderen rausgehauen. Und die müssen wir jetzt chronologisch mit den Detailen abarbeiten. Ich habe mir ein paar Notizen gemacht, was wir alles verpasst haben.
Interessiert irgendjemand die neuen Macs?
Ja, mich interessieren die neuen Macs. Wollen wir damit anfangen?
Ja, na gut. Abhandeln?
Ja, also ich bin tempted, ich würde sagen, ich bin versucht neue Hardware zu kaufen. Ich bin bloß noch nicht dazu gekommen, mir wirklich darüber konkret Gedanken zu machen. Was ist rausgekommen? Ein iMac Update? Ein Mac Mini Update?
iMac auch?
Der iMac hat jetzt Nvidia auch, ne?
Also sie haben jetzt sozusagen alles auf Nvidia-Grafik gebracht, was sie ja irgendwie brauchen, um mit Snow Lepard richtig angeben zu können. Und das war ja auch ein naheliegender Schritt und auch bei Mac Mini. Also alles war eigentlich naheliegend. Was nicht so naheliegend war, war, dass diese Spy Pics, die davor gepostet wurden, von den Mac Mini ja tatsächlich hundertprozentig zutrafen. Das heißt, das Ding...
Mit den fünf USB-Ports die Geschichte.
An die ich keine Sekunde geglaubt habe. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass Apple jemand zu mir redet, mit fünf USB-Ports rausbringt.
Na ich...
Und nicht mal einen USB hab.
Na, aber da sieht man mal, was so ein DVI-Stecker, der nicht mehr da ist, auf einmal frei werden lässt. Also das war ja ein riesiger Klotz und dafür haben sie jetzt einmal Mini-Display-Port und sie haben... Oh, wie toll ich das finde. Einen zweiten Ausgang, ne? Dass sie das mit dem zweiten Ausgang gemacht hat. Ich glaube, das wird ganz erheblich dazu beitragen, dass dieser Mcmini, obwohl er ja wieder teuer geworden ist, wird das Ding trotzdem reinhauen. Weil ich kenne ganz viele Leute, das heißt natürlich wieder dieses Gefühl, ich kenne Leute, die sagen das und das und deswegen schließe ich darauf, dass das allen so geht. Aber das ist das, was ich sehr häufig gehört habe, dass einfach der Dual-Monitor-Support bei Mcmini eigentlich so die große Spaßbremse ist. Weil, wie viele Leute wollen sich das Teil als Fernseherbespielungs-Device hinstellen?
Ich, ich, ich, ich. Aber unter aller Bedingung ehrlich gesagt.
Du kannst auf so einem Scheiß-Fernseher dieses Gerät nicht bedienen. Und du willst eigentlich noch einen Computermonitor anschließen, der dann vielleicht noch ein paar Meter weiter zur Seite geht, wo du es irgendwie an deinem Schreibtisch hast, sodass ihn auch als normalen Computer benutzen kannst. Weil, benutzt das Teil ja fast selten genug. Also fast, fast nie, mein ich. Guckst du halt mal einen Film an, na und dann? Guckst du ja nicht gleich wieder den nächsten? Okay, wenn du so eine totale Couch-Potato bist.
Du meinst eigentlich braucht man gar kein Mcmini?
Na, es macht schon Sinn einen zu haben. Aber ihn nur dafür zu haben, auf dem Fernseher Filme anzuzeigen, ist dann doch ein bisschen übertrieben.
Aber ist doch eine schöne Lungtastatur dazu und dann so von der Couch aus.
Ich hab's ausprobiert, es sieht scheiße aus. Ja, weil dafür bist du dann wieder nicht nahe genug dran. Du hast natürlich auch nicht die Schärfe, die jetzt so ein richtiger Computermonitor hat.
Schade.
Das ist das, warum diese Computermonitore so teuer sind, wenn sie groß sind.
Weißt du, was ich mir auf der CeBit habe zeigen lassen, kurz?
CeBit war ja auch noch.
CeBit war auch noch.
Hat das was mit den neuen Macs zu tun?
Das hat nichts mit den neuen Macs zu tun. Dann lassen wir uns erstmal über die Macs reden.
Ja, dann merkt ihr das mal kurz. Dann bleiben wir vielleicht einfach mal ausnahmsweise beim Thema gleich.
Na gut.
Und schließen das mal ab. Also, zwei Monitore finde ich super. Interessant finde ich, dass sie dann nicht zweimal Mini DisplayPort genommen haben, sondern dass sie sozusagen noch den alten DVI mit drin haben. Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, bedeutet das... Wie bedeutet das?
Herr Lehrer, ich weiß es.
Na?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Du weißt es nicht?
Nein.
Na was hat denn der Mac Mini, der Mini DVI, was der Mini DisplayPort nicht hat?
Analogsignal.
Genau, da kommt noch Video raus.
Nicht unbedingt.
Aber es ist so beim Mac Mini.
Weiß ich nicht. Aber man muss es ja nicht ausführen.
Doch, aber ich glaube, das ist der Grund. Und dann kannst du es nämlich auch noch an so ganz... wollen Fernseher anschließen. Ich glaube, ich hab's sogar gelesen, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich hab's nicht gedouble-checkt. Oh, der Chat meint, es wäre nicht so. Sicher? Ach, das macht der Nvidia-Stein natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr, ne? Echt nicht? Das ist mal... Gut, dass wir einen Chat haben.
Aber man kann dann auch alte Monitore anschließen, die nur DVI haben.
Na ja, aber dann hätten sie auch noch Mini DisplayPort nehmen können, zwei Stück. Dann ist es nicht so ganz so schlüssig. Das wäre jetzt der einzige Grund gewesen, warum, weil ich meine, was ist denn da sonst schon noch mit dabei? Na, das hätten sie sogar mit einem Mini DisplayPort. Also das ist ein sehr hoferen...
Rückwärtskompatibilität.
Zu alten Adaptern, wo sie eigentlich sonst immer drauf scheißen, macht ja alles keinen Sinn. Wie auch immer. Ich habe auf jeden Fall mal nachgerechnet, wenn man so ein Mini sich kauft mit einem ordentlichen Monitor, mit diesem 24 Zoller, da kann man auch gleich einen iMac nehmen. Das ist auch wahrscheinlich das, was ich tun werde. Weil ein iMac hat ja dann auch noch einen Ausgang, wo man sich dann sehr anschließen kann. Was es aber nicht gibt, sind lange Mini... Also es gibt sowieso überhaupt... Also einen Mini Display Kabel in Lang kaufen. Das ist mir noch nicht gelungen.
Also weißt du irgendwo...
Ja, ein Kabel, das du auf einen Mini Display Port anschließt. Ich kaufe ja auch keinen, bevor ich nicht das anschließen kann, was ich anschließen möchte. Ich hab mal nach langen Kabeln geguckt, ob irgendwo... Naja, ich meine, wenn, dann will man das ja auch anschließen können. Und dann 10 Meter hab ich nicht gefunden, nur in den USA. Und dann auch nur Display Port, nicht Mini Display Port. Also das ist alles irgendwie noch ein bisschen huschig. Wie auch immer. Das Thema trägt, glaube ich, nicht ausreichend. Hab ich mir noch irgendwas... Ja, MacBook Pro ist auch noch ein bisschen schneller geworden. Mac Pro ist auch noch irgendwie schneller geworden.
Die 15 soll aber ein bisschen gespeedbumpen.
Ja, aber das ist alles irgendwie nicht so spannend. Genau, ein bisschen gespeedbumpt. Aber das macht das irgendwas aus mir, ne?
Von 253 auf 266 oder so was. Und den Großen von 28 auf 293.
Oh, was ging bei dem neuen, was hab ich jetzt vergessen? Wie auch immer. Was ich dann schon sehr viel interessanter fand... Achso, jetzt wolltest du von der HTC mitreden, ne?
Ja, und zwar, es gibt von Asus, die in letzter Zeit alles IEI nennen, weil sie mit diesen kleinen Networks irgendwann mal Erfolg hatten, haben die als Prototyp vorgestellt, soll wohl noch dieses Jahr tatsächlich rauskommen. So eine kleine Tastatur, die so, echt ganz schick aussieht, so eine Alu-Tastatur, so ungefähr so groß wie so eine Mac-Tastatur auch, hat rechts so ein iPhone-großes Display, was ein Touchscreen ist, wo man so die wesentlichen Bedienelemente drauf hat.
Was sind denn die wesentlichen Bedienelemente? Eine Maustaste?
Nee, du hast quasi ein kleines iPhone-Nesgis-Interface da drauf und dann setzt du einen kleinen Funkadapter auf den Monitorausgang und der schickt angeblich ein HDMI-Signal auf dein Fernsehen. Das heißt, du hast auf deinem Schoß mit Akku drin und einem Pipapo hast du einen Computer, den kompletten Computer, in Form einer Tastatur, mit einem kleinen Touchscreen noch drin, damit du nicht jedes Mal auf einem Bildschirm ein großes Interface brauchst.
Ist ja wie beim 64er dann.
Und dann HDMI.
Genau, und dann soll dann ein Funk-Signal rauskommen. Ich glaube nicht, dass die ein HDMI hinkriegen. Bisher gibt es den nur in Alu, also die Produkttypen gibt es nur in Alu. Aber das fiel mir in dem Zusammenhang ein. Das war so ein Gerät, was ich mir relativ okay vorstellen könnte zum Rumsurfen.
Und wie fandest du die Cebit ansonsten? Die war ja auch... Nächstes Thema.
Ich war auch ganz kurz dran, mir ging es eh nicht.
Ja, es war furchtbar, oder? Vor allem, ich habe noch nie so viel Leere gesehen. Inhaltlich war es recht leer und die Hallen waren ja so leer, die war alles so zusammengekürzt. Das war wirklich traurig. Diese Platzhalter, Blumenkübel, die überall rum standen. Hier hätte ihr stand sein können.
Man hätte auch denken können, das wäre eine Tapetenausstellung sein könnte.
Genau, und so Hallen in der Mitte mit so einer Baustellenwand zugezimmert.
Und auf dem Messeplan, der so verteilt wurde am Eingang, das ist, also nicht die, die an den Gebäuden dranhängen, aber so am Eingang, da wurden komplette Hallen einfach nicht eingezeichnet. Ich nehme an, um die Lehre nicht ganz so erscheinen zu lassen. Also man ist an einer Halle vorbeigegangen, die laut Messeplan überhaupt nicht existierte.
Die CeBit. Lass mir die CeBit sein, das führt glaube ich nirgendswo hin.
Aber ich hatte das erste Mal einen eigenen Zettel-Messerstand auf der CeBit mit meiner kleinen Firma Etnation.
Ah, es gab noch ein Hardware-Update, was ich ein bisschen toller fand. Und zwar gibt es ja auch ein Update für die Time-Capsule. Und das fand ich wirklich knifflig, äh pfiffig.
Mit dem Gäste-Access und Dual-Hill und so. Sicher?
Du meinst hier in der letzten Sendung? Nein, da gab es das alles noch nicht.
Echt?
Nee, das kam ja alles zeitgleich raus.
Dann gab es auch nicht die neue Tastatur? Mit Kabel, aber trotzdem so klein wie das?
Ja, die gibt es auch noch nicht.
Mittlerweile gibt es sie, aber die gab es damals noch nicht.
So gab es alles noch nicht. Ja stimmt, die kleine Tastatur, auch noch sehr nett. Aber bei der Time Capsule, ich meine mit dem Dual Band, das ist echt cool. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt sozusagen zwei separate WLAN-Steine da drin, die halt zwei Netze machen.
Kannst du N und G gleichzeitig oder wie?
Du kannst halt N und G gleichzeitig machen. Und jetzt habe ich es nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden, was das bedeutet. Man kann dann aber auch, also man kann sowohl N und G gleichzeitig machen und man heißt es aber, dass das N dann das eine und G das andere ist. Das heißt, das Public-Netz ist dann sozusagen nur G oder kann er dasselbe, auch kann er dasselbe Netz auch auf G und auf N gleichzeitig machen?
Also so Gästenetze ist ja, ich habe so einen kleinen Phon, so eine kleine Phonbox, falls ihr die kennt, von Nero oder wie die Dinger heißen und die kann auch Gästenetze, also ich glaube, das ist... Aber nun...
Indem er ein zweites logisches Netz auf demselben Funk-Kanal anbietet.
Genau.
Ja, das ist eigentlich auch ein cooles Feature, weil wenn man das dann nämlich intern dann auch korrekt trennt und hier ist es ja so, dass du dann sozusagen einen Internet-only-Zugang machst, der halt nicht ins lokale Netz kommt.
Also bei denen geht das sogar dann so weit, dass die Verbindung dann über einen zentralen Server von denen läuft. Also erst mal, die haben ja sowieso diesen Public Access. Naja, damit du nicht haftbar bist, falls da jemand draufgeht und jetzt zum Beispiel Kinder-Porno runterlädt, dann wirst du ja plötzlich dafür haftbar, wenn das über deinen Anschluss geht.
Ach, da machen die sozusagen noch so einen VPN, oder was?
Da ist so ein VPN drin, das kommt mit deinem Netz gar nicht in Berührung, du bist plötzlich nicht mehr... Könnte man mal ausprobieren, ob man darüber reingehen kann und deinen Spotify-Account kriegt? Spotify, kennt ihr das?
Hab ich.
Das ist so eine ganz hübsche Musik, die ich gestern ein paar Invitations für verteilt. Und die sind... Das funktioniert in Deutschland nicht wegen GEMA und weiß ja toll, was sie noch nicht die entsprechenden Verträge abgeschlossen haben. Man braucht dafür eine englische IP oder ich glaube eine spanische IP geht auch, oder eine amerikanische. Nicht schwedische, aber spanisch geht auch nicht. Auf jeden Fall müsste man gucken, was man dann behauptet.
Man hat einen VPN. Auf jeden Fall gibt es noch ein zweites interessantes Feature, nämlich dass sie auch Back to my Mac, also Mobile Me, IPv6, PrivatVPN unterstützen.
Also du kannst auf deine Time Capsule von außen zugreifen, oder wie sehe ich das?
Von außen zugreifen kannst du ja auch jetzt schon. Du kannst ja den Zugriff auf die externe Platte oder auf die Platte freischalten.
Nach ins World Wide Internet?
Ja, denke ich schon, oder geht das nicht? Auf jeden Fall ging das nicht über Mobile Me. Warte mal, ich gucke gerade mal auf meinem Device. Jetzt bin ich mich gerade etwas verwirrt. Ich habe das ja hier alles im Netz. Auf jeden Fall geht das jetzt halt mit Mobile Me. Das heißt, die Time Capsule lockt sich irgendwie ein und announce das eben auch über dieses globale Bonjour. Wide Area Network Bonjour. Und wenn du dich dann halt dahin verbindest, machen sie halt so einen IPv6-basierten Tunnel auf. Also so funktioniert das heute jetzt auch schon mit Macs, um dann eben Falscherungen zu machen. Sprich und mit Kerberos-Verschlüsseln. Die machen einen riesen Aufwand, also wenn du über Mobile Me auf deine maximal fünf Devices zugreifst, per Falschering, dann ist das durch und durch verschlüsselt. Und das Ganze auch noch via IPv6. Also zumindest in einem Direktverbund. Und dann eben entsprechend noch getunnelt über IPv4, weil ja normalerweise nichts anderes da ist. So, guck ich mal kurz hier. File, ah Mann, jetzt hab ich hier die falsche Tasse geklickt. Sag doch mal was.
Ich bin hier gerade dabei, Hörern zu helfen.
Hörern?
Hörern zu helfen, die den Stream nicht auf dem iPhone hören können.
Du machst Support während der Sendung?
Ja, ich meine danach hilft nichts viel, oder? Dann können sie den Stream ja nicht mehr hören.
Ja genau, ShareDiscs over Warn, wusste ich doch. Und auch über Bonjour. Also das Bonjour-Feature und das irgendwie im Netz die Platten anbieten ist in dem Sinne nicht neu. Neu ist nur, dass das eben in Mobami integriert ist. Naja, fand ich auf jeden Fall toll.
Die Express ist ja auch neu, ne? Also die Time Capsule und die Express.
Also die Express finde ich ja Time Capsule, reißt mich ja nach.
Die Airport Extreme, die kann das auch. Genau, das gilt nicht nur dafür. Richtig.
Und Software-Updates sind ja auch rausgekommen dafür. Also Firmware-Updates und für die Express auch.
Genau.
Hat sich noch nichts geändert an der Express eigentlich?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also Mobile Mi habe ich jetzt halt auch bei meiner Time Capsule. Das ist sozusagen nicht nur für die neuen. Die neue hat halt nur diese Sachen mit dem Gastnetwork und so weiter. Fände ich mal ganz interessant. Muss mal gucken, ob die jetzt irgendwie 64-Bit-HFS unterstützt, dass man da wieder mal größer als zwei Terabyte-Volumes erinnert. Das ziehe ich noch an die Diskussion mit dem komischen Teil. Mal gucken.
War man nicht erstmal noch bei Hardware? Waren die Mac Pros nicht auch neu?
Die waren neu, aber gibt es auch viel zu erzählen?
Die haben jetzt noch mehr Kerne, oder?
Die haben jetzt schon diesen neuen Nehalem, die abgehen wie Schmitzkatze.
Ist das so? Warst du da?
Nee. Aber alle sagen es ist scheiße schnell. Also die hat ja Apple nicht viel mit zu tun, sondern es sind halt die Intel-Chips. Und die ist schon nochmal wieder eine neue Liga. Ist so wie damals. Warst du von Pentium 4 nach Core? Ging's ja, oder? Und das ist jetzt wieder so ein großer Schritt. Also ist nicht so von Core nach Core 2 Du oder so ein bisschen Upgrade, sondern es ist wieder so richtig.
Eine neue generelle Architektur. Ja stimmt, die sind ja auch von der Taktrate her gar nicht so unterschiedlich. Da hat sich nicht so viel getan.
Sie haben jetzt ihren eigenen Memory-Controller mit onboard, was die vorher mal extern hatten, was bei AMD schon seit langer Zeit ist. Deswegen war AMD wohl im Memory-Bereich immer viel schneller. Und das haben die bei Intel jetzt auch. Und das rockt noch mal richtig. Und die, was früher mal so ein bisschen belächelt wurde, weil es nicht so richtig was gebracht hat, dieses Hyper-Threading. Bei FreeBearStick, kann ich mich erinnern, hieß es früher gar nicht erst einschalten, weil es geht eher in die Hose. Also es ist nicht wirklich schneller, sondern eventuell so eher langsamer. Das haben die jetzt wieder eingeführt, weil es gab es ja mit Core und Core 2.0 nicht. Es ist jetzt wieder da. Das heißt, diese Mac Pros, die zweimal Quad haben, also acht CPUs, haben dann auch noch Hyper-Threading, das heißt 16 logische CPUs. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie Apple das hier im Dock mit dem Activity-Monitor macht.
Wie soll das hier oben bei iStatMenu gehen? Da braucht man ja wirklich ein 40 Zoll Display nur in den ganzen Prozessoren anzuzeigen.
Deswegen verkaufen wir jetzt diese großen Bildschirme, weil man das CPU-Meter draufkriegt.
Ja, habe ich echt noch nicht gesehen. Also, die soll richtig flott sein.
Es ist eine Zeit für Snow Leopard. Aber richtig.
Da gibt es ja auch einen neuen Bild. Aber gibt es nicht noch mehr Hardware? Nee, jetzt kommt Software, ne?
Ich gucke mal. Hardware, Hardware, Hardware...
Ja doch, iPod Nano. Oder wie heißt das Ding?
Was?
Ach, iPod Shuffle.
Hab ich vergessen aufzuschreiben. Guter Hinweis. Und?
Das ist jetzt so wie bei MacBook Pro. Sie haben schon wieder die Tasten weggespart. Keine Tasten mehr.
Bei MacBook Pro?
Das ist ja lustig.
Ich hab keinen Maus-Button mehr.
Ach so, stimmt.
Als ich das Ding das erste Mal gesehen habe, hab ich da oben diesen Schiebereler gesehen und hab gedacht, ah, das wird der Hold-Button sein. Bis ich dann irgendwann drauf gekommen bin. Der hat keinen Hold-Button mehr, weil das ist ja die einzige Taste, die er hat. Das versteht keiner, oder? Da oben ist ein Taste, so ein Schiebeding.
Ja, damit macht man den Repeat-Shuffle-Modus, oder nicht?
Ja, aber ich dachte zuerst, das wäre also Intuition so, ah, das wird der Hold-Button sein. Mit dem man Tasten-Sperre macht.
Man kann auch keinen Hold-Button verstehen.
Ohne Tasten braucht man auch keine zu sperren. Okay, Entschuldigung. Ich dachte, ihr seid die beiden, die so wenig geschlafen haben. Ja, also sehr interessant, nicht wahr? Mit dem Audio-Interface. Keine Ahnung, ob das die Leute annehmen werden.
So wichtig toll hat sich das nicht angehört.
Ausreichend. Aber immerhin, jetzt gibt es Podcast-Support auf den Dingern, das gab es vorher nicht. Und weil du jetzt explizit da auch so eine Podcast-Playlist machen kannst?
Kann man jetzt eventuell in QuickTime sein eigenes Titel-Audiostück hinterlegen, damit die das dann beim Vorsprechen benutzen können? Damit die das nicht mit ihrer generischen Software erzeugen müssen? Dass du sozusagen im QuickTime speichern kannst, das ist, oder relativ kurz halt, Mobile Max 24, zack, und der das halt abspielt und nicht irgendwie Mobile Max 24.
Der spricht ja nur die Playlist-Namen. Ah ne, und die Titel. Du meinst, dass ich jetzt sozusagen nochmal eine Annotation für ein File, nochmal einen Extra-Titel selber gesprochen?
Könnte man eine tolle Website machen, wo man sich dann automatisch iTunes runterladen könnte, so User Contributed Titel-Ansage.
Da muss der das nicht machen, weil das hört sich ja nun wirklich nicht so doll an, was die da so als Sample hatten. Und ich meine, du musst dir vorstellen, was die da als Sample hatten, ist das wahrscheinlich schon das Coolste, was sie hingekriegt haben.
Ich bezweifle, dass euch Funktionalität möglich ist, aber man weiß es ja nicht.
Eigentlich wäre das relativ easy, aber ich glaube nicht, dass Apple sowas macht.
Nee, wir halten das erstmal ganz einfach und dass sie überhaupt jetzt Podcast-Support auf den Shuffle draufgepackt haben, finde ich ja ganz gut, ob das dann benutzbar ist. Steht natürlich nochmal auf einem ganz anderen Blatt.
Klaus Kinski als iPod-Shuffle-Stimme wäre tatsächlich großartig, wie es der Evel gerade vorschlägt. Klaus Kinski als iPod-Shuffles-Stimme. Wie war das bei diesem Amazon Kindle? Der kann auch jetzt auch vorlesen. Da haben sie auch den Schauspieler rausgesucht, dessen Stimme das ist. Der hat wohl so einen merkwürdigen Akzent.
Schauspieler?
Das ist so ein Schauspieler oder Sprecher, den sie da synthetisiert haben.
Wirklich?
Sie haben sich eine eigene Stimme dafür entwickelt. Ansonsten ist das glaube ich auch komplett. Ich würde gerne mal hören, wie das bei dem Kindle klingt, aber ein Buch möchte ich mir nicht so hören müssen.
Also mit automatisch generierter Sprache ist es so eine Sache. Diese Alex-Stimme, die klingt schon ganz gut, aber längere Texte würde ich mir davon nicht vorlesen lassen wollen. Für Blinde ist das was anderes, da mag das wunderbar funktionieren, aber wenn ich darauf verzichten kann, aber das muss man ja hier auch gar nicht. Er liest einem die Sachen vor und das war's eigentlich.
Aber ich finde das erstaunlich, wie bei synthetischer Stimme in den letzten Jahren für Kinofilme gar nichts passiert ist. Also relativ wenig, man sieht, was an visuellen Effekten alles dazugekommen ist.
Wie meinst du, dass wenig passiert?
Naja, ich meine, komplette 3D-Filme ohne Schauspieler, wo sie die Schauspieler einscannen und die Mimik nachbilden und den in jedem Alter nachbilden können. Optisch geht es unglaublich viel, aber bei Geräusch machen sie immer noch Boiyo Boiyo.
Naja, Alex klingt schon ziemlich gut.
Der klingt nicht schlecht, aber...
Na, da haben sie wirklich eine ganze Menge Sachen drin. Der holt ja sogar Luft und macht irgendwie richtigen Sprachpausen und so.
Der holt Luft?
Also die haben schon sehr viel da reingesteckt. Und so eine gute Stimme zu entwickeln ist teuer.
Nein, ohne Frage, aber...
Deswegen haben sie davon auch nicht so viele. Man kann ja auch Stimmen kaufen, in Mac. Also es gibt professionelle Stimmenanbieter. Ich hatte mir auch schon mal ein paar runtergeladen, aber leider ein bisschen wenig Zeit gehabt, die wirklich... Das ist nicht Alex.
Ach so, du spielst Musik ab.
Das ist Sam, oder was?
Ich nehme an, das ist irgendwie...
Ich glaube, das ist diese Default-Mac-and-Talk-Stimme, diese ganz alte. Und das ist auch OK-Computer.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist sogar Sam. Das ist der Sound-Synthesizer auf dem C64.
Nee, nee, das ist Mac. Ich hab's mal nachgebaut. Ich hab mal den Text abgetippt von dem Song und hab den mitsprechen lassen. Das ist eindeutig die Mac-Stimme.
Na, da hat sich doch eine ganze Menge getan.
Es war Fitter Happier von Radiohead, genau.
Großartiges Album.
Jetzt müssen wir GEMA zahlen, Scheiße.
Hammer, oder?
GEMA oder OK-Computer?
Oder Radiohead?
OK-Computer, ich hab das ja zu Hause als Original.
Hab ich noch nicht so viel gehört. Bist du das?
Das kann ich gut unterstützen.
Wir müssen legitimer einwandern. Es gibt noch zu den Stimmen. Also man kann Stimmenpakete kaufen für ein Mac und es gibt auch deutsche Stimmen. Weil das Problem von Alex ist ja, der ist schon festgelegt auf englische Sprechweise. Die Stimme ist ja nicht nur der Klang, sondern eben auch wie gesprochen wird und du brauchst eben für einzelne Stimmen die Sache. Deswegen frage ich mich, da sie ja jetzt so einen umfangreichen Sprachsupport haben beim iPod Shuffle, weil sie können ja nicht alles auf Englisch vorlesen.
Sie scheinen es ja hingekriegt.
Wo diese Stimmen herkommen, weil die müssen ja in dem iTunes irgendwie drin sein. Andererseits benutzen sie ja offensichtlich schon auch die Fähigkeit der Stimmen auf dem Mac, zumindest für Englisch. Und da stelle ich jetzt mal. Also es gibt ja diese Beispiele auf der Webseite. Ich vermute, dass es so läuft. Auf dem Mac nimmt das iTunes Alex für Englisch. Ob sie auch für alle anderen Sprachen Englisch nehmen, weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, weiß man nicht. Oder sie haben halt für diesen einen Zweck sich das lizenzieren lassen und das liegt dann irgendwo rum. Aber glaube ich auch nicht, weil Alex ist auch verdammt groß. Das ist eine riesen Datei. Davon können sie nicht mal eben nochmal 100 nachinstallieren. Das funktioniert nicht. Weiß nicht, wie groß die ist, aber die war irgendwie verdammt groß.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall erstaunlich, dass sie unter Windows eine andere Stimme haben.
Weil sie da halt kein Alex haben.
Warum nicht?
Weil es da kein Mac OS X gibt mit der Sprachsynthese.
Ja, aber können die nicht so einen Sprach... Ist das so komplex?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach eine Lizenzgeschichte. Und das ist natürlich auch dieser Wink mit dem Soundfall. Wenn du möchtest, dass es gut klingt, dann kauf dir doch ein Mac.
Vielleicht hat das wirklich was mit der Größe zu tun, weil iTunes ist ja mittlerweile gar nicht mehr, wenn du dir so einen Shuffle kaufst und hast ja gar keine CD mehr dabei. Und wenn du dann erst mal so einen 200 Megabyte Download nur für iTunes anschmeißen musst...
I don't know.
Also das finde ich auf jeden Fall...
Ich suche gerade die Stimme. Wo liegt die denn? System Library...
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, der alte Shuffle hat mir besser gefallen. Ich fand den alten Shuffle richtig schick. Ich hab mir den mal überlegt, mir einen zuzulegen, bloß weil es... bloß weil ich...
Der ganz alte?
Nee, nicht der ganz alte, der jetzt...
Ich fand den ersten geil.
Ich hab doch ein iPhone.
Also hier, Alex... Alex, also die größte Stimme, die nicht Alex ist bei Mac OS X, ist Vicky und Vicky wiegt 28 Megabyte.
Und Alex?
Alex hat 670 Megabyte.
670, wow.
Da sieht man mal, was da drin steckt.
Das kann man bestimmt nicht gut komprimieren.
Interessanterweise ist das eine einzige Datei, die den Namen PCM-Wave trägt.
Ich kann 600 MB jetzt löschen...
Du kannst 670 MB löschen und darfst dir dann aber keinen iPhone Shuffle mehr kaufen.
Das ist die Datei, das wollen bestimmt viele Leute wissen.
Das ist in Slash-System, Slash-Speech, Slash-Voices und dann sind sie da alle. Alex.Speech-Voice heißt das.
Da würde ich doch eher mal empfehlen, die überflüssigen Garageband Loops empfehlen.
Es gibt ne Menge, die knallen mit 4 GB rein.
CD-System und dann Library und dann Speech, okay. Und dann Voices. Und dann Alex.
Das ist ein Gigabyte.
Und dann Contents, uiuiuiui. Ach und dann ist hier...
Und dann von meinem Du-H.
Ja ich weiss.
Ach, so eine große Datei. Du löschst aber auch manche Sachen so ein bisschen aus Prinzip, oder?
Nein, Quatsch, Mann.
Aber man könnte die mal mit BZ packen.
Ach ja, der Shuffle. Das ist ein sehr gewagtes Marketing. Find's erstaunlich. Ich hab ja keine Ahnung, wie gut sich das Ding verkauft, aber soweit ich mich erinnere, lief der immer sehr gut.
Ist ja doch der billigste gewesen, oder?
Der billigste ist vor allem so der Sport-iPod. Das ist so das Ding, was wirklich keinerlei zusätzliches, also kein nennenswertes zusätzliches Gewicht mehr dazu bringt. So kein Armband ranmachen und so, klippst du halt einfach an und jetzt ist es halt noch einfacher, ran zu klippen. Ich hab jemanden zum Geburtstag einen iPod Nano mit diesem Nike-Jogging-Klimb mal gekauft. Das funktioniert offensichtlich. Ich hatte leider nicht sehr viel Zeit, ihm dann dabei zuzuschauen, wie er das alles in Betrieb nimmt und benutzt. Aber ich hab mal so selber da so das Setup gemacht. Steckst dann halt an den Nano unten so ein kleines Ding ins Dock, so diesen Funk-Kram. Beim Touch ist das ja irgendwie jetzt auch schon mit drin eingebaut.
Beim Nano hab ich mir das damals auch gekauft.
Ja? Achso, und hast du das auch mal benutzt?
Ich wollte es eigentlich zum Fahrradfahren haben, dafür geht es aber leider überhaupt nicht.
Nee, da musst du schon laufen.
Ich hab es mal irgendwie mit dem Laufen ausprobiert, aber so richtig angetan.
Also ein Fahrrad ja schieben.
Stimmt, das ist eine Option. Ich hätte ja sagen können, dass die Bewegung ähnlich genug ist, dass wenn man sich das an den Schuh klemmt, dass man dann einfach sagt, ich mach einfach viel größere Schritte, und dass es dann auch beim Fahrradfahren geht. Weil ich ja nun sehr viel Rad fahre, aber das geht leider überhaupt nicht.
Der braucht wahrscheinlich da die, keine Ahnung, das ist eine andere Bewegung, das ist halt die ganze Zeit eine Kreisbewegung, anstatt so eine Null-Bewegung.
Wahrscheinlich macht er einfach so dieses Aufklatschen, wenn man mit dem Fuß auf dem Boden auftritt, dass er das als Takt-Signal nimmt für einen Schritt oder so was.
Dass er sich halt nicht bewegt. Oder kaum.
Oder extrem schnell abbremst.
Oder das. Das ist eine interessante Frage, wir haben ja so viele Gedanken drüber gemacht. Naja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist der neue Shuffle noch minimalisierter. Und dass sie das wirklich mit Speech probieren, das finde ich ehrlich gesagt mutig. Wirklich, wirklich mutig.
Ja, also das ist diese komplette Steuerung darüber. Finde ich auch ein bisschen.
Ich finde es mutig. Aber ich muss sagen, so rein jetzt vom wie häufig wechselst du eine Playlist und so. Und so hast du halt wirklich, aber es gibt eine Sache, da habe ich ein bisschen geweint. Da habe ich ein bisschen da gesessen und geweint. Weil sie eine Idee zerstört haben von mir, ein Traum. Ich versuche ja schon seit drei Monaten einen längeren Blog-Eintrag zu schreiben. Es gelingt mir einfach nicht. Ich hoffe, ich nicht die Ruhe dafür finde. Zum Thema, wie sie das mal mit dem Podcasting machen sollten. Ich habe irgendwie alles gesammelt, was mir schon immer eingefallen ist. Und eins der Features, die ich unbedingt haben wollte, ist, dass wenn man mit dem iPod hört und man hat halt diese Taste, du weißt schon, die Taste, die man einmal drückt für den nächsten Track, zweimal drückt, um, ähm, nee, einmal, entschuldigung, einmal drückt, um... Für Pause? Für Pause und wieder weitermachen, zweimal drückt, um weiterzugehen, dreimal drücken, um zum letzten Track zurückzukommen.
Um wieder anzufangen.
Genau. Und ich dachte mir halt, man könnte diese Geste lange gedrückt halten. Also, weil das tut jetzt das sorgt dafür, dass du dann halt diese Playliste vorgelesen bekommst, nicht so ganz verstanden, aber auf jeden Fall benutzen sie das jetzt. Dass man das verwenden kann, um eine Marke zu setzen in einem Podcast, den man gerade anhört. Ja, viermal klicken. Klar, man könnte sich jetzt alles Mögliche einlegen, aber das wäre sozusagen so immediate. Ich drücke drauf, genau an der Stelle, verliere keine weitere Zeit und kann auch weiter zuhören, weil viermal klicken, da muss man schon irgendwie bis vier zählen. Das ist ein bisschen zu viel. Ja, dann drückst du nur dreimal, dann spult er zurück und so.
Einfach lange festhalten?
Ja, das dachte ich eben. Einfach lange festhalten und dann macht's so, so ähnlich wie du normalerweise auf dem Autoradio deinen UKW-Sender programmierst. Haben sie ja mittlerweile auch drauf geeinigt. Du hast irgendeinen Sender, willst den abspeichern, drückst du einfach lange auf die Speichertaste. Und genauso hätte ich das auch gut gefunden, dass man dann, ist das nicht sogar auch schon irgendwie belegt gewesen? Haben sie nicht sogar so was, macht man nicht damit seine To-Go-Playlist? Ist das, aha, wie passt denn das dann zusammen? Na wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, ich hätte gerne so ein Feature, wo ich eben sagen kann, mach mir hier mal irgendeine Stelle, markier mir mal was.
Lange gedrückt halten auf einem iPad, auf einem klassischen iPod?
Ja, ich bin jetzt selber gerade am zweifeln, ob das nicht sogar schon belegt war und diese To-Go-Playlist ist.
Und ich glaube jetzt ist es doch Genius-Modus, oder?
Oh Gott.
Was? Auf dem iPod?
Wir haben doch den Genius-Modus auf dem iPod. Auf dem klassischen, nicht nur auf dem iPhone. Wo er diese Playlist zusammenstellt.
Ich dachte, das gibt es nur in iTunes.
Nee, das hast du doch auf dem iPhone. Wusstest du dir gar nicht? Es gibt ja auf dem iPhone einen kleinen Button, wenn man einen Song anhört, da ist so ein kleines Genius-Icon, dieses Atom, was vom Rest der Welt als Atomkern wahrgenommen wird.
Bei Musik oder irgendwie auch bei...?
Während du Musik hörst.
Stimmt, es gibt eine Genius-Liste hier.
Nee, du kannst auch während du Musik hörst, ich mach das ganz gerne mal, du fängst an mit einem Musikstück, was du magst oder worauf du Lust hast. Und während das läuft, drückst du kurz den Genius-Button und dann stellt er die Playlist zusammen auf der Basis.
Auf dieses Atom-Ding? Aha, zu diesem Titel gibt es nicht genug ähnliche Titel zum Erstellen einer geniusen Wiedergabeliste. Oh Mann.
Das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, was du jetzt ausgewählt hast.
Kinderlieder. Aber ich hab hier fast nur Kinderlieder gerade drauf.
Achso.
Der Kippo-Rate kommt. Nein.
Bloß nicht.
Aber nachher.
Den Teufels mit Küche bringst du uns hier. Okay, gut, hab ich verstanden.
Also, iPod Shuffle ist jetzt tatsächlich fast komplett tastenlos. Ich glaube, das ist die job-feuchte Traum.
Die meisten sind meiner Meinung nach da, wo sie hingehören. Weil dieses Ganze mit Fernbedienung dran klatschen und so, das war immer alles so ein bisschen mau. Jetzt gibt es wenigstens eine einzige Stelle, wo das ist. Große Frage ist, wird es jetzt relativ bald Side-Party-Devices geben, die dieses User-Interface auch für andere Kopfhörer machen? Weil das ist für manche sicherlich recht wichtig.
Ja, wobei ich hab mir ehrlich gesagt, ich hab mir das, also schön wär's natürlich schon, aber es gab ja Leute, die dann gesagt haben, jetzt kauf ich mir mal keinen iPod-Shuffle, weil ich da meine Third-Party-Kopfhörer nicht mehr drankriege. Ich glaube, wer sich bessere Kopfhörer zulegt für sein iPod, hat eh keinen iPod-Shuffle, oder? Also das ist doch eher so ein Ding, was man so nämlich meint.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich bin immer wieder überrascht, wie viele Leute doch einfach so die Standard-Kopfhörer verwenden, aber bei mir passen die einfach nicht ins Ohr. Also mir tun die weh. Das ist das Problem.
Also ich bin mit dem eigentlich relativ okay, mit dem normalen Kopfhörer.
Ich kann den nicht benutzen, wenn ich die in mein Ohr reinstecke, das tut dann nach 5 Minuten weh.
Also ich hatte so Sennheiser mir geholt, noch ein zweites Mal und die muss ich nochmal umtauschen, weil die sind wirklich nach nicht mal einem Monat kaputt gegangen. Das ist sagenhaft, also bei normaler Benutzung.
Also mit den Kopfhörern glaube ich so wie mit Radfahren. Wenn du lange nicht gefahren bist, tut der erstmal der Arschloch.
Du meinst, ich muss einfach durchhalten?
Als ich damals WoW gespielt habe, hatte ich mir auch so ein Headset gekauft wegen Teamspeak und das ganze Zeug und so. Und dann hat mir der erste WoW auch immer irgendwie meine Ohren wehgetan und so. Und das ist ja erstmal empfindlich, weil normalerweise ist ja in meinen Ohren irgendwie nichts dran und dann war da immer ein Kopfhörer drauf und aber es war nach einer Woche dann weg, dann gewinnt man sich da irgendwie dran.
Und ich hab mir jetzt eben gerade keinen Armok-Laufwitz gemacht.
Das ist gut. Hast du keinen Armok-Lauf gemacht?
Armok-Laufwitz gemacht.
Keinen Armok-Laufwitz. Das ist gut, es gibt einfach viele gute Witze, die wir uns heute sparen können. Ist nicht die Zeit dafür. So, jetzt aber weg von der Hardware.
Hardware müssen wir jetzt mal kurz dabei bleiben, weil heute sind ja lustige Bilder aufgetaucht.
Was?
Von?
Ach, stimmt.
Auf einer russischen Website, auf irgendeiner russischen Zeitschrift.
Wir müssen über Romors reden.
Genau, weil die sehen ja auch mal scharf aus. Die sehen scharf aus, oder?
Es gibt einen entscheidenden kleinen Unterschied.
Die Eject-Taste. Also, für alle, die es nicht mitbekommen haben, sollten in diversen Blogs einen MacBook Nano sehen.
Wir werden jetzt zum Romor-Podcast.
Na ja, komm, das ist schon... Das kann man schon mal erwähnen.
Also wir haben alle das Gefühl, das wäre etwas, was wir uns kaufen würden. Stimmt?
Also ich auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube ich nicht. Ich bin tempted. Wenn das Ding USB hat, und das wird es haben, dann würde es haben, wenn es wahr wäre, würde es auch USB haben. Dann, ja.
Gibt es eigentlich bei Apple auf der Seite so ein Button, ich bestelle das nächste, was ihr rausbringt?
Wie auch einmal, gibt es bestimmt.
Aber ist das alles an dem Air?
Na, das ist ein 10, also das Gerücht sagt, dass es sich hierbei um die Abbildung eines sehr flachen, so ähnlich wie das eher gebauten MacBooks handelt, was aber nur 10,5 Zoll Display-Durchmesser hat.
Kenne ich einen, der sich jetzt ärgert?
Mit 1280 x 768. Ich meine, weiß der Geier, ob das stimmt? Das Ding ist nur, üblicherweise haben wir es ja hier mit so einer Photoshop-Geschichte zu tun, das haben wir ja schon tausendmal gesehen. Aber erstens gibt es schon zwei Renderings, die beide irgendwie halbwegs akkurat aussehen.
Die aber beide aus der seinem Zeitraum standen auch.
Ja, gut, aber die dann trotzdem beide eben diese eine Eject-Taste nicht mehr haben, was ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch sinnvoll ist, weil da gibt es einfach nichts mehr. Na gut, es gäbe schon noch Festplatten, aber wenn sie noch nicht mal mehr USB haben, dann gibt es noch nicht mal mehr eine USB.
Also ich meine, es gibt doch irgendwo Bilder von einer Seitenansicht, wo man den USB-Anschluss sieht.
Wenn sich die beiden wieder gibt.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall, sie haben sich relativ viel Mühe gegeben, wirklich das Tastatur-Layout komplett abzuändern, dass es auch halbwegs hinkommt und so. Also ich kann mir natürlich sehr gut vorstellen, dass es einfach ein gelangweilter russischer Grafiker ist, der das gemacht hat.
Auf dieser neuen Wired-Tastatur ist aber noch ein Eject drauf, oder?
Meinst du, dass das daherkommt?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich hab mir die Tastatur noch nicht so genau angeschaut, aber ich hab nichts davon gelesen, dass es weg ist.
Also langweilig, auf jeden Fall.
Das meint, das könnte dann das Apple-Netbook sein, auf das alle warten. Wo Apple sagt, dass sie ja was sich überlegen wollen.
Ja, die Vermutung sagt da auch noch irgendwas von 900 Dollar.
Was ich für das, ich weiß nicht...
Na, im Vergleich zu dem R, was wie... Fast doppelt so teuer ist.
Wäre das also, das ist so... Aber es hätte einen Atom-Prozessor laut.
Das ist das, woran ich so ein bisschen zweifel, weil...
Hab ich zu Hause so einen Atom?
Die sind nicht besonders fix.
Die sind aber okay.
Ich hab so einen Blogpost gelesen, eigentlich nur so quer, wo Benchmarks gemacht wurden auf Netbooks mit Mac OS X. Hast du das auch gelesen?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Und wo sie halt... Aktuelle Netbooks, fragen Sie mich bitte nicht nach den Bezeichnungen, deswegen bin ich jetzt hier auch so ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen.
Die haben ja alle im Wesentlichen in seinem Prozessor.
Die haben ja alle im Wesentlichen in diesen Etern irgendwas.
Genau. Und das haben sie mit dem iBook G4 verglichen. Und die waren halt so ein bisschen schneller als ein iBook G4. Und bei ein paar Sachen doppelt so schnell.
Also ich hab so rein von einem Gefühl her, ich hab das ja, wie gesagt, ich hab ja dieses MSI mit einem Mac OS 10 drauf. Und hat ja dieses MacBook Air mir mal gebesorgt und vom Gefühl her war es nicht deutlich langsamer als ein MacBook Air. Natürlich aus anderen Gründen, also wegen dieser unglaublich kleinen Festplatte, die über jeder Gelegenheit anfängt zu rotieren und wegen dem Prozessor, der so schnell überhitzt beim MacBook Air. Und dann wird ja ein Kern abgeschaltet, was das Ding ja wirklich unerträglich lahm macht. Und wirklich schlechter war das, als das MSI dagegen nicht. Insofern, und es gibt jetzt auch diesen, kommt ja jetzt langsam dieser neue Atom-Prozessor, der ein bisschen schneller ist nochmal, einen höheren Frontside-Bass hat, mit einem höheren Takt.
Es gibt aber sicherlich einige Performance-Dinge, die für Apple sehr wichtig wären, dass die schnell gehen. Da gehört Video-Abspielen dazu. Wenn sie allerdings jetzt auf Nvidia-Steine setzen und die Hardware-Beschleunigung konsequent nutzen, also mit so einem Nvidia-Grafikstein und Snowlapper teilt sozusagen mit der GPU zusammen die Performance-Lücke, die dort zwangsläufig entsteht mit so einem Netbook-Prozessor, wieder auszugleichen, dann würde ich sagen, hat das Ding unter Umständen eine Chance. Aber etwas, was nicht in ihr Medienbespielungsuniversum reinpasst und wo nicht zumindest ein 720p-HD-Video abgespielt werden kann, das glaube ich nicht, dass sie so etwas rausbringen würden. Weil das wäre dann einfach nicht ihr Stil.
Nee, das muss schon gehen.
Das kann nicht so ein Schleicher sein. Das Ding muss dann auch, da will er sich hinstellen und sagen Worlds Fastest, bla, Faselnetbook, hast du nicht gesehen und kann auch das hier, was alle anderen nicht können und da könnte zum Beispiel Video abspielen und dazugehören. Ansonsten sind sie ja durchaus, Achtung, gelungene Überleitung, sind sie ja durchaus im Bereich der Geschwindigkeitsoptimierung unterwegs, unsere Freunde von Apfel.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo diese Überleitung gehen soll.
Zu Safari. Vier hatten wir auch noch nicht.
Hatten wir auch noch nicht.
Nein, das ist Safari. Wir sind so hinterher. Alles ist in diesem Monat passiert. Ja, im Chat man nur, dass jemand alle können 27 Pages...
Also so richtig toll ist dieses Safari 4 nicht.
Ähm, sag mal.
Toller Opener, oder? Erstmal rumranden. Na also dieses hier, wie heißt das? Top Sides hier, es sieht ganz schick aus und ist auch ganz schick gemacht. Da haben sie sich bestimmt schick Mühe gegeben und alles. Brauche ich aber irgendwie nicht, ich weiß nicht. Da kommt also dieses optische Feedback, wo ich eigentlich auch so ein bisschen drauf stehe, ich habe ja nicht umsonst auch einen Apple. Aber irgendwie da, das brauche ich nicht. Und, äh, obwohl ich glaube ich darf gar nicht mitreden, oder als Browser-Typie, der nicht mal...
Sagt doch mal!...
der nicht mal Tabs benutzt darf, ich glaube ich darf gar nichts sagen.
Du benutzt keine Tabs. Du durftest ja gar keine Issues haben bei Safari.
Doch, ich musste die erstmal alle abschalten. Dass die weg sind.
Wie, dass die weg sind?
Na, die Tabs da oben.
Wenn du gar keine aufmachst, dann siehst du doch auch keine. Ach du meinst auch dieser eine, der da schon sich beißt.
Und das, ich meine dieser ProGast Bar, der so im Blau in die hintere Adressleiste kommt. Das war einfach mal die coolste Idee überhaupt. Riesengroß, du siehst es sofort so, weil du klickst irgendwas. Alles klar, es geht, weil da ist ein blaues Stück. Er lädt auf jeden Fall. Aber dieses Drehding da...
Ich stelle mir das zu. Das fehlt mir auch.
Und dann muss ich alles Mögliche umschalten, damit der wieder kommt. Und jetzt sieht mein Safari wieder so aus wie vorher. Das kann man ja machen.
Ja, man kann alles wieder abschalten, dann bist du aber immer noch schneller.
Das habe ich mit WebKit auch. Das ist nicht so das Ding.
Das stimmt.
Und dann, was war noch? Also werde ich jetzt hier diese Address Completion, oder All Completion nennt man es ja, da kommen jetzt nur noch, ich muss mal das kurz machen, da kommen jetzt nur noch 5 irgendwie in der History und 5 irgendwie in... Nee, jetzt kommen sogar nur noch 5 in der History und einer in Top Hit, warum auch immer. Das ist irgendwie ein bisschen wenig. Also vorher kam da die ganze Liste, jetzt zeigt da nur noch 5 an. Also ist ja...
Also ich hab mir das noch nicht so genau angeschaut, wie es sich jetzt so vorher vergleicht, aber ich fand vorher die Completion nicht so gelungen wie jetzt. Also ich kriege jetzt einfach bessere Sachen vorgeschlagen.
Ja, aber dafür auch nicht mehr alle irgendwie.
Also ich hatte am Anfang...
Weil ich benutze hauptsächlich meine History als meine Bookmarks. Ich mache einfach unlimited History. Also einfach alles, wo ich war.
Aber dafür kannst du ja jetzt explizit in der History suchen. Das ging ja vorher nicht. Also du kannst jetzt auch nach Content suchen und nicht nur nach der URL.
Wie, was, wo?
Na wenn du auf die Bookmarks-Seite gehst, also wenn du auf dieses Buchsymbol klickst, dann hast du rechts oben ein neues Suchfeld und kannst jetzt richtig im Content aller Seiten suchen.
Das benutze ich eigentlich nicht. Ich benutze immer halt die Adress.
Jaja, ich verstehe schon, was du meinst. Aber es...
Apfel L, zack, das, was ich weiß, wie es anfängt. Und dann kommen die und dann scroll ich ein bisschen rein.
Ich hätte die Suche nach den besuchten Sachen eigentlich auch lieber rechts oben in dem Feld und nicht nochmal in so einem anderen Feld, weil ich hab's ja auch schon in meinem Standard-Spotlight rechts oben im Prinzip ja auch schon drin. Da tauchen ja auch... der sucht ja auch die Historie. Also es ist alles noch nicht so fertig, glaube ich. Aber das Ding ist ja auch eine Beta. Und ich fand das mit den Tubs sehr mutig, weil in gewisser Hinsicht hatte Google ja recht. Weil Google hat ja angefangen mit Chrome und hat die Tubs nach oben gepackt. Weil, dass die Tubs unterhalb der URL sind, ist eigentlich Quark, weil sie ja Teil der ganzen Sache sind. Und eigentlich ist es wirklich die Top-Level-Ordnung. Dass sie jetzt die Tubs in die Fensterzeile selber mit reingepackt haben, ist natürlich, wie man so schön sagt, ein Bold Move. Der so nur von Apple kommen konnte. Weil man fragt sich natürlich schon, was haben sie im Sinn? Wenn sie nur dieses Konzept von, naja, die Tubs müssen die URL-Zeile mit beeinflussen, dann hätten sie es halt auch einfach nach oben packen können. Und einfach nur über die URL-Zeile. Haben sie aber nicht gemacht, sondern sie packen es oben rein. Und abgesehen davon, dass sie dabei...
Ist ja aber auch sinnig, weil sonst ist der ganze Titel ja irgendwie so ein bisschen vergeben. Und es hätte auch ganz schön scheiße ausgesehen.
Ich finde, es sieht auch so nicht so wirklich umwärts. Ich hab getwittert, ich hab mich auch, glaube ich getwittert, hab mich jahrelang gefragt, warum die Tab-Leiste nicht da oben ist. Jetzt weiß ich es seit Safari 4, weil es scheiße aussieht.
Ich finde, das sieht eigentlich okay aus.
Ich will nur meinen blauen Progress Bar haben.
Es gab irgendwo, irgendeiner meinte, dass das Development Team so durch hat durchsickern lassen, dass sie der Meinung sind, dass heutzutage dieser Progress bei diesen ganzen dynamisch ladenden Seiten sich so nicht mehr...
Da haben sie recht.
Aber ich fand es trotzdem besser.
Der war einfach größer.
Ich muss nicht irgendwie dieses kleine Riechen suchen.
Ja, das ist auch noch so tiny tiny und dann überlagert es sich auch noch mit dem Cancel und Reload-Button an einer Stelle. Also es ist, ich finde das auch den größten Rückstand. Aber nochmal zu den Sachen mit den Taps. Ich grübel darüber, was das bedeutet. Und das Ding ist, Apple ist ja im Prinzip der Pionier gewesen, was Multiple Document Interfaces betrifft. Also dieses Prinzip, dass ein Programm mehrere Dokumente hat und für jedes dieser Dokumente ein einzelnes Fenster, die dann von einem Window-Manager alle global sortiert werden, aber jeweils immer noch dem Programm zugeordnet sind. Windows kam ja später nach und hat es ganz anders gemacht. Ursprünglich Windows hat dann irgendwie das Programm hat ein Fenster und da drin hast du dann die Fenster des Programms.
Die erinnern uns alle.
Alles ganz furchtbar. Davon sind sie ja, ich richtig sehe, auch von abgewichen. So, was allerdings Windows wiederum dem Mac voraus hatte, war, wenn sie es auch extrem schlecht gemacht haben, aber sie haben ja die Taps vor dem Mac gehabt.
Wo?
Na in ihrem Betriebssystem. Und Windows gibt es seit Ewigkeiten Taps. Taps gibt es auf dem Mac noch nicht so lange.
Ach so, du meinst generell, die sind doch von OS2. Die kamen doch von OS2 und die haben sie dann mit drüber geholt nach Windows.
Und wo auch immer es her kam.
Es gab es nicht auf dem Macintosh First.
Und was ich schon immer finde...
Wobei, da waren das eher nicht so die Taps, da waren das nicht so diese Taps, wie man sie heute nutzt an Firefox, sondern du meinst diese Konfigurationsdialogen, dass man das so aufsplitten kann. Also das so...
Na, es gab verschiedenste Ansätze, wie man so unter... Auch die alten System-Preferenzen bei Mac, könnte man im Prinzip sagen, naja, das waren jetzt Taps, wo du dann die Icons gehabt hast und so weiter. Und mal waren sie links in einer Vertikel...
Du meinst diese ganz, ganz alten System-Sechszeiten?
Na generell, also sagen wir mal, Taps im Sinne von ein User-Interface mit das Konzept Unterabteilung im User-Interface. Dass man einfach etwas kategorisiert und dem Benutzer die Möglichkeit gibt, von mehreren Unterpunkten auszuwählen, während man in einem Hauptpunkt sich befindet. Und das wiederum als Unterteil des Fensters.
Ja, aber so als standardisiertes Element gab's das glaube ich seit Mac OS 8, das war schon ewig.
Es gab es bei Windows zuerst.
Das mag sein, aber dann bei Mac.
Ich weiß jetzt schon gar nicht mehr, wann es bei Mac eingeführt wurde.
Mit Mac OS 8, ziemlich sicher.
Was sie richtig gemacht haben, ist, dass sie nicht so bekloppte Scheiße einführen wie bei Windows, was es da ja heute immer noch gibt. Und ich glaube sogar bei Vista immer noch gibt.
Mehrzahlige Tabs.
Mehrzahlige Tabs, die dann auch noch ihre Position ändern, wenn du draufklickst.
Sich bewegende User-Elemente.
Das ist wirklich... Tontaubenschießen ist das.
No Go ist das.
Das geht gar nicht, oder? Ja, wie auch immer. Ich will ja nicht über Windows reden, sondern mir geht es jetzt um Folgendes. Der Mac hat also das Prinzip gehabt, mehrere Dokumente. Und du hast ja als Standard-Element auch im User-Interface, im Window, siehst du ja dann einen Eintrag für jedes Window. Jetzt kommen sie mit diesen Tabs und schießen diese Tabs in das Fenster selber rein. Was mir sagt, dass sie da an etwas arbeiten. Nämlich, dass sie ihr Multidocument-Interface generell auf System-Ebene irgendwann zu einem Multidocument mit Tabs machen können. Dass dieses Prinzip Unterdokument auch Einzug finden könnte ins Betriebssystem. Dass wir das jetzt nicht nur im Safari sehen, sondern dass wir das auch nutzbar erstmal für andere Programme haben. Dass auch andere Programme dieses Konzept von Tabs übernehmen können.
Wäre ja eigentlich nicht so schwer, sogar nachträglich für alle Programme, weil es ist ja eigentlich nur der Window-Manager, der aus zwei Fenstern eins macht, oder?
In gewisser Hinsicht würde man nämlich jeden Tab als einzelnes Fenster betrachten können. Genau, weil es ja dann vollständig ist und abziehen kann. Und insofern wäre das auch ein sehr eleganter Ansatz. Ich bin mir jetzt bloß nicht so sicher, ob mir so viele Beispiele für Programme einfallen würden, die das jetzt wirklich unbedingt brauchen.
Naja, Tabs hat man schon.
Textverarbeitung, würdest du da wirklich mit sowas arbeiten?
Na, Code-Bearbeitung, dass man mehrere Fenster offen hat, ist ja relativ, also Text-Made und BB-Edit haben ja schon so eine Pseudo-Tab.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, genau.
Also es gibt da schon einige Bereiche, in denen das geht. Ich finde den Ansatz, den sie jetzt gewählt haben, aber nicht sonderlich elegant, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Also zum einen ist es ja sowieso schon so, dass durch diesen Unified-With-No-Look kann man ja Fenster mittlerweile an den unterschiedlichsten Stellen bewegen. Zum Beispiel auch, wenn man in die Button-Leiste klickt und nicht auch direkt auf den Button. Oder bei Safari kann man auch, indem man die Status-Leiste des Fensters klickt, das Fenster bewegen. Auf der anderen Seite kann man aber plötzlich oben, wenn man in die Titel-Leiste reinsteckt, an bestimmten Stellen nicht mehr das Fenster bewegen, sondern dann hat man dann plötzlich diesen Regler. Also ich hab zum Beispiel, wenn ich einen Tab verschieben will, muss ich in Safari jedes Mal aufs neue Nachdenken. Ich klick erst in den Tab rein, probiere den Tab zu schieben, dann verschiebt sich das Fenster und denke mir, ah stimmt ja, ich muss ja da oben jetzt diesen kleinen Handle greifen.
Der ja auch so ähnlich aussieht wie der Resizer.
Total.
Was ja nun auch irgendwie keinen Sinn macht.
Überhaupt nicht. Also das finde ich wirklich bisher keine dolle Lösung.
Ich glaube auch, dass Sie damit noch nicht am Ende sind. Und ich denke, dass die finale Version von Safari nicht so aussehen wird.
Dass generell dieses Aufräumen, dass man da oben erstmal, also diesen Reload-Button in die Adressleiste reinzupacken, finde ich nicht so verkehrt, diesen kleinen Plus-Button, der fürs Bookmarks hinzufügen, also dass man diese ganze Leiste da oben mal generell ein bisschen überarbeitet und so dämliche Sachen wie Home-Buttons rausschmeißt oder sowas.
Ist das raus?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es standardmäßig raus ist, aber auf jeden Fall finde ich, sieht die deutlich aufgeräumter aus, diese ganze Leiste.
Am Morgen war doch aber da nie, oder doch?
Ich weiß nicht, ob der per Default 3 war, aber es gab natürlich noch mal einen Home-Button, den kann man sich jetzt definitiv auch noch nach wie vor einsetzen.
Dass das Reload plötzlich nicht mehr drüben bei den anderen Buttons ist, finde ich auch blöde.
Ja, das finde ich auch so.
Ich bin auf einer Stelle, ich will ja nicht mal da hinfahren und mal da hinfahren.
Ja, das finde ich auch.
Also sowas mit sich sowieso Shortcuts.
Das finde ich auch blöd.
Ich finde es, also es sieht halt aus wie auf einem iPhone. Ich glaube darum geht es auch ein Stück weit.
Das ist schon, sie versuchen da so ein bisschen davon zu lernen, ob sie sich das richtig als Vorbild genommen haben. Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall auch eine interessante Frage. Also so richtig begeistert bin ich nicht davon.
Ich finde auch dieses Plus da oben, das ist so ein bisschen... Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das... Ich glaube, ich habe das noch nicht einmal benutzt, um ein neues Tab aufzumachen. Aber dann gibt es auch so Momente, wo ich Tastaturtyp bin und dann gibt es Momente, wo ich so Maustyp bin. Da bin ich dann über alles froh, was man mit dem Maus erreichen kann und bin immer total grantig, wenn Programme Kommandos haben, die man zwar über einen Tastaturkürzel abrufen kann, aber nicht über das Menü.
Ich hatte am Anfang höllische Probleme mit Safari 4. Ganz merkwürdige Sachen, dass zum Beispiel diese Top-Sides wurden bei mir schlicht und ergreifend nicht angezeigt. Dieser Progress-Button hat sich für immer gedreht und hat niemals geendet. Das habe ich dann irgendwie gelöst gekriegt, indem ich auf ganz abstrusen Wegen draufgekommen bin. Es gibt einen Ordner, Private War Folders, den ich irgendwann mal gelöscht habe nach dem Ordner namens Folders. Welches dämliche Programm hat das hier abgelegt? Das dämliche Programm nennt sich Mac OS 10.5 oder 10.4 oder welche wahrscheinlich schon ältere Version auch. Und wenn man diesen Ordner löscht, dann verhalten sich ein Haufen Programme doch reichlich merkwürdig. Unter anderem aus Safari einfach anlegen, Rechte reparieren lassen von einem Festplattendienstprogramm. Seitdem läuft Safari auch bei mir wieder eins.
Tja, da hättest du vorher mal reinschauen sollen in diesen Folders-Ordner, was da so drin liegt.
Da liegt ein Ordner drin im Augenblick bei mir, der heißt 1C, einer heißt 7E, einer heißt Groß ET.
Ja, und hast du mal da reingeschaut, was da drin liegt?
Da hab ich reingeguckt und da liegt zum Beispiel eine Datei drin, die heißt 1C MST plus F2.
Du musst schon noch ein bisschen tiefer gehen, mein Freund. Mach einfach mal, kriegst du jetzt mal einen heißen Unix-Tipp. Jetzt gehst du mal da rein und tippst einen Feind, Leerzeichen, Punkt.
Danke.
Bitte. Und dann?
Wusste ich vorher überhaupt nicht.
Nee? Na gut, dass du bei Mobile Wechs bist.
Da sind ein Haufen Ordner drin, die alle Caches heißen.
Genau. Du hast dir einfach einen Cache-Ordner gelöscht.
Was hat ein Cache-Ordner in Private War zu tun?
Was hat ein User in Private War zu suchen?
Ein Mac-User vor allem.
Ein Mac-User. Das ist verbotenes Terrain für dich. Da sind Landminen. Here be Dragons. Do not enter. Das ist ein Verzeichnis, was dir von deinem Feind nicht angezeigt wird, wenn du frechdachs da reingehst. Ja?
Bin ich selber schuld.
Du hast deinen Sandkasten verlassen und hast mit der Schaufel einfach irgendwo draufgehauen und jetzt wunderst du dich.
Also falls auch ihr denn draußen mit dem Sand-Schäufelchen alle böse Ordner verprügelt habt, dann könnt ihr euren Safari zum Laufen bringen, weil ich habe exakt nichts dazu gefunden in irgendwelchen Foren, in denen ihr private Warp-Polders wieder anlegt. Tja, es ist ein Glück. Ich war tatsächlich schon kurz davor genau wie du. Weißt du, du hast im letzten Mal der Rohr noch erzählt, von wegen ich habe noch nie ein Betriebssystem neu installiert und ich war wirklich so verzweifelt, dass ich schon kurz davor war. Ich habe Safari deinstalliert, reinstalliert, deshalb ein Netz durchsucht, das hat alles nichts gebracht. Dann habe ich diesen dämlichen Ordner angelegt und alles läuft wie eine Eins. Das ist, ähm...
Ja, einfach wieder den Zustand vorher herstellen. Das hilft mir manchmal. Safari 4 kann ja jetzt auch Google Suggest. Na, wenn man jetzt reintabt, hat man sozusagen Live-Suche. Das heißt, Google weiß jetzt nicht mehr, was wir suchen, sondern auch alle Verschreiber.
Nein, das habe ich...
Also wenn du nach Kripo suchst zum Beispiel und du vertippst dich erstmal und schreibst Kripo, dann bist du gleich auch in der Liste. Ja, auch Leute, die sich vertippen, bedenken sich was dabei. Und die Abteilung Gedankenkontrolle kann sowas nicht dulden.
Kripo, Motors, Chevrolet...
Also ich habe auch mit Google Suggest...
Also ich habe ja immer die Erweiterung Glimpse genutzt, die ich sehr hübsch finde. Das ist so, die rüstet ein paar sehr praktische Features kostenlos nach bei Safari. Zum Beispiel dieses Suggest-Feature schon seit einiger Zeit. Und auch ein bisschen hübscher. Also zeigt auch ein paar Suchergebnisse mit an. Und Glimpse heißt das. Es bietet einen Fullscreen-Modus, der so ganz okay ist.
Ist das auch so ein Input-Manager?
Ich glaube das ja, das ist auch so ein Input-Manager. Und was das ganz toll ist, es kann die Tabs wieder herstellen, wie sie beim letzten Mal waren, automatisch. Und man kann mit Apple Z versehentlich geschlossene Tabs wieder öffnen. Das ist completely fry.
Total fry.
Totally fry. Das findet man zum Beispiel beim Mac-Update.
Und Glims, so wie Glimpse?
G-L-I-M-S.
Ah, Glimpse. Also Buchstabier es nochmal.
GL, Gerda, Lisa, Iselotte, Maxien.
Iselotte?
Lieselotte. Lieselotte. Lieselotte, Maxien, Jodomi.
Was hast du für I gesagt?
Nichts?
Das hätte man so einfach haben können. Okay, GLIMS. Super. Ist gemerkt, wird getestet. Ja, mehr fällt mir nicht ein zu Safari 4, außer dass es halt dann wohl mit Snow Leopard seine finale Version finden wird, denke ich mal. So viel Zeit werden sich da sicherlich noch Zeit lassen. Ich finde es aber interessant, dass sie da so nach vorne schreiten. Es gibt ja auch ein paar weniger beachtete Features, die in Safari 4 drin sind, die ich ganz bemerkenswert fand. Nämlich, dass sie auch den ganzen Accessibility-Bereich wieder ausgebaut haben. Also sie sind die, das ist jetzt... Es funktioniert zwar noch nicht so wie in iTunes, aber es ist auch, genau wie auch generell in Snow Leopard. Also das scheint für sie wirklich ein großes Thema zu sein. Ich weiß nicht genau warum, aber ich finde es gut, dass es so ist.
Na, böse Zungen würden jetzt behaupten, es gibt viele Behinderten, die den wegbenutzen.
Na ja, weil sie kein Windows benutzen können.
Es gibt viele, na ja, also sagen wir mal so, die neuen Features, die haben schon gewisse Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt. Die meisten Tools, die es heute gibt für Blinde, sind natürlich vor allem so Windows getargetet. Da gibt es einfach noch nicht. Es gibt so ein paar Mac-Blinden-User-Groups, aber das könnte halt noch mehr werden, weil es gibt ja das Problem, dass diese Accessibility von Webseiten durch diese ganzen neuen JavaScript-Geschichten, also durch unsere Web 2.0-Features, die immer so schön Visual-Snav, irgendwie hübsche Sachen bringen und lustige Interfaces, die sind natürlich für die Accessibility nicht so gut. Aber es gibt von der Vibra C ein entsprechendes Framework, das sogenannte, jetzt hab ich es wieder vergessen, Rich. Wie auch immer, ich schlag nochmal kurz nach. Sie haben es ja bei der Safari-Webseite auch genannt. Wie auch immer, es gibt ein Standard dafür, wie man eben auch aufwändige Web-Applikationen accessible machen kann. ARIA heißt es genau. ARIA heißt der Standard und das ist etwas, was Safari 4 erstmalig unterstützt.
Hast du gerade Safari das erste Mal gestartet, überhaupt, weil es dir das Intro-Video gezeigt hat?
Nein, ich hab nur die URL eingegeben, die er da das erste Mal macht. Die hat sich hier noch in meiner Historie, die einem dann ja immer so vor die Nase geworfen wird.
Was ich in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht mal erwähnen kann, ist das einzige Feature, was ich bei den Bedienungshilfen wirklich nutze. Also es gibt ja diese Systemeinstellungen, Bedienungshilfen, wo man sich so für, wenn man Sehbehinderung hat oder sowas, ein paar Hilfen geben lassen kann, die eigentlich alle total egal sind. Aber eine Sache ist da extrem hilfreich, und zwar unter Hören gibt es den Bildschirm blinken lassen, wenn einen Warnton ertönt. Das ist ganz toll, wenn man so in einer leisen Umgebung ist.
Du willst trotzdem dein D-D-D-D haben.
Man hat so ein visuelles Feedback, wenn man irgendwas falsch macht.
Visual Bell, genau. Das hatte ich auch mal eine Weile, hab ich jetzt irgendwie ausgeschaltet, weiß nicht warum. Dann haben sie das erste Mal auch richtig Zoom eingebaut und sie benutzen jetzt und sie haben sozusagen auch einen ersten Screenreader eingebaut in Safari. Also der, du weißt, was der Begriff Screenreader bedeutet? Screenreader ist die Software, die Blinde oder Sehbehinderte, die Eingeschränkte verwenden, um sich den Bildschirm vorlesen zu lassen. Also ein Bildschirmvorleser.
Also ist das entweder so eine Braille-Zeile oder richtig laut vorlesen?
Auf welche Art und Weise auch immer. Aber der sozusagen den Inhalt des Pixel-Screens so dechiffriert, dass man ihn eben lesen kann als Blinder. Oder wahrnehmen kann, wie auch immer. Und VoiceOver ist ja nun eine Technologie, die schon länger in Mac OS 10 drin ist, die, wie wir schon besprochen haben, so mit Alex jetzt auch eine richtige Stimme bekommen haben. Und sie haben ja auch in Leopard schon eine ganze Menge Accessibility-Features mit eingebaut, dadurch dass sozusagen das Betriebssystem in der Lage ist, aus den wohlstrukturierten Informationen des User-Interfaces eines Programms mehr zu machen. Man kennt das, man kann über die ganzen User-Interface-Elemente rübergehen und wenn er halt VoiceOver ausgeschaltet hat, eingeschaltet hat, dann kann er dir das genau beschreiben, was da ist, weil er das eben direkt aus diesen User-Interface-Beschreibungen rausnimmt. Und jetzt haben sie das eben auch noch in Safari eingebaut, sodass sie eben auch das Safari, die Logik der Webseite, die ihr ja kennt, weil er liest das ja und rendert das ja, mit Voice-Over eben übersetzen kann. Und das ist natürlich sehr viel besser, als ob du ein Programm drauflegst auf einem Browser, der davon eben gar nichts versteht und der dann wiederum versucht, aus dieser Webseite, was da angezeigt ist, irgendwas Sinnvolles rauszunehmen. Also sie sind da eigentlich auf einem ganz interessanten Weg.
Na es gibt ja sogar...
Und es ist gut, dass sie das so unterstützen.
CSS unterstützt das schon seit einer ganzen Weile so. Die wurden eigentlich, ich kenne das nur von irgendwelchen Hacks, die genutzt wurden, um Internet Explorer 5 oder 6 was beizubringen, dass da gerne hat eh keine Sau Unterstützung nach dem Motto Voices für benutzt wurden. Also man kann so bestimmte Stimmfamilien definieren für unterschiedliche Bereiche auf der Seite, dass man die Navigation von einer anderen Stimme vorlesen lässt als Textinhalte und sowas. Wäre natürlich mal ein interessantes Experiment, ob das jetzt bei Apple auch alles unterstützt wird. Probier ich mal aus.
Dann haben sie eingebaut HTML5-Features. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich schon als HTML5-Compliant bezeichnen können, weil HTML5 in dem Sinne auch noch nicht abgeschlossen ist.
Das ist ja nach wie vor ein Drive-Doc. Sie haben eine Menge Zeug nachgerüstet.
Sie haben Audio und Video.
Sie haben sehr, sehr viel nachgerüstet.
Sie haben das Tech-Audio und das Tech-Video, das sie jetzt unterstützen.
Sie unterstützen jetzt offiziell auch mal CSS-Transitions und Animations und so dieses ganze Zeug.
Die funktionieren auf dem iPhone auch schon.
Die funktionieren auf dem iPhone auch schon. Und was im iPhone, was in Safari 4 nicht funktioniert, aber auf dem iPhone sind 3D-Transformationen von irgendwelchen Inhalten. Was ich ja mal ganz lustig finde. Auf dem iPhone kannst du per CSS Inhalte der Seite dreidimensional verzerren und drehen zum Beispiel. Es gibt so einen kleinen Kartentrick, wo sich die Karte einmal dreht. Geht auf dem Desktop einfach nicht. Ich hab keine Ahnung warum.
Ja, ich wollte noch auf was hinaus, weil das ist für mich nicht nur so ein unwichtiger Punkt mit diesem HTML5-Kram, sondern ich halte das für eine der allerwichtigsten Hinzufügungen überhaupt. Denn, was steckt denn dahinter? Audio, Video und das Ganze ist Scriptware. Was fällt dir dazu ein? Genau. Und ich sage dir, die Scheiße wird auch im iPhone OS, in dem Mobile Safari unter Umständen zu finden sein. Dann kannst du eine Webseite machen, wo ein Video drin ist und wo JavaScript drumherum ist, was da ein User Interface drauf macht. Hab ich das laut gesagt mit dem Video und dem Audio?
Den Teil habe ich vorher gesagt.
Aber du verstehst, was ich meine. Sie bauen hier den Webstandard ein, der im Prinzip die Power hat, das zu tun, was heutzutage eigentlich der Hauptgrund ist, dass die Leute nach Flash schreiben. Weil niemand will ja Flash auf dem iPhone haben, weil sie Flash haben wollen. Sie wollen deshalb alle Flash auf dem iPhone haben, weil sie U-Porn gucken wollen. Die Porn-Sites gehen wahrscheinlich alle. Aber YouTube, ihr wisst schon, diese ganzen Sachen. Daily Show, iPhone OS werden wir gleich nochmal besprechen. Kommt ja jetzt auch serienmäßig mit Streaming und so weiter. Streaming Video ist ja auch alles mit dabei. Hier kommen die Sachen irgendwie zusammen. Das heißt, sie sind jetzt in der Lage, einen Browser zu liefern, der auf dem iPhone, auch auf dem Mac, aber eben auch auf dem iPhone in der Lage ist, dass du einfach in Standard HTML und Standard JavaScript dieselbe Funktionalität bereitstellen kannst, wie du das heute eben nur mit Flash machen kannst. Mit der Ausnahme von Aufnahme.
Es gibt noch dreieinhalb andere Features.
Ja, aber die sind nicht so nachgefragt.
Die sind nicht so nachgefragt, das stimmt schon. Mit SVG kann man ja schon eine ganze Weile, oder SVG oder wie auch immer das ausgesprochen wird, also dieses Grafikformat.
Scalable Vector Graphics.
Scalable Vector Graphics kann man schon eine ganze Weile auch Vektoren endlich mal in HTML zeigen. Dann gibt es ja diesen Canvas-Tag, der ja unglaubliche Dinge ermöglicht. Also bei Google Chrome gibt es im Augenblick komplette 3D-Simulationen, die in diesem Canvas-Tag ablaufen. Es ist soweit, wir haben 3D-Renderer, die in JavaScript geschrieben werden. Mozilla hat jetzt gerade, wie heißt das, B-Spin? Mozilla probiert gerade den Text-Editor, den Programmers Text-Editor, den wir zum Coden nutzen sollen als geneigtes Publikum, probieren, den HTML nachzubauen. Und weil die geahnt haben, dass dafür...
Warte mal, welcher Editor was?
Ein Text-Editor. Die probieren einen Text-Editor. Zum Beispiel für HTML oder Program-Code.
In JavaScript?
In JavaScript zu schreiben. Damit man z.B. kollaborativ arbeiten kann oder ähnliches. Und weil sie mitbekommen haben, dass dafür das Text-Area sicherlich eher ungeeignet ist, und diese ganzen wesentlichen Scheiße auch, haben sie einen kompletten Text-Editor in Canvas nachgeschrieben, inklusive blinkendem Cursor und scrollbar und allem Peepapo. Das ist keine perfekte Geschwindigkeit, aber eine okaye Geschwindigkeit. Also wenn das so weiter geht, dann stehen uns sehr lustige Zeiten bevor, was Features im Web angeht.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich bin auch schwer davon überzeugt, dass JavaScript einfach eine der kommenden Environments ist für Application Delivery.
Da gibt es auch No Flash. Wir brauchen kein Adobe-Programm mehr zu öffnen, um das alles zu erstellen.
Ich glaube auch, das mit dem Flash ist auch bald ausgestanden. Das wird jetzt noch ein paar Jahre abappen, aber das hat jetzt einfach Peak Oil erreicht. Peak Flash.
Ich glaube, das hat es eigentlich schon eine ganze Weile, oder? Das ist so richtig.
Peak Flash, na ja, es gibt derzeit noch so viel Scheiße, die mit Flash rauskommt, gerade mit den ganzen Video-Kommunikationen, Schnickes aufnehmen und so.
Ja, okay, aber es sind immer Module. Es ist nicht so wie früher, dass irgendwelche Webseiten komplett in Flash gemacht werden. So dämlich ist es heutzutage kaum noch. Gibt es noch, klar, aber das ist heute Gott sei Dank eher die... Wobei bei den wirklich viel besuchten Seiten war es wahrscheinlich immer die Ausnahme. Stimmt schon.
Es nimmt ab. Also wer heute seriös Website-Development macht, macht das... Also wer es seriös schon immer gemacht hat, der hat es noch nie in Flash gemacht, aber auch die, die sich häufig nicht dran gehalten haben, werden, glaube ich, heute häufig daran gehindert.
Ich sag's mal anders. Es gibt immer wenige Gründe, Dinge in Flash zu machen.
Genau. Kommen wir nochmal zum Safari-Feature, was auch mit dabei ist. Ist auch übrigens ein HTML5-Feature. Ich hab jetzt überhaupt erst mal reingeschaut, was ein HTML5 alles dabei ist. Ich glaub, ich muss da mal ein CAA zu dem Thema machen. Offline-Support ist mit drin.
Ja, das ist das. Damit hab ich schon mal ein bisschen rumgearbeitet. Das funktioniert.
Du meinst, ich kann jetzt brausen, ohne Netz zu haben?
Nenn ich. Ja, also du kannst ohne Netz.
Das ist, was ich ohne Netz denken würde.
Na ja, es gibt einen definierten Weg dafür, wie eine JavaScript-Applikation in deinem Browser eben auch offline funktioniert. Dass sie weiß, dass sie offline ist und dass sie eben Sachen zwischenspeichern kann.
Das ist ja wichtig für später Net-Anwendungen, die halt offline funktionieren.
Na ja, Google treibt das massiv voran.
Genau, Google will das ja mit seinem Google, wie heißt das noch gleich?
Gears sozusagen Google-mäßig machen. Die schaffen einen eigenen Standard, der demlicherweise nicht kompatibel zu HTML5 ist. Wenn man das hat, wenn man zum Beispiel nicht Safari 4 hat, kann man das zum Beispiel mit Gmail schon machen. Die haben das als Beta-Feature eingebaut. Als Lab-Feature kann man Gmail offline nutzen. Und das ist, der lädt dann im Hintergrund, fängt dann an, so Mails runterzuladen. Und dann kann man, wenn man im Zug sitzt, kann man immer noch auf seine Mails zugrafen, als ob nichts gewesen wäre. Man braucht dafür kein Internet. Und eigentlich ist dafür auch ein Safari schon, auf dem iPhone sogar schon eine ganze Weile, alles vorhanden und hat nämlich kleinzeitige Datenbanken, in denen man die Daten abspeichern kann. Und es gibt eine sogenannte Manifest-Datei, in die man reinschreibt, welche Dateien lokal gespeichert werden sollen auf dem Gerät. Und das funktioniert dann relativ transparent. Das nämlich das iPhone speichert diese Daten ab und lädt die dann auch nicht mehr. Auch wenn du Netz hast, werden die nur noch geladen, wenn es wirklich unbedingt notwendig ist, wenn sich diese Manifest-Datei inhaltlich geändert hat. Und das ist in der Theorie alles ganz großartig, weil du rufst eine Seite auf, hast keine Internetverbindung, sie ist einfach da. Und hat bei mir aber, ich hab dann die Experimente erst mal irgendwann abgebrochen, weil ich keine... Achso, und es gibt JavaScript-Events, so, hey, übrigens, jetzt hab ich doch eine Internetverbindung, willst du was aktualisieren? Jetzt bin ich nur über, bin ich jetzt gerade über WLAN verbunden, also hast du, ich glaube, sogar Verbindungsgeschwindigkeiten etc. pp. Ja, aber auf dem iPhone funktioniert es wirklich noch nicht perfekt, gerade der Zugriff auf externe Bilder hat überhaupt nicht geklappt.
Naja, wir werden sehen. Tja, haben wir noch was? Also, es gibt ja noch so tausend, also die Liste an neuen Features ist ja nun wirklich nicht gerade kurz, man kann sich jetzt bei Safari 4 noch hier ein tausend Sachen festhalten. Ich meine, über Coverfloor muss man glaube ich nicht reden. Dennis, hast du noch einen Beitrag irgendwie?
Zum Safari?
Ja, ist nicht so dein Thema, ne?
Nee, habe ich ja gesagt, ich benutze nicht mal Tabs. Bei mir muss der Brauch sein, der muss halt schnell sein.
Er nutzt nicht mal Tabs, das ist sagenhaft.
Nicht krass?
Nee.
Aber zum Thema Tabs, OmniWeb.
Manchmal.
OmniWeb ist jetzt A, frei.
Ja, habe ich auch gelesen.
Und B, in der neuesten Version, auch schon mit der neuen WebKit-Version. Also wenn du Safari 4 installierst, dann benutze das auch. Und das heißt, du hast hier sozusagen die Rendergeschwindigkeit von Safari 4. Aber du hast halt die coolen Tabs von OmniWeb, die schon immer nur OmniWeb hatte.
Diese Fenster seitlich so drinnen, dass man so eine Vorschau hat.
Vertikal mit einem Thumbnail.
Aber da finde ich wiederum in Safari 4 ganz cool, halt in den Bookmarks, die History und so weiter. Also Bookmarks halt, History ist ja auch nur eine Art Bookmark. Dieses, was iTunes hat, wie hieß das, hast du gerade gesagt? Coverflow genommen, das ist schon schick. Nö, aber naja, was heißt benutzen? Indirekt, du kommst ja nicht dran vorbei, wenn du halt in deinen Bookmarks irgendwas suchst und da ist die visuelle Hilfe schon, man benutzt es ja nicht direkt, sondern es ist einfach da. Du kommst ja nicht dran vorbei und das ist schon ganz cool.
Man kann es nicht ausschalten, ne?
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich meine, ich bin unten in meiner Liste und oben sehe ich halt, wie die Seite aussehen würde. Dann weiß ich auch gleich, alles klar, die war es nicht. Weil mein Gehirn kann sich natürlich auch so vom Bild her das gut merken.
Bookmarkt ihr ernsthaft noch Sachen?
Nein, also doch in der History.
Also meine Bookmarks heißen History, offene Tabs und Google. Ich benutze keine Bookmarks, schon seit Jahren nicht.
Ich hab mich auf History und Google beschränkt. Ich hab ja keine Tabs.
Du nutzt ja keine Tabs, genau. Also ich würde eher sagen, Sie sollten mal langsam von diesem Bookmarks-Ding wegkommen und sich was wirklich Cooles Neues ausdenken, wie man Bookmarks, wie man History, Tabs und Google vernünftig miteinander verbindet, um mal wirklich was Gutes Neues daraus zu machen. Also dass ich ein einfaches Interface habe, mit dem ich sagen kann, ich hatte doch da vor kurzem eine Webseite, die hieß so und so, und die wieder öffnen, genau in dem Zustand, in dem sie vorher war, ohne Ladezeiten oder so was, oder dass im Hintergrund irgendwann geladen wird und ich vorher erstmal aber nicht merke, dass sie gerade geladen wird, dass sie erstmal schon da ist. Irgendwie wäre da mal was Neues fällig. Also so richtig angetan bin ich von dem Tabs-Ansatz von Safari 4 nicht. Ich hatte da oft mehr gehofft.
Ich wäre ja schon glücklich, wenn dieses Scheiß-Browser mal... Ich meine, jetzt haben wir hier schon irgendwie so eine Historie und er hat da irgendwie ein Thumbnail von der Seite, aber wenn ich jetzt mal mein Internet wegbricht und ich sage irgendwie, geh mal zurück auf die Seite, wo ich schon mal war, von der du mir eben sogar noch ein Thumbnail gerendert hast, dann steht da trotzdem irgendwie kein Internet, kann ich nie laden. Dabei liegt es in seinem Scheiß-Cache rum. Wenn ich frage mich mal, wozu cashen Sie das, wenn ich den Cash sowieso nur anschauen kann, wenn ich Netz hab. Oder? Ich meine, hat das jemals Sinn gemacht? Ich kenn keinen einzigen Browser, der das richtig hinkriegt, dass wenn irgendwie kein Netz da ist und es ist im Cash, dass er mir das dann anzeigt. Er kann ja anzeigen mit, du guckst dir jetzt die Seite aus dem Cash-Cash-Iscan sein, dass die nicht aktuell ist oder so. Irgendwas, aber das ist wirklich einfach. Wenn ich nur einmal reinzufällig auf, gerade so dieses, du bist im Zug, du machst dir deine fünf Tabs auf, irgendwie schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, für die nächste Stunde, die du irgendwie kein Netz hast. Du hältst gerade am Bahnhof, hast Netz, dann fährst du wieder, hast kein Netz. Dann willst du dir das irgendwie durchlesen, dann kommst du irgendwo rein, zufällig mal auf Back.
Und schon geht nichts mehr.
Und dann willst du wieder nach vorne und dann so, nee. Ja, das hab ich jetzt 0,1 Sekunden, hab ich diese 10 Kilobyte dieser Seite auf einem Computer, der 4 GB RAM hat, davon gammeln 3 GB drum, aber er ist nicht in der Lage, mir diese Scheiß-Seite anzuzeigen. Rand, Rand, Rand, Rand, Rand. So was finde ich furchtbar.
Gerade auf dem iPhone ist jetzt abgesehen von diesem HTM 5 Offline-Zug, wo es jetzt langsam kommt, aber auch da dieses Caching-Management, ich meine, das Ding hat 16 GB, von denen bei mir vielleicht 12 genutzt sind, da könnten 4 GB, da könnten die Offline-Cache reinpacken, Bilder etc. Es wäre nicht mal, die Cache-Unterstützung ist nicht mal so gut wie ein Safari auf dem Desktop oder sowas.
Das benutzen sie einfach nicht, das ist wahrscheinlich auch zu langsam.
Ich glaube, es kommt jetzt mit iPhone 3.0, dass sie auch Storage nehmen dafür. Also dass sie nicht nur am RAM-Speichern cashen, sondern auch auf der Platte.
Dass man nicht das Flash-Dialog schnell weggammelt. Das hält auch nicht ewig.
Nicht, dass er schlecht wird.
Ja, ja, nicht, dass er schlecht wird.
Gut.
Wollen wir zu und zu machen das Thema Safari?
Safari, ich hab doch ganz, nee, so Safari indirekt...
Hab ich schon gesagt, dass OmniWeb auch kostenlos ist?
Ja, hast du gesagt.
Und Omnidisc-Sweeper ist auch kostenlos.
Omni hat überhaupt mal ein bisschen rumge... Die haben es ein bisschen aussortiert.
Alles jetzt.
Verkannte Software.
Nee, Quatsch, nicht alles. Aber Omnidisc-Sweeper, denn OmniObjectmeter, so viel Programmierer, so ein Object-Leaks zu finden ist umsonst. Und noch irgendwie zwei andere.
Omnidessel, glaube ich, oder so was heißt das? Womit man so...
Ja, Sachen, die für sie jetzt einfach nicht mehr so wichtig sind, weil ich glaube, ihre Hauptprodukte sind jetzt so OmniPlan und OmniFocus. Die machen in diesem ganzen GTD-Kram, an den sie sich jahrelang nicht reintrauen wollten.
Und Omnigraph-Sketcher.
Ja, interessantes neues Tool, ne? Hast du damit schon ein bisschen rumgespielt? Ich hätte leider noch nicht so viel Zeit dafür.
Ich hab nur kurz das Ding gelesen.
Weißt du, wovon wir reden, Max? Omnigraph, aber du, Omni, sagt dir was?
Omni, also ich kenn OmniWeb, ich kenn die Firma schon seit Jahren.
Aber benutzt du auch so mit diesen, also hast du immer so gut? Graffle und so?
Nein.
Genau, also wenn man mit dem Programm, also OmniGroup ist ja eine wirklich coole Firma. Also wer mit deren Programm noch nicht rumgearbeitet hat, der sollte sich mindestens mal die Zeit nehmen, ein bisschen damit rumzuspielen, weil sie immer wieder ganz weit vorne sind und sie haben bei ein paar Sachen, finde ich, waren sie wirklich wegweisend. Also ihr Inspector-User-Interface, was sie ja durchgehend in allen Programmen benutzen, halte ich für mit Abstand das beste Inspector-UI, was es gibt. Also die Art und Weise, wie sie da Unterteile des Inspectors kollabieren und wie du die aneinander docken lassen kannst, das ist also deutlich besser gelöst als zum Beispiel Adobe in Photoshop und so weiter.
Das ist, die haben sich überhaupt unglaublich Liebe zum Detail.
Genau und dann haben sie und vor allem auch Liebe zum OS. Sie benutzen immer sehr viel der Technologien. So und das ist ja auch eine alte Next-Step-Bude.
Das ist bei OmniWeb jetzt was, was mir so einfällt. Ich glaube, das haben sie irgendwann auch mal aufgegeben, aber bei OmniWeb war es so, wenn man in diesen Graphite, da kann man ja umschalten zwischen dem bunten Modus, wo oben die Buttons Rot, Gelb und Grün sind, die schließen Boxen und dem Graphite-Modus, wo sie einfach nur so Graustufen sind, diese relativ wischen. Bei OmniWeb war es so, dass die Icons sich umgefärbt haben, je nachdem, welchen Modus man eingestellt hat. Und sogar, wenn man den Modus gewechselt hat, einfach während OmniWeb offen war, hat das eben mit gewechselt. Du hast es nach vorne geholt. Das war wirklich besser, als es Apple jemals gemacht hat.
Ja, das sind diese Sachen, aber was ich viel wichtiger finde, ist, dass sie auch, also sie liefern so Programme, die eine Lösung sind für Leute, die besonders so im, wie soll ich sagen, organisieren, planen, dokumentieren. OmniGraffle zum Beispiel ist einfach ein hervorragendes Tool, um so Flowcharts und so eine Sache zu machen. Du kannst einfach deine Gedanken ganz gut graffisch strukturieren und da relativ easy Sachen machen. Und wenn du dann damit arbeitest und merkst, wie viel Liebe sie da in dieses Clipping und wie sich das irgendwie alles sortiert und allein lässt und wie das mit dem Inspector funktioniert, merkt man einfach große Freude. Eins meiner Hauptprogramme, wichtigsten Programme, die ich überhaupt benutze, ist OmniOutliner. Ich habe auch lange lange Zeit auf den Mailing-Listen dafür mitgevotet, da war ich auch nicht alleine, dass sie unbedingt mal so eine GTD-Applikation machen, was sie ja jetzt auch gemacht haben. Jetzt benutze ich sie nicht, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Kommt aber vielleicht noch. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Dieser Omni, wie hieß er noch? Graph-Sketcher ist jetzt wieder so ein Ding, wo sie nach vorne gedacht haben. Und zwar kennst du diesen Effekt, du bist in deinem Spreadsheet und du hättest ganz gerne mal eine schöne Grafik?
Betonung auf schön.
Da sagen wir mal, eine, die zum Ausdruck bringt, was diese Zahlen eigentlich bedeuten. Dann klickst du da irgendwie in Numbers oder in Excel dir da irgendwie auf deine Buttons und hast du deine Balken und Torten-Diagrammen und schaust du das an und denkst dir immer so, wie wäre denn das, wenn das jetzt mal, was weiß ich, die X-Achse und die Y-Achse müsste früher anfangen oder später oder so. Und dann stehst du da und suchst dann den 1000 Optionen im Inspector-Fenster und merkst, wir haben so 3, 4, 5 Sachen konfigurierbar gemacht, aber es just doesn't cut it. Und das ist genau da, wo dieser Graph-Sketcher ansetzt. Du machst ja erstmal deine, holst die Daten da rein, dann machst du da deinen Graph und dann kannst du da drin rumzuppeln und rumdraggen und irgendwie alle Sachen anklicken und rumeditieren. Also es ist sozusagen ein Editor für Charts. Und ich kann jetzt noch nicht so sehr viel aus der Erfahrung berichten. Ich hab so ein bisschen mit rumgespielt und das Konzept so erstmal ein bisschen verstanden. Und es ist auf jeden Fall wertvoll, sich das anzuschauen. Ich bin immer noch ein großer Freund von Omni. Und wer OmniWeb auch noch nicht ausprobiert hat, kann das jetzt nochmal tun.
Die gibt es ja auch schon seit 1993 als Firma. Ich hab gerade nochmal reingeguckt. Und die Gründer sind schon seit 1989 irgendwie mit OS, ne nicht mit OS X, aber mit Next Step und Objective-C dabei. Bill Bumgarner ist auch so ein Next Step Veteran, der jetzt auch bei Apple arbeitet seit ein paar Jahren. Und der meinte auch letztens im Twitter, dass er jetzt sein 20. Jahr Objective-C macht. Das ist schon ganz schön fett.
Das will was heißen. Und hier Will Shipley, der Typ, der dieses Delicious Library gemacht hat, der war ja auch vorher bei Omni gewesen.
Ach. Das Crossbone hat mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch auf mich.
Das sind so die Jungs, die das mit den Objective-C-Frameworks echt verstanden haben.
Das sehe ich jetzt nochmal, wo wir von Safari und OmniWeb gesprochen haben. Es gibt jetzt seit ein paar Tagen den ersten komplett inoffiziellen und hochinstabilen Chromium-Bild für den Mac.
Also jetzt so ein richtig und nicht so vorher wie Fusch.
Du weißt von Google.
Das ist jetzt quasi der Google-Code, der schon läuft auf dem Mac so halbwegs. Das ist auch, wenn man die Aktivitätsanzeige aufmacht, dann sieht man tatsächlich, jeder Tab hat seinen eigenen Prozess, genauso wie man sich das vorstellt. Ist noch, ich finde es mit den Tabs ehrlich gesagt besser gelöst als in Safari. Ich habe jetzt mal so ein bisschen mit rumgeklippt. Er bleibt ungefähr alle zwei. Man kann also keinen Flash darstellen, man kann nichts downloaden mit. Man sieht, das Ding ist noch nicht mal in der Alpha-Phase. Aber es reicht schon aus, um sich erstmal einen allerersten Eindruck zu vermitteln. Ich finde ihn eigentlich so relativ aufgeräumt, relativ hübsch gemacht. Kann man auf jeden Fall mal mit rumspielen. Auch da geht es langsam mal weiter.
Und heißt das, dass der jetzt auch schon mehrere Prozesse macht?
Der macht mehrere Prozesse, ja. Jetzt suche ich mal nach Chromium, dann sieht man hier, ich habe drei Tabs offen und habe vier Prozesse. Nämlich einmal das eigentliche Programm.
Und die heißen dann alle nur Chromium?
Und die heißen alle nur Chromium.
Kannst du mal den hierarchischen View?
Und abgestürzt.
Kam gleich erstmal in seinem Activity-Monitor, dass die drei Unterprozesse von Chromium, was steht da, reagiert nicht.
Okay, aber man sieht schön, da hat man so ein Chromium und dann hat man so Unterchromiums.
Genau. Also sind die jetzt wirklich tot oder sind die...
Das heißt, auch der erste Tab ist schon ein zusätzlicher Prozess. Das heißt, du hast ab der ersten Webseite schon zwei Prozesse.
Du hast ab der ersten Webseite zwei Prozesse. Der müsste jetzt ja auch eigentlich noch irgendwo... Ach so, dieses ganze Menü fehlt hier komplett. Dieses eine, was beim Original Chromium dabei ist.
Ja, die brauchen noch ein bisschen.
Das dauert noch eine ganze Weile. Also man sieht schon, da ist so ziemlich noch gar nichts. Ja, aber die Tabs finde ich ganz... Also das geht schon relativ gut. Also man kann jetzt hier diesen Tab nehmen und dann verwandelt der sich noch beim Draggen in ein eigenes Fenster. Man kann ihn aber noch nicht wieder zurückpacken.
Ja, im Prinzip genau der gleiche User-Interface-Ansatz wie Safari 4. Bloß eben, dass sie die Tabs halt im Body des Fensters haben und nicht im Header des Fensters.
Dream habe ich kaputt gemacht.
Ach, hast du gerade das optische Kabel rausgezogen?
Nee, ich glaube eigentlich nicht.
Was habe ich gehört? Microsoft hat mir immer etwas erzählt. Ich kann es ja eigentlich immer noch nicht glauben, aber es hat es mir nochmal wiederholt, aber ohne Quelle.
Kabelbruch, sagen sie. Der Ton knackt.
So viel zu den dicken Bohrkabeln. Das war dann wohl auch nichts.
Also hier kommt ein ordentliches Signal an.
Ich hab jetzt nochmal...
Jetzt ist gut? Wahrscheinlich. Dann nehmen wir das nachher mal raus hier.
Dann war es ein Software-Problem. Ich hab mal ein Nicecast neu.
Besser jetzt heißt es. Jetzt geht's wieder an.
Jetzt hat das Chromium alles lahm gelegt.
Chromium ist schuld.
Was knackt?
Also ich bin hier, kann sein, dass ich beim zeigen über das Kabel.
Ja, du bist hier auf jeden Fall gerade über die wichtigen Kabel hast du deinen Rechner rüber geschoben. Das ist ein bisschen unklug gewesen, Max. Das geht so nicht.
Bin ich raus?
Gibt jetzt noch sehr unterschiedliche... Der Chat vermutet, es lag an Chromium. Siehst du, Google ist nämlich evil.
Microsoft will auch überlegen, also sie wollen eventuell nach IE 8 nicht den nächsten bauen, sondern auch auf WebKit gehen.
Was?
Das glaub ich nicht.
Ach so, das war irgendein Gerücht.
Wer erzählt und ich hab jetzt irgendwie, der meint auch, hat da irgendwo gehört, ich hab jetzt leider noch nicht online gesucht, aber ich meine, das ist ja so schlecht, das kann man ja nicht erfinden.
Wo hab ich denn das gelesen? Das war ein ganz hanebüchenes Gerücht. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich erinnere mich... Also wenn sie das tun, dann wären sie... Das wär...
Hell freezes over.
Dann würd ich leider langsam ein bisschen Angst kriegen. Weil ich find grad Microsoft Strategie ist super.
Mit dem neuen Werbe?
Schade, dass man den Verständnis im Blick nicht verstehen kann, den ich grade zeige.
Sie verkacken alles so großartig, sie schaufeln so mächtig an ihrem eigenen Grab rum, also sie baggern geradezu an ihrem eigenen Grab, dass ich einfach großen Spaß hab. Also ich sitz eigentlich jetzt schon seit zwei, drei Jahren quasi mit Popcorn im Sofa und schau mir einfach so diesen Niedergang von Microsoft an. Und hab großen Spaß. Aber wenn sie jetzt mal so mit Sachen kommen, wie wir machen auch WebKit, dann hab ich so die Vermutung, könnte irgendjemand nachdenken bei denen.
Also WebKit, das wär ja fast noch ne Rettung. Aber es geht doch das... Hallo, das geht nicht.
Das kann nicht. Sie kommen nicht mehr hinterher. Ich sag dir, sie schaffen es nicht, mit ihrem Internet-Explorer die Lücke zu schließen. Guck dir die Geschwindigkeit an, die derzeit Firefox und auch eben die WebKit-Community hinlegen.
Das ist aber echt sagenhaft. Wie viele Leute entwickeln ernsthaft am WebKit? Also das sind doch...
Egal, wie viele das sind. Die Frage ist, wie viel Fortschritt sie machen.
Ja, aber das ist doch... Warum kriegt Microsoft sowas nicht auf die Reihe?
Ja, weil du ein Projekt nicht dadurch beschleunigst, dass du da mehr Leute drauf wirfst. Das stimmt.
Aber vielleicht sollten sie mal einen mit einer Peitsche dahinstellen.
Mit der Peitsche kannst du halt Programmierer... Hast du schon mal versucht, Softwareunternehmen zu filmen mit der Peitsche? Das bringt einfach nichts.
Ich weiß nicht, womit man... Aber ich meine, Microsoft ist... Also ich meine, sie haben es geschafft, Betriebssysteme und Office-Applikationen und dann auch ein paar Betriebssysteme und noch weitere Office-Applikationen zu schreiben.
Und Betriebssysteme.
Ja, und alle sind scheiße.
Ja, aber ich meine, das hat sie... Ach komm. Die nehmen niemals WebKit.
Ich glaub auch nicht, dass sie das tun werden, weil sie werden extreme Probleme haben, WebKit so zu modifizieren, dass das mit ihrem alten Scheiß wiederum zusammenläuft.
Das wird nämlich, ich glaube, da haben sie ein richtig großes Problem, so diese ganzen Corporate-User, die ihre...
Also sie haben Legacy auf beiden Seiten. Wenn sie was Frisches nehmen im Webbereich, dann müssen sie irgendwie daran arbeiten, dass ihr Legacy damit klarkommt.
Die haben kein Problem damit zu sagen, geht halt nicht mehr. Haben sie mit ihrem Audiozeug es auch gemacht hier.
Das ist der Place for Sure. Ja, aber das ist nicht... Ich glaube, wenn du... Wenn du irgendeine Firma hörst, dass dir eine Intranet-Applikation plötzlich mit dem neuen Internet Explorer 8 nicht mehr geht...
Ich guck mir nochmal den aktuellen Marktanteil an von...
Also global ist er nach wie vor relativ hoch.
Von Internet Explorer?
Das ist nicht mehr so viel manchmal.
Was würdest du denn so sagen aus dem Gefühl heraus?
Über 90.
90? Wo lebst du denn? Internet Explorer?
Na kommt drauf an, wo man guckt. Bei Heise halt nicht.
Nein, bei Heise nicht. Aber bei NetApplications gucke ich. Das sind halt diejenigen, die die weitreichendsten Statistiken machen. Die sammeln halt die ganzen Zugangsdaten von irgendwie Selected Sites aus. Keine Ahnung. Ich sag auch immer, in absoluten Zahlen darf man denen nicht trauen, aber man darf einen Trend rauslesen. Bei ihnen ist es so, Internet Explorer liegt derzeit bei 67,4 Prozent. Wie viel? 67,4 Prozent. Internet Explorer verliert derzeit jeden Monat 1 Prozent.
Das sind die neuen iPhone-Joser, die dazu kommen.
Das sind die noch nicht so sehr, aber auch das iPhone spielt ja mittlerweile schon eine richtige Rolle. Also so ein Prozentchen haben iPod Touch und das iPhone. Ich meine, mit 30 Millionen verkauften Devices, kein Wunder. Aber hier steht Safari 8 Prozent, Firefox 21,77 Prozent und der Internet Explorer, wie gesagt, bei 67,4. Das heißt, Safari und Firefox alleine sind schon fast bei 40 Prozent der Menge von Internet Explorer. Das wird jetzt einfach noch eine Weile so weitergehen.
Was ich persönlich ganz hübsch finde, ist, dass das auf Webseiten, die ich so in letzter Zeit gemacht hab, ich hab jetzt mal mit...
Da hat doch mal was dazu. Ich meine, ich kann ja auch nochmal die Trendgrafik zeigen. Die ist auch sehr schön.
Gucken wir mal hier.
Also das ist einfach eine Linie, die geht einfach langsam, aber beständig nach unten.
Wie blau da oben, ja.
Aber die fliegt noch verdammt weit über den anderen. Aber das ist doch mittlerweile...
Das ist halt nicht mehr so viel. Das sind halt nur noch 67,4 Prozent. Und hier siehst du halt irgendwie, wie das hier so abgeht. So, April 2008 hatten wir noch 74,8 Prozent. Und dann geht also hier einfach plöppel, plöppel, plöppel, plöppel, plöppel, geht das einfach runter. Also es ist nicht ganz ein Prozent.
Und könnt ihr das nicht hochrechnen jetzt mathematisch? In wie vielen Jahren irgendwie sich das kreuzt?
Na ja, du weißt ja, wie das ist. Dann kommt jetzt keine Ahnung. Das muss ja nicht jetzt in dem Speed bleiben, aber bisher läuft's halt so. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir hier den Time-Frame, kann man hier noch ein bisschen Enter, Date-Range?
Weiß ich auf jeden Fall ganz praktisch. Ich hab eine Seite gemacht, die heißt Why I Don't Tweet. Ist so ein Gag gewesen, dass man eine Seite macht für all die Leute, die ständig sich in Kommentaren auf Blogs beschweren, warum sie nicht twittern, dass man denen noch mal eine richtige Plattform gibt, wo sie nicht twittern können, dass das Ganze bei Twitter landet. Und da ist das Schöne, da hat der Internet Explorer einen Marktanteil von 7% auf diesen Seiten. Da gehört er hin.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir hier mal die letzten zwei Jahre und dann sieht man, dass er hier so August 2007 und so, also April 2007 bis so August 2007, vielleicht noch Oktober, da war wirklich, da atmete er hier noch so um diese 80% herum. Dann kam das iPhone. Naja, da kam so einiges.
Naja doch, mit dem iPhone kommen schon auch eine Menge Leute, die dann switchen, glaube ich.
Ja, aber ich glaube, kann man, also der Mac macht hier bestimmt was aus, aber ich glaube, dass es vor allem auch der Tod vom Internet-Explorer auf Windows ist. Dass viele Leute nicht den Schritt von 6 auf 7 und von 7 auf 8 machen, sondern dass sie in dem Moment, wo sie da wechseln, auch Firefox verwenden. Also ich denke vor allem, Firefox hat einen großen Anteil da dran.
Da sind wahrscheinlich genügend Kinder, die wenn sie bei ihren Eltern sind, über Weihnachten zu Hause, die sagen, guck mal, ich entzöne dir mal einen vernünftigen Browser.
Ja, das kann auch gut sein. Nun, wie auch immer. Sind wir jetzt durch mit den Browsern? Ich glaube, wir haben es jetzt durch. Alle sitzen hier, warten darauf, dass wir über iPhone 3.0 reden. Und wir haben jetzt hier schon wieder eine, na?
Wir haben schon mal angefangen mit dem eigentlichen Thema.
Nein, wir haben noch nicht mal angefangen. Ich finde das gut. Ich habe ja auch noch andere Themen, um es noch rauszuzögern. Wie nennt man einen rausgezögerten Orgasmus? Nicht den unterbrochen, nicht den Interruptus, sondern gibt es auch so einen Freudeus, wie Verschieberitis? Wie auch immer.
So etwas kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Ich will es ja auch nicht unterstellen, dass irgendjemand orgasmisch unterwegs ist.
Ich habe hier gerade eine verzögerte Blasenentleerung, deswegen macht man für drei Minuten ohne mich weiter.
Holst du dann auch noch Clubmate? Weil die Clubmate ist nämlich alle. Dennis, worüber reden wir denn?
Von einer verzögerten Ejakulation spricht man an das Erreichen des Orgasmus-Punktes und das auch...
Bei Wikipedia?
Ich wollte mal wissen, wie es heißt auf Lateinisch. Steht ja aber irgendwie auch nicht.
Du bist verschnupft, ne? Ja, die Klubmate ist alle. Genau, die muss jetzt erst mal nachgefüllt werden und...
Hab ich schon erzählt, jetzt können wir wieder hier ein bisschen Lücken füllen, dass ich jetzt mit laut war. Habe ich noch mal mich rangesetzt.
Hast du es geschafft?
Habe ich geschafft. Level 212.
Wie? Das gab nur 200.
150. Danach geht es beim ersten wieder los, nur dann sind die Gegner ein Stück schneller.
Ach, und beim?
Also dann Level 1 ist dann sozusagen Level 151, aber die Gegner rennen ein Stück schneller. Aber man selber nicht.
Ah, verstehe. Aber man weiß schon, wie man die Levels löst und eigentlich sind sie relativ einfach zu lösen.
Ja, und die, deswegen...
Weil sie reiten jetzt so schnell, dass man sie richtig beeilen muss, oder was?
Naja, ist nicht so schlimm. Also die ersten Level, da kommt es ja auch nicht so aufs Timing an. Deswegen bin ich auch gleich wieder bis 212 gekommen und hätte ich nicht so langeweilig gehabt, weil ich musste ganz schön lange zocken, dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen mehr geschafft. Aber ich hatte auch schon nicht mehr so richtig Lust und manchmal war ich schon so richtig froh, weil ich ein Leben verloren habe. Ja, also ich habe kein extra sterben lassen, aber ich fand es nicht schlimm, wenn ich so kleine Fehler gemacht habe. Man nimmt alles dann nicht mehr so ernst. Ich war ja einmal rum und das war schon cool. Und was ich noch rausgefunden habe, ich meine, wir können ja ein bisschen labern jetzt hier in der MaxRofKlos, ich hatte vorher eine Version von Lordauna, wo die letzten drei Level, da hat der Haxor da, der damals gecrackt hat, seine eigenen Level gemacht und seine eigenen Buchstaben da reingesetzt. R, I und K, weil der Typ hieß wohl Rick. Also meine Diversion habe ich nicht gespielt, ich habe mir das Original besorgt, aber die Version hatte ich vorher. Und da habe ich gemerkt, dass nicht nur die letzten drei Level geändert waren, sondern auch Level 146 hat der Typ geändert. Der Typ hat gegen Level 1 getauscht. Und da habe ich nie verstanden, warum das gegen 1 tauscht. Und dann habe ich halt das originale Level 146 gespielt, weil ich mir das Original besorgt habe. Und das war so scheiße schwer. Es hat mich 20 Manikens gekostet, bis ich drauf gekommen bin, dass man, ich weiß nicht, wie man jetzt die Leute Lothwana kennen, aber normalerweise macht man dieses Loch, was man bei Lothwana machen muss, immer in Cook-Richtung. Man kann es aber mit Ctrl-D umschalten, dann macht das nach hinten. Das heißt, ich kann vorher was wegrennen und dabei drücken und nach hinten ein Loch machen und weiter nach vorne wegrennen und noch eins machen. Ich muss mich nicht immer so umdrehen, zurück und weiterrennen und umdrehen und zurück. Und das brauchte man diesem einen Level. Und bis ich das kapiert hab, hat es mich 20 Manikens gekostet. Und dann hat das vom Timing so gestimmt, dass ich es geschafft hab. Das ist übrigens ein Level, den dürfte man dann, wenn man dann dort ankommt, das ist dann die 296, der schon einmal wieder rumkommt, den dürfte man dann nicht mehr schaffen. Obwohl, da braucht man gar keine Gegner, den schafft man trotzdem.
Da braucht man keine Gegner?
Nee, da muss man sich durcharbeiten, ganz tief.
Ach so, man kämpft mehr gegen das Zuwachsen der Löcher.
Genau, genau, genau.
Verstehe. Und wachsen die nicht auch schneller zu? Das nicht, nur die Typen sind schneller. Ah, verstehe.
Ja, jedenfalls hab ich...
Wir reden über Lojrana, er hat es geschafft jetzt...
.einen Punkt habe ich knappe 2 Millionen Punkte gemacht und bei Twin Galaxies, die ja in dem Film King of Kong vorkommen, weiß nicht ob die Leute hab ich schon mal von erzählt, nee, ne? Das ist so ein Dokumentarfilm über zwei Leute, die sich im Donkey Kong-Spielen bekriegen, so richtig am Arkadeautomaten und da wird halt offiziell die Highscore bei twingalaxies.com eingetragen, die bekriegen sich da immer noch und jedenfalls da wäre ich jetzt Weltmeister in Low-Toner-Spielen, also mit mehr als das Doppelte, was die da haben. Nur müsste ich es halt irgendwie auf Video aufnehmen irgendwie und dorthin schicken und kann da keine zehn Stunden Video aufnehmen. Müsste ja auch Formate machen, die man ja nicht mehr aussprechen kann, VHS oder so.
Kannst du aber Screen Capture Tool nehmen und dann...
Zehn Stunden lang?
Schließt noch so eine 100 GB-Platte an.
Ja, aber das ist alles nicht so richtig cool.
Du musst jetzt auch irgendwie in aller Ewigkeit festgeschrieben sein. Du fängst einfach nochmal jetzt bei Null an.
Aber wir haben jetzt im Club einen richtigen 64er und ein richtiges Floppy-Laufwerk, wo wir richtig das Original-Load-Runner wieder auf Diskette geschrieben haben mit so speziellen Tools und so und ich kann jetzt richtig die theoretische Original-Diskette-Load-Runner spielen.
Mit welchem Joystick?
Im Club habe ich gerade einen Competition Pro normalen, ich habe zu Hause aber noch meinen Competition Pro Deluxe und einen QuickShot 2.
Ich habe keine C64 Infrastruktur mehr.
Gibt es bei eBay, ich bin gerade voll am eBay. Kostet du so 64er, dann kriegst du so 5 bis 10 Euro und die Laufwerke auch so für ein 10er. Ich habe mir der vorletzte Nacht eine 1571 geschossen. Ja, so viel dazu. Der Max ist wieder da. Dann können wir jetzt zum nächsten Thema übergehen und das wäre dann nämlich an...
Also ich habe noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten.
BB-Edit-903.
Ein kurzer Hinweis, was ich hier gerade noch habe, können wir kurz mal weghaken. MacPorts ist mittlerweile bei Version 171 und jetzt habe ich so wirklich den Eindruck, dass es langsam funktioniert.
Echt, du benutzt Ports?
Natürlich benutze ich Ports. Guter Witzwutz. Also MacPorts 171, da kann man jetzt so richtig so, wenn man irgendwie tausend Sachen installiert haben, sagen, Sudo Port Upgrade installt und dann klappt das auch mit dem Upgraden und danach kannst du sagen, Sudo Port Uninstall Outdated und dann wirft da alles weg, was äh...
Altes.
Alte ist alte Version, weil du ja mehrere Versionen gleichzeitig installiert haben kannst, aber wenn du immer nur eine Version wirklich Interesse daran hast, dann sammelt sich da immer so viel Kraft an und das hab ich halt früher immer probiert und hab mich immer gewundert an den ganzen Dependencies, das hat irgendwie alles nicht funktioniert und das haben sie offensichtlich ganz gut hinbekommen.
Du könntest echt ein Mähdern-Nachfolger werden, alle haben auf seinen Rücktritt gewartet und er hat es nicht gemacht, jetzt warten wir alle auf iPhone und du machst das einfach nicht.
Ich soll zurücktreten?
Nicht zurücktreten, sondern auf den Punkt kommen. Lass uns doch mal anfangen hier.
Über iPhone zu reden?
Oder nudel deine Punkte schneller durch.
Jetzt bin ich verunsichert.
Na mach schnell.
Na kommen wir doch auf iPhone.
Na gut.
Gut. Hat jemand was mit dem Thema iPhone zu sagen?
Das iPhone geht jetzt nach China.
Geht?
Geht nach China.
Da kommst du doch her.
Na du meinst.
Ja, jetzt kommst du auch wieder hin. Das ist lustig, oder? Der ganze Scheiß wird in China gebaut, nur kaufen kannst du ihn dann nicht.
Weil China Mobile Telekom jetzt äh.
Na sie machen es ja nicht mit China Telekom. Also ich fand diese ganze Diskussion um China Telekom, also um den größten Mobilfunkanbieter, la la la, der mehr Subscriber hat als die USA Einwohner, war das nicht so. Also ich fand diese ganze Diskussion um China Telekom, also um den größten Mobilfunkanbieter, la la la, der mehr Subscriber hat als die USA Einwohner, fand ich immer völlig absurd, weil es war eigentlich vollkommen klar, dass sie niemals mit denen zusammengehen werden. Also zumindest mir war das klar. Wieso? Na, weil die überhaupt gar keinen UMTS machen. Das ist einfach kein UMTS-Anbieter, sondern die machen halt diesen China-3G-Standard, der sozusagen von oben verordnet da, wir machen mal was anderes als die anderen. Und damit haben sie wahrscheinlich hintenrum den Markt für China die ganze Zeit schon mal beliefert, um irgendwie klar zu machen, dass da irgendwie auch 3G und UMTS angesagt ist. Naja, reden wir mal darüber. Haben sie angekündigt? Nein, das glaub ich nicht. Ich glaub nur, dass sie das einfach am Anfang weggelassen haben und einfach der Meinung waren, das wäre erstmal nicht so wichtig, auf so einem eingeschränkten User-Interface solche komplizierte Sachen zu machen.
So unglaublich wichtig ist es tatsächlich auch nicht, wenn man ehrlich ist. Man konnte es sich ja schon mit den entsprechenden Jailbreak-Lösungen schon eine ganze Weile nachrüsten und wirklich oft benutzt hab ich es eigentlich nicht. Aber wenn man es vermisst hat, hat man es wirklich total vermisst.
Hat es denn da genau so funktioniert, wie es jetzt angekündigt wurde?
Ähm, nicht ganz genauso. Also jetzt ist es ja so, du kannst mit lange gedrückt halten und dann so rüberziehen, dann hat man so zwei Handles dran. Oder Doppeltipp? Doppeltipp? Ich greife jetzt mal rüber zu dem iPhone, mit iPhone OS 3.0, was ich nicht habe. Achso, nee, ich darf es ja haben, du darfst es.
Max, du hast so ein Gerät hier liegen. Du hast so eins mitgebracht.
Ich habe ja eins mitgebracht. Und man tippt doppelt drauf. Das geht eigentlich ganz hübsch. Man hat so zwei Marker, einen oben, einen unten. Und mit denen kann man dann...
So Gänsefüßchen.
Mit denen kann man dann so lang ziehen, das geht eigentlich. Für Sonne, Frühjahr, Beta relativ gut.
Na ja, ist auch genug Zeit. Ich denke, Sie haben einfach mit vielen Sachen rum experimentiert und am Ende das genommen, was Ihnen am besten gefallen hat. Und man wird sehen, wie gut das angenommen wird.
Wie man in dem Video ja auch schon gesehen hat, nutzen Sie halt auch aus, dass wenn man im Safari Copy und Paste macht, dass der gleich schon den Block markiert.
Wie meinst du das?
Na so, wie du jetzt einen Double-Tap machst in Safari auf so einen Paragrafen. Dann zoomt er so, dass das von der Größe passt. Und das Gleiche nutzen Sie jetzt auch für das Copy und Paste aus, um genau diesen Block auch schon mal vorzumarkieren. Da kannst du ja auch im Safari Copy und Paste benutzen. Da kannst du gleich mit einem Double-Tap, nein, mit Drücken festhalten, glaube ich, war es.
Ich habe es noch nicht ganz verstanden. Was muss man machen, um diese Lektion durchzuführen? Man drückt einfach drauf oder was?
Jetzt geht es gerade aus irgendeinem Grund nicht. Vielleicht abgestürzt. Also oben in der Adressleiste, Double-Tap drauf.
In der Adressleiste?
Zum Beispiel. Jetzt einfach im Texteingabefeld sozusagen.
Ach, da kann man das auch machen. Ist ja interessant.
Naja, würde man ja meinen. Und dann kann man hier, ah, verstehe. Und dann zieht man dann einfach den Futzel, zieht man dann nach vorne und den hinteren Futzel kann man auch nach vorne und nach hinten ziehen. Und man hat die ganze Zeit so eine Vergrößerungssprechblase, die ein bisschen anders aussieht als die.
Die ein bisschen eckig ist.
Vom Editieren, genau. Die mehr so ein, vorher hatte man ja so dieses runde Ding, diese Lupe. Und jetzt ist es mehr so eine Sprechblase. Also mit einem Pfeil und einem rounded rectangle darüber. Das funktioniert aber eigentlich ganz gut, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe gelesen, dass es total scheiße gehen soll. Und alle nicht glücklich. Aber ich finde es so erstmal relativ okay. Kann man doch auch besser machen.
Aber jetzt im Safari, wenn ich jetzt hier doppel klicke, dann...
Ja, da muss das aber gerade ausgefallen sein. Also eigentlich geht das da haargenau so.
Aber doppel klick ist doch Zoom.
Doppelt und gedrückt halten vielleicht. Also einmal tippen und dann gedrückt halten, mein zweiter Mal. Aber ich glaube, dass ihr gerade abgestürzt.
Naja, wie auch immer. Fand ich auf jeden Fall jetzt auch nicht so das Allerwichtigste. Find ich ja schön, dass sie da auch drüber nachgedacht haben. Aber ich find, die wirklichen Improvements sind... andere Sachen. Das fand ich ja komisch. Also dass sie wirklich MMS eingebaut haben, da hätte ich jetzt auch glatt noch eine Kisse Marte gegen gewettet, dass sie das nicht tun werden.
Na, da haben wahrscheinlich die Telefonfirmen so lange rumgeheult, dass sie halt auch noch ein bisschen Geld verdienen wollen.
Das glaub ich auch. Das war so, wie ihr wollt jetzt auch Chat machen und Skype irgendwie Applikationen freischalten, dann müssen wir aber auch noch irgendwie ein paar User abziehen können und müssen irgendwie MMS machen.
Ja, so wird's gewesen sein.
Kennst du so Leute, Max, die irgendwie nach MMS geschrien haben?
Ja, ich, damit man...
Mit Omi? Dass du Omi ein Foto schicken kannst oder was?
Nee, einfach nur, damit man bei der Bahn Online-Tickets kaufen, äh, Handy-Tickets kaufen kann. Ich kann mir sonst keinen anderen Grund vorstellen.
Bei der Bahn kann man mit MMS...
Ja, es gibt MMS-Tickets. Kannst du dann auch bald den nächsten... Achso, das ist ja eh eine Bahn-Card, dann brauchst du dich ja gar nicht zu interessieren.
Ja, aber... Warum kann man das nur mit MMS machen?
Weil du kriegst halt diesen... Du kriegst so ein Barcode als Bildchen zugeschickt und den scannt dann der Schaffner ein. Und das gleiche könnt ihr natürlich auch mit einem PDF-Dokument machen, das musst du aber ausdrucken. Ansonsten, wenn du es nicht, wenn du es einfach nur auf dem Bildschirm hast und ihm das zum Einscannen geräuchst...
Warum geht das auf dem Mobiltelefon und nicht auf dem Computer?
Weil es in den AGBs steht.
Ja, warum steht es in den AGBs?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wird sich das jetzt ändern, jetzt wo MEDA uns zurückgetreten ist?
Max, berichte live!
Wir werden es nicht klären können. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall gibt es jetzt MMS und Sie integrieren das mit SMS in eine einzige Applikation. So wie es Sinn macht. Dann kann man halt auch Audio und Audiodateien versenden und empfangen. Sagen Sie, ob das jetzt mit MMS zu tun hat? Weiß ich nicht.
Voice Recording Funktion? Überhaupt generell drin?
Ja, Sie bauen Voice-Memo ein. Ich hab mir eine ganze Reihe, ich glaube, ich hab mir nahezu alle Programme im App-Store gekauft, die Audio-Recording machen.
Und die laufen alle nicht im Hintergrund, total scheiße, oder?
Und jetzt kommt Apple und baut es ein und dann läuft es halt im Hintergrund. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das Ende von diesen ganzen anderen Voice-Recording-Programmen. Weil das ist immer das größte Problem gewesen, weil du machst so eine Aufnahme und dann, was weiß ich, kommt so ein bekloppter Kalender-Notify oder sowas. Irgendwas, ein Anruf.
Dann ist ja auch deine Audio-Aufnahme gleich tot.
Ein Anruf und so und haut dir das halt weg, das ist halt total elend. Und das neue Voice-Memo wird wahrscheinlich ausreichen. Was will man schon?
Kann man denn auch Telefonate aufzeichnen?
Das wäre nochmal eine praktische Sache.
Eins der Features hieß Call-Log. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das damit meinen. Das Call-Log ist eigentlich, dass mit dem Adressbucheintrag angezeigt wird, wenn du mit jemandem telefoniert hast.
Genau, da steht jetzt nicht mehr nur der Name und Uhrzeit, sondern da steht auch, hat mich angerufen, ich hab ihn angerufen.
Sicherlich sehr sinnvoll.
Mobil oder im Festnetz und wie lange und so. Man sieht mal ein paar Gesprächsinformationen, die vorher eingeladen wurden. Na man sieht, welcher Telefonnummer man angerufen hat.
Achso, ja, hast ja recht. Das stimmt. Aber kommen wir doch vielleicht mal zu den großen Sachen, die sie auch gleich am Anfang gemacht haben. Vor allem das Interessante an dieser Präsentation, also wir reden jetzt von diesem Special Event, den Apple mittlerweile auch auf seinem Keynote-Podcast gepostet hat. Da kann man sich das 700 Megabyte-Datei runterladen und nochmal in Full Glory anschauen. Habe ich auch nochmal gemacht. Vor allem, weil ich mir diese zwei Slides genauer anschauen wollte.
Wo die ganzen Features draufstehen?
Wo diese ganzen Features, die sie auch noch haben. Wir hatten noch so viele Features. Wir reden überhaupt nicht über alles. Und dann war so ein ganz kleiner Schrift da noch ein paar zu sehen. Die habe ich mir vorhin extra nochmal rausgezoomt, um die mal durchzugehen. Weil da sind wirklich ein paar interessante Details drin. Aber vielleicht erstmal die großen Sachen. Das erste, womit sie gekommen sind, ist eine ganz neue Funktionalität im Upstore. Die schonmal interessant ist. Insofern vor allem, weil sie das erste war, was genannt wurde. Jetzt mal so rein.
Man kann direkt aus dem Programm heraus zu der Switch was kaufen.
Na erstmal, genau. Also das geht, Programme können während sie laufen über den Upstore Dinge verkaufen.
Was hoffentlich dazu führt, dass es nicht mehr irgendwelche Verlage, die E-Books verkaufen, ungefähr 80.000 Mal ihre diversen E-Books einreichen. Sondern ein E-Book Programm, das ist ja schon zu spät.
Ich fand das interessant, dass sie sogar E-Book explizit gesagt haben. Als Beispiel. Na ja, also Kindle gibt es jetzt auch als Applikation, aber ich bezweifle, dass sie die 30% da nochmal abgeben wollen an Apple. Auf jeden Fall ein super interessantes Modell. Die Bedingung ist, wenn du was verkaufen willst in deinem Programm, muss dein Programm auch vorher gekauft worden sein.
Das finde ich allerdings ganz gut.
Das ist cool, ne?
Weil sie können dann nicht anfixen mit freien Programmen und später wollen sie einem alles so verkaufen, sondern einfach frei.
Ich denke, sie wollen sich auch, glaube ich, ihre Upstore-Experience nicht versauen lassen. Dass, wenn die Leute was Freies holen, dass es eben auch frei bleibt. Und das haben sie auch ganz klar gesagt.
Vor allem wollen sie nicht, dass alle Leute erst mal mit frei anfangen. Apple nichts verdient. Weil so musst du halt gleich schon mit einem Dollar mindestens anfangen.
Na ja, gut. Ich meine, ja.
Das könnten sie auch.
Das ist ja nicht der Punkt. Ich meine, sie können jetzt auch für einen Dollar irgendwie deine Applikation verkaufen und danach irgendwie die 50-Dollar-Häppchen machen. Also daran verdienen sie ja jetzt auch mit. Das war ja generell nicht erlaubt, ein Bezahlsystem.
Wahrscheinlich wollen sie einfach Next-Screens, also diese nervigen Screens, die beim Hochfahren eines Programms, dass man warten muss, warte noch 15 Sekunden, bis ich das Programm starten darf, wenn du jetzt gekauft hättest. Wie war das Shareware-Programm, das früher üblich war?
Das nervt auch.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie ja mehrere Sachen genannt, unter anderem eben auch Subscriptions, dass man sozusagen auch Programmen, dass man die Subscription von Content darüber abwickeln kann. Dann eben sowas wie Levels für Games, was sicherlich ein echtes Thema ist. Gerade bei, also was jetzt all diesen ganzen bezahlten Games die Möglichkeit gibt, auch weiterhin noch Revenue zu erzeugen. Und ich glaube, das ist für die Game-Developer ein richtig gutes Ding. Und dieses, naja, dieses irgendwie, ich kauf mir eine neue Wumme in meinem Shooter, weiß ich nicht so richtig, ob es das ist. Ich glaube, bei New-Content geht es Ihnen wirklich auch um New-Content im Sinne von Content, der derzeit einfach noch gar nicht als verkaufsfahra... Also das fand ich bei dieser Content da ist.
Dieses, bei diesem Sims fand ich das Beispiel, fand ich das ganz, also dass man sich so in seiner virtuellen Welt spätestens, wenn das dann anfängt, irgendwann alles vernetzt zu werden, dann wird es ja auch so ein bisschen um Bling Bling gehen.
Geht das nicht bei World of Warcraft auch denn ist?
In-Game-Kauf.
Kann man da... Nee?
Nicht.
Aber es gibt doch Programme, die das machen.
In-Game-Kauf?
Naja, so wie Second Life Scheiße.
Ich hab irgendwann mal gehört von... Da hat mir jemand erzählt, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, das war südkoreanisch, die haben so ein Browser-Game geschrieben, also was ich komplett im Webbrowser, die Dinger knallen ja rein ohne Ende. Und das Spiel war komplett kostenlos. Es gab nur zwei Features in dem Spiel, die man bezahlen musste. Das eine ist Scheiße, mit dem man jemand anders bewerfen kann und das andere war ein Tuch, mit dem man diese Scheiße wieder abwischen kann. Und darüber hat sich das gesamte Spiel finanziert, angeblich.
Nein!
Die Dammich Korea!
Oh Mann! Wirklich!
Nochmal!
Das heißt, das ist die erste Firma, die wirklich offen zugibt, dass sie ihr Geld mit Scheiße kriegt? Das ist ja unfassbar! Zweites Feature, was sie genannt haben, ist Peer to Peer über Bluetooth. Finde ich eine ganz große Nummer. Ohne Peering. Das bedeutet, dass sie und mit Bonjour, was sie nicht gesagt haben, aber was ich da rauslese, ist, dass das auf Basis von Bluetooth-Paren funktionieren muss. Personal Area Network, dass du sozusagen dein Device als Device sozusagen postest und dass eben diese Federation in deinem Personal Area Network von den ganzen Devices, die da rumlaufen, quasi wie ein neues Gerät an einem Ethernet ist. Dass die sich alle sehen und dass in dem Moment, wo ein Gerät auftaucht, dass es einfach daran teilnimmt und eben dort sichtbar ist mit seiner Mac-Adresse wie ein Gerät. Und dass sie darüber eben normal Bonjour posten, das heißt, die annunzen sich die ganze Zeit, Hallo, ich bin ein iPhone, bei mir läuft Programm und ich biete folgende Services an und dann kannst du die eben automatisch detekten. Das heißt, ein Programm kann sich starten und kann sagen, ich möchte mal gucken, ob in meiner Umgebung ein Programm meinesgleichens ist oder zumindest etwa ein Dienst, mit dem ich zusammenarbeiten kann. Und dann geht das. Und das ist natürlich total klug. Erstens, weil sie Bluetooth richtig nutzen. Zweitens, weil sie damit das Problem umgehen, dass du eben nicht in einem bestimmten WLAN sein musst. Also bisher musstest du ja einen WLAN erzeugen, um mit anderen spielen zu können. Und wenn aber das WLAN selber das verhindert, Bonjour filtert und so weiter, gerade bei diesen ganzen Hotspots und so, da unterliegst du diversen Einschränkungen. Hab ich ganz häufig gemerkt, dass da eben einfach nichts ging oder so. Oder dass da irgendwie verschiedene Access Points dann untereinander nur gerautet werden, aber nicht geswitcht sind. Oder dass du dann eben diese Bonjour Announcements auch nicht siehst und so weiter. Auf jeden Fall macht das total Sinn. Also ich finde das einfach eine coole Funktionalität. Und ich denke, das werden sehr viele benutzen.
Aber könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als es beim iPod Touch beim zweiten so Gerüchte aufkam, dass er Bluetooth hätte und so und was die damit wohl wollen. Und dann als sich das aber alles, ja, waren nur Gerüchte und ein Screenshot und so. Und jetzt haben sie da bestätigt. Das Ding hat Bluetooth und wir haben es bloß noch nicht freigeschaltet bisher.
Ah, echt? Das habe ich noch gar nicht mitbekommen. Beim Bluetooth, iPod Touch zweiter Generation, der hat jetzt Bluetooth mit dem Update.
Der wird nach dem Update Bluetooth haben per Software. Oder 10?
10.
Ja, so eine Summe, die man durchaus in die Hand hält.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die ganzen Accessories jetzt am iPhone gehen. Weil, das ging ja bisher nicht. Ich habe zum Beispiel zuhause so eine Apple Remote-Firme, die mit dem Radio drin. Da war ja so ein Stecker, der so ein bisschen wie so ein iPod Nano aussah. Also früher mal dieses, den Clip. Und da, wo das Radio drin ist. Und das geht bisher am iPhone nicht. Und wenn dann die 3.0 mal kommt, müsste das Ding funktionieren.
Na, ich glaube nicht, dass die das für alte Sachen machen werden, sondern es geht ja eher darum, dass es für Entwickler eine API geben wird, dass man für diesen Stecker eigene Anschlüsse... Sie haben doch dieses Demo gehabt, dass man...
Das könnte natürlich sein. Aber ich denke, wenn sie den Support einmachen, dann können sie auch den alten Scheiß mal...
Ich weiß jetzt noch nicht ganz genau, wovon redest du, Dennis? Von welchem Gerät? Von welchem Device?
Die... Apple Remote hieß das irgendwie.
Es gab so eine Apple Remote, die ein Radio mit drin hatte.
Also ein Kopfhörer mit so einem Clip dran, mit Playbussen, das kommt unten ins... Ein iPod rein, genau.
In den Dock-Anschluss.
Ja, aber in den Dock-Anschluss.
Und da war ein Radio mit drin. Im iPod hast du dann irgendwie, wenn du das reingesteckt hast, kam so ein neues Menü, Radio hast du raufgegangen und dann hast du da so eine Digital-Anzeige mit so einem Sender und konntest da dann über den iPod dieses Radio steuern.
Ja, das wird interessant sein zu sehen, ob sie alte Sachen noch nachträglich unterstützen.
Ja, also ich hoffe, weil hat es echt die Euro gekostet, das scheiß Ding.
Na ja, Ruhe, du hast das ja für einen bestimmten Zweck gekauft, um zwar dir die Ausgabe wert zu fahren.
Eigentlich wollte ich nur die Fernbedienung haben, damit ich mein iPod immer nicht aus der Tasche holen muss.
Aber das, muss ich sagen, ist wahrscheinlich von allem, was sie angekündigt haben, das wichtigste Feature.
Definitiv.
Auch wenn das von vielen nicht so gesehen wird. Weil im Prinzip, was sie jetzt... Also ich sag mal, sie stimulieren jetzt einen Riesenmarkt von portabler Hardware, kluger Hardware, der eigentlich noch das User-Interface gefehlt hat. Das ist User-Interface, dafür ist das iPhone.
Das ist... Es wird...
Dein Auto...
Auto ist auch das erste, woran ich gedacht habe.
Man könnte das Auto auch damit lenken. Man könnte einfach mit dem Daumen...
Bin ich jetzt noch aus so einer Art dafür? Gerne auf einem anderen Kontinent. Nee, aber dass man irgendwelche Motorendaten, dass man irgendwelche Adressdaten, GPS-Daten, dass die ausgetauscht werden.
Ich glaube, dass es...
Dafür braucht man nicht viel Fantasie, um sich das vorzustellen.
Ich fand Ihre Beispiele auch wieder ganz kez. Gerade im medizinischen Bereich, da sind Sie ja irgendwie ganz gerne unterwegs, weil im Prinzip empfehlen Sie sich für eine ganz neue Generation von vertikalen Markt. Nämlich Custom, Hardware, für spezielle Anwendungen, auch in so super teuren Bereichen wie im Medical und so weiter. Und dass Sie eben dafür einfach das User Interface liefern. So ein iPod Touch kriegt nämlich jetzt, also das iPhone ist dann natürlich das eine, aber der Touch wird sozusagen jetzt auch so das Generic Interface, den kann man einfach nochmal dazukaufen, ohne das jetzt im Vertrag und so weiter.
Na das finde ich ja sowieso. Ich habe ja, ich glaube, es gibt es mittlerweile, insofern kann ich es auch mal laut sagen. Ich wollte ja immer mal ein Kassensystem rein auf Webbrowser-Basis und iPod Touch-Basis hochziehen. Weil in Geschäften haben die öfters mal diese kleinen, diese Handgeräte. Ich möchte nicht wissen, was die kosten, wo die dann reintippen, was du gerade gekauft hast. Und wenn dir damit irgendwie dann nicht eins runterfällt, dann wartest du wahrscheinlich vier Wochen bis das Neue kommt. Hingegen macht das auf iPod Touch-Basis über eine Webseite, nimm dafür 20 Euro oder sowas. Und wenn du eine zusätzliche Kasse brauchst, gehst du in den Laden, holst dir einen neuen iPod Touch, hängst den in deinen W-Laden und was die meisten Cafés heute sowieso haben oder die besseren. Und für solche Anwendungen wird das...
Es wird explodieren, ich glaube auch.
Es wird explodieren, ja.
Das ist wirklich ganz fett und sie werden, sie haben eine gute Chance, die Universal-Fernbedienung für alles zu werden.
Na das ist... Kameras, kann ich mir sehr schön vorstellen, dass man die da unten dran schließt.
Kameras? Was für Kameras?
Aber die...
Fotoapparate, um vom Urlaub aus eine höhere Bildqualität zu haben, um sie zu back-upen, um sie online zu stellen, YouTube-Videos zu machen.
Und die jetzt da ans Dock anschließen?
Nicht ans Dock, sondern unten an mein iPhone. Das ist halt das Dock. Ach so, an dem...
Der Dock-Connector, davon rede ich.
Ja, um die Daten rüberzukriegen.
Bluetooth-WLAN.
Damit wenn ich im Urlaub bin und Fotos mache, damit ich die unten anschließen kann und meinen Lieben einen schönen Urlaubsgruß schicken kann.
Ja gut.
Oder Video-Berichterstattung machen kann von unterwegs.
Naja, da weiß ich nicht so sehr, ob sie da... Ja gut, davon träume ich auch. Also, der Punkt ist, es liegt jetzt nicht mehr an Apple. Jeder kann im Prinzip so eine Applikation machen und du kannst über Bluetooth jetzt frei verfügen. Also es gibt jetzt endlich die Bluetooth-App.
Man könnte sogar GPS für alte Geräte nachrufen.
Man könnte auch... Interessanter Punkt. Die Frage ist, ob man das dann wiederum in das System-Framewandel reingebaut bekommen kann. Das wahrscheinlich nicht, aber wer weiß.
Und Sie haben dieses Routing vorgestellt, wo Sie meinten, man muss seine eigene Map mitbringen. Das habe ich doch nicht so ganz verstanden.
Genau, Karten. Dann kommen wir zu Karten. Also die Maps-Applikation wird weiterentwickelt. Das war jetzt kein großer Schocker, aber...
Die wird embeddable? Also dass man so eigene Programme einbetten kann?
Genau, das wird auch nochmal einen riesen Schub geben. Da fallen mir so aus dem Stand 10, 20 Programme ein, die das benutzen wollen.
Da braucht man auch nur auf Android zu gucken, ob die das da schon nutzen. Aber, wie heißt das? Turn-by-Turn?
Turn-by-Turn. Jetzt zulassen. Und ich frage mich, was eigentlich der Grund ist dafür, dass sie das jetzt zulassen und nicht schon vorher getan haben?
Ich nehme einfach an, dass sie die API jetzt bestimmte Vorhersagen unterstützt. Also bei Turn-by-Turn brauchst du ja mehr, da musst du ja noch einen Kompass mit einbauen, eine Richtung sozusagen, wie du gerade fährst. Und dass sie dafür jetzt einfach eine bessere Unterstützung drin haben.
Das heißt, sie holen das jetzt in Software aus dem Signal, wo sie es vorher nicht rausgeholt haben.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Oder es gab vielleicht schon immer den Kompass-Chip, aber sie haben ihn nie benutzt.
So was in der Richtung, würde ich vermuten.
Sie haben ja gesagt, dass das Update kommt für alle iPhones. Aber das alte iPhone, das haben sie explizit genannt? Bestimmte Dinge nicht kann, weil die Hardware es nicht kann. Das eine Beispiel dafür war...
Weiß der Teufel warum angeblich?
Genau. Da habe ich mich wirklich gefragt, was das jetzt soll.
Na, die wollen halt nur iPhones verkaufen.
Ja, aber kennst du jemanden, der sagt, oh, jetzt schmeiße ich mein altes iPhone weg?
Sag mir mal, die Hardware-Limitierung des ersten iPhones, die es verhindern soll, dass man damit eine MMS schickt und empfängt?
Na, weil es keinen 3G hat. Ja, aber dann hat die sagen, weil sonst ist bei den Bildern die Leitung geblockt.
Ich meine, die sprachen halt wirklich von einer Hardware-Limitierung und deswegen gibt es das nicht.
Also das andere, was sie nicht haben, ist Bluetooth-Audio-Übertragung.
Das liegt daran, dass einfach nicht der neuere Standard von Bluetooth drin ist. Oder dass der Stein, den sie da drin haben, aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht performt. Das kann ich nachvollziehen, aber das mit der MMS kann ich nicht nachvollziehen, weil das ist ja eigentlich eine rein logische Geschichte. Achso, kann das sein, dass der Baseband-Chip da irgendwas unterstützen muss?
Das ist eine Datenverbindung. Das ist die normale HTTP-Verbindung. Ich glaube, das ist sogar ein HTTP-Connect, den du aufmachst.
Über?
Über GPS oder 3G. Da gab es doch mal den hübschen Hack sogar, dass jemand...
Können Sie das nicht mit diesem Stein, den Sie da drin haben? Das machen Sie doch sowieso die ganze Zeit, um Ihre Daten... Ich hab...
also ich...
Wir sind unwissend. Ich guck mal, ob der Chat irgendwie mehr weiß. Hat der Chat hier irgendwie eine gute Erklärung dafür? Ich weiß es nicht. Basement? Also das scheint irgendwie ein bisschen der Grund zu sein. Irgendein Feature fehlt da drin, weil ich sehe jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht ein, warum Sie das dann nicht auch gleich in den ganz alten iPhones noch einschalten sollten. Dann kann es Ihnen eigentlich auch wurscht sein. Sie haben es halt eingebaut, weil die Telecoms das haben wollten. Und vielleicht drei oder vier Omas.
Genau. Wir waren aber gerade bei Navigation. Genau. Da ist aber Bring Your Own Card, Bring Your Own Map.
Ja, das wird natürlich super interessant, weil wird TomTom jetzt sozusagen endlich seine Applikation aufs iPhone bringen?
Was bringt dich dazu, das als Frage zu formulieren?
Na ja, weil ich mir auch immer noch vorstellen könnte, dass, was weiß ich, also ich sehe da zum Beispiel dieses Problem, dass es ja immer noch Bedingungen gibt, unter denen Programme dann so beendet werden. So, was weiß ich, das Einblenden von irgendwelchen Telefonanrufen und so weiter.
Da ist ja das Programm nicht sofort beendet.
So, und dann, wie kaufst du Karten nach? Wird TomTom dann die Karten über den iTunes-Store verkaufen?
Zum Beispiel. Ja, oder sie machen einfach ein Subscription-Modell. Also ich hab ja die Hoffnung, dass das der große Durchbruch für OpenStreetMap sein könnte. Naja, also das ist Kartenmaterial, was es so schon gibt.
Ja, aber OpenStreetMap taucht nicht für Verkehrsnavigation. Derzeit. Dazu empfehle ich dir Hausradio Express. Ich nehm mal kurz hiermit Eigenwerbung.
Und wenn sie diesen Podcast jetzt herunterladen, dann kriegen sie auch kostenlos dazu.
Aber ich hab mich genau über das Thema ausführlich unterhalten. CIE 113 zu OpenStreetMap und da war das auch ein Thema. Ich hab das natürlich hinterfragt und kurze Antwort ist, theoretisch für die Zukunft irgendwann mal vorstellbar, aber derzeit gibt es das Datenmaterial das so nicht her. Weil sonst muss man Sachen erfassen, die da so noch nicht erfasst werden.
Ist auf jeden Fall was, was das gut unterstützen könnte.
Aber grundsätzlich wäre das natürlich auch zu begrüßen.
Lizenzfreie Karten, übers Netz verfügbar, das Gerät ist da.
Könnte man auch heute schon verwenden, das ist so ein Ding. Aber hier geht es wirklich um das Kartenmaterial von diesen Providern selber. Hier geht es um Tederatlas und so weiter. Das, was schon TomTom und die ganzen anderen Navigationsanbieter haben. Und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, es gibt ja in den USA auch jetzt schon irgendwie so eine Anwendung, die Turn-by-Turn irgendwie macht. Das ist alles irgendwie so ein bisschen fishy. Also es gibt schon so eine Anwendung, die für die USA sowas anbietet. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sie nur angekündigt war oder ob sie wirklich schon im Upstore verfügbar ist. Keine Ahnung. Also wie auch immer, wir werden das sehen. Ich denke, dass es Anbieter geben wird. Und TomTom hatte ja am Anfang schon sehr früh gesagt, dass sie ja im Prinzip bereit wären, das zu tun. Jetzt hätte ich bloß ganz gerne noch einen iPod Touch mit GPS, dann würde ich mir sogar noch einen dafür kaufen.
Worauf ich ja eigentlich warte, dass das eine vernünftige Sprachansage dann kommt, weil ich hab ja, ich möchte ja gern sowas haben, dass ich fahre, ich hab ja kein Auto, ich bin ja Radfahrer.
Wenn dieses Nano-Ding das kann, dann kann das iPhone es auch.
Dass ich einen Kopfhörer drin habe, und dass mir dann die Stimme ansagt, und nächste bitte nach links abbiegen, und dass ich dann...
Ja, dass diese Software dann wohl kann. Na hoffentlich, oder? Wenn das ein Tom-Tom kann, dann können sie das auch an dem iPhone machen. Ich meine, das ist alles nur eine Frage. Muss ja halt nur programmieren.
Also sollte sich mal was vernünftiges ausdenken.
Da müssen ja keine Textos Speech machen, ich meine, die Ansagen...
Ja natürlich, die haben sie auf Band, das ist ja gar keine Frage.
Auf Band!
Flash! Das haben die auf Flashram!
Das ist ja, ich hab jetzt... Die sagen ja mittlerweile Straßennamen an. Irgendwo müssen wir arme Menschen sitzen und Straßennamen die ganzen Tage über vorlesen. Von wichtigen Straßen. Das stimmt, das ist unglaublich.
Na vielleicht machen sie das mit Textos Speech und dann hören sie sich die bloß nur an, ob sie irgendwie scheiße sind und trimmen die dann unter Umständen noch. Wahrscheinlich lassen sie die Straßennamen einfach im Flur laufen. Wenn die Leute irgendwie am Watercooler stehen, dann müssen sie die ganze Zeit so Heinrich-Heine-Straße, Leopoldplatz und so über sich ergehen lassen.
Nein, Tim, ich glaube das machen die nicht.
Naja, ich hätte was sie nicht angekündigt haben, ich hab mir einiges notiert, was sie nicht angekündigt haben, aber jetzt bei Maps ganz konkret, ich verstehe nicht, warum man diesen Terrain-Modus da nicht einschalten kann. Es gibt nur Satelliten und Karten.
Du willst so nach hinten kippen?
Nee, den Terrain-Modus, den es online gibt.
Der ist vielleicht noch zu neu, kann das sein?
Was heißt denn zu neu, da machst du einen Button und sagst, gib mir Terrain anstatt Satelliten.
Ich glaube, da stehen noch zwischen diesen einen Button und den einzubauen, stehen ungefähr 48.000 Anwälte, die auf diversen Seiten... Na ja, das ist doch alles ein Lizenzproblem, die müssen noch Verträge machen mit Google, welche Karten sie genau kriegen, und dann müssen sie Lizenzverträge machen mit... Das könnte auch ein Grund... Also angeblich war das auch der Grund, warum Maps anfangs gelten.
Dann können die sich da einigen. Ich hätte auf jeden Fall gerne die Maps. Ich hab nämlich gemerkt, dass wenn du irgendwie in der Pampa unterwegs bist, und du suchst irgendwie mal ein See und Wald...
Dann hilft dir so eine graue Fläche nicht so richtig viel weiter.
Dann hilft mir so eine graue Fläche. Der See ist da zwar noch drauf, aber du weißt einfach nicht, wo oben und unten ist, und du siehst nicht, wo die Berge und die Hügel sind. Und was ihr alle mal einbauen könnt, ist irgendwie einem zu sagen, ob so eine Scheißstraße Kopfsteinpflaster hat oder nicht. Ich hab mich da irgendwie verfahren und bin dann irgendwie auf so einer Straße gelandet, wo ich dann irgendwie so 5 Kilometer hartestes ostdeutsches Kopfsteinpflaster unter dem Arsch hatte.
Und das war keine Freude.
Gut, Push-Notifications wurden noch angekündigt. Also sie haben nichts Neues gesagt, außer das, was sie schon vorher gesagt haben.
Sie haben exakt das Gleiche wiederholt.
Sogar die gleichen Slides, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Im Wesentlichen schon.
Ja, ich bin gespannt.
Und doch, die einzige Ausrede war, weil es... Nicht skaliert hätte, weil so großer Erfolg und so. Und sie einfach noch mal ihre Infrastruktur neu machen muss.
Den großen Erfolg verschoben.
Naja, die haben, ich glaub, die haben, die haben...
Sie haben einfach mit ihr...
Die haben gesehen, wie billig das bei uns läuft.
Konfusion.
Das können wir auch noch zwei Wochen später machen.
Disclaimer, wir sind kein Apple-Service.
Auch wenn wir manchmal so schlecht funktionieren.
Steve ist reingegangen und hat gesagt, wenn das nicht läuft, seid ihr alle entlassen. Und dann haben sie gesagt, oh, oh, oh.
Nee, die haben sich einfach die Zahlen mal von... Ich glaub, sie haben ja auch, glaub ich, ESPN mal als Beispiel genannt. Das war aber jetzt glaub ich nicht in der Keynote selber, das kam irgendwie danach, glaub ich, bei einer Nachfrage. Und die haben denen irgendwie mal gesagt, wie viele Notifications die so raushauen an ihre Kunden, weil die diese ganzen irgendwie Basketballspiele und so weiter...
Der Sporttyp wieder.
Genau. Und das war wohl so im Millionenbereich irgendwie pro Tag. Und da sind sie so ein bisschen so mäßig zusammengezuckt. Und dann haben sie nochmal drüber nachgedacht, ob sie das leisten können. Wie auch immer. Ich hab kein Problem damit, dass sie lange drüber nachdenken, wenn es dann beim ersten Mal funktioniert.
Aber dann kostet es auch nichts, oder?
Was? Die Push-Notification? Die Developer?
Ich schreib jetzt ein Programm, so was wie dieses ESPN-Zeugs, nur ich nehm gar kein Geld für mein Programm, nutz aber fett irgendwie für tausende von Nachrichten diesen Service am Tag. Und es kostet nicht nix?
Ich weiß es nicht. Sie haben sich dazu nicht geäußert.
Oder geht's dann nur mit Mobile... Was heißt das jetzt? Mobile Max?
Nein, das muss schon mit. Ihr seid ja konfus.
Wir sollten doch irgendwie 99 Dollar im Jahr nehmen. Du wirst schon die ganze Zeit verwechseln.
Und dann die ganze Zeit nicht funktionieren.
Und dann setzen wir einen Blog auf ohne ESPN.
Wenn man Mobile Me sagt, dann denk ich ja mal, ich mein ja mich, weil Mobile Me mich, ich bin ja aber hier, also das ist es nicht, also das ist es an und dann sag ich Mobile Max und dann ist es zu spät.
Wir sollten ihnen ein Sees and Desist Letter schreiben. So geht es nicht weiter, das ist einfach eine Vermischung.
Wir verklagen die.
Ja, wir verklagen die.
Das ist jetzt so unfällig.
Genau.
Zieht euch warm an.
So, jetzt kommt der erste Slide, den ich analysiert habe. Slide-Analyse bei Tim. Und ja, da waren noch einige interessante Sachen rauszulesen. Erstmal die, die sie so groß gemacht haben, also die er ja auch nochmal kurz erwähnt hat, so ein paar möchte ich erwähnen, hat er gesagt. Die fand ich schon interessant. HTTP-Streaming-Audio-Video.
Das ist jetzt wichtig, damit man live Video machen kann.
Naja, damit hast du halt Streaming. Aber mit Streaming, im API, supported und so weiter. Ein Programm kann sagen, ich will diesen Stream jetzt hier angezeigt bekommen, Video.
Wir könnten eine eigene Mobile-Max-Applikation machen.
Ja, also das könnte dazu führen, dass da mehr standardisierte User-Interfaces und Verhaltensweisen und performante Audio- und Video-Wiedergabe stattfindet. Das wird natürlich alles nur mit MPEG-4 funktionieren, das ist ja ganz klar. Bei Audio bin ich mir nicht ganz so sicher, wenn sie auch MP3 machen, fände ich das ganz gut, weil da sollte sie eigentlich nichts von abhalten, da sie ja MP3 generell unterstützen. Dann haben sie noch rumgeprallt mit In-App-E-Mail.
Das hat mich ein bisschen traurig gemacht. Warum?
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Also erst mal In-App-E-Mail, das ist, dass jedes Programm......
eine Mail verschicken kann, ohne beendet zu werden.
Genau, also da geht so ein Cheat auf, als ob du Mail starten würdest.
Genau.
Und der Grund, warum mich das ein bisschen traurig macht, ist, ich finde, einer der wesentlichen Nachteile des iPhones ist, gar nicht mal so sehr, dass man nicht mehrere Programme gleichzeitig ausführen kann, sondern dass man nicht schnell hin und her wechseln kann zwischen zwei Programmen. Also jeder RSS-Reader, den ich kenne, und jeder Twitter-Client hat zum Beispiel einen kleinen Webbrowser eingebaut. Warum? Wenn ich erst großartig beim Anklicken eines Links Safari starte, muss ich danach auf den Home-Button klicken, muss wieder das Alken raussuchen, den Twitter-Client starten und erst dann ist er wieder da oder den Reader. Und ich hatte ein bisschen drauf gehofft, dass sie das mal so ein bisschen, so eine User-Interface-Änderung machen in der Richtung, dass man schnell wieder zurückwechseln kann zu einem anderen Programm, da sie aber jetzt diese Sheets einbauen und nicht sagen einfach, hey, dann machst du halt ein Mail-True-Link und...
Du willst das machen, was Palm angekündigt hat.
Ich möchte gern zurück...
Nö, Programme, die laufen, Hintergrundprogramme.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es unbedingt Hintergrundprozesse sein müssen, aber eben, dass man möglichst schnell wieder zurückwechseln kann. Na, wie die Tabs in Safari zum Beispiel. Das geht ja auch auf dem iPhone.
Won't happen. Zumindest haben sie das nicht angekündigt. Ich denke, dass da immer noch ein bisschen Luft ist.
Ja, aber dadurch, dass sie eine andere Lösung für dieses Problem propagieren, offensichtlich gehe ich davon aus, dass sie von mir auf den Weg nicht gehen.
Aber du wirst akzeptieren, viele Programme haben den Bedarf, mal eine Mail zu verschicken und dass sie dafür nicht beendet werden, ist ganz sinnvoll. Trotzdem kriegen sie es sozusagen vom System abgenommen. Das heißt, du musst den ganzen Mail-Scheiß nicht programmieren. Was ich so ein Fragezeichen im Kopf hatte, ist in-game-Voice. Habt ihr das verstanden, was sie damit meinten?
Na, du kannst während du spielst, zum Beispiel über das WLAN, kannst du chatten mit der anderen Person.
Voice-Chat.
Multiplayer-Voice-Chat. Genau.
Ja, heißt das das?
Ja, das heißt das.
Und wie funktioniert das dann? Also ich meine, mit wem kann man dann?
Mit seinen anderen Mitspielern.
Achso, das heißt, das Protokoll muss man schon auch selber programmieren, aber sie erlauben die Möglichkeit, das Mikrofon einzuschalten oder was?
Vielleicht unterstützen sie ja auch direkt. Vielleicht haben sie ein eigenes Protokoll.
Protokoll, das heißt, die haben halt iChat für in-game aufgemacht.
Das wäre natürlich, das wäre natürlich, also eigentlich kommt ja Voice-Over-LP damit so ein bisschen über...
Ich meine, was ist der Unterschied zwischen jetzt einfach das Mikrofon anzumachen und Lautsprecher zu bedienen? Das kannst du doch jetzt auch schon. Aber was ist dann was ist dann sozusagen das Neue? Also wenn da jetzt...
Ich nehme an, dass du das ganze Protokoll unten drunter abpappen.
Welches Protokoll?
Dass du direkt einen Echtzeit-Chat dabei hast.
Du meinst, dass da ein Netzwerkprotokoll mitimplementiert ist?
Vermutlich mal. Aber ohne jetzt...
Das glaube ich halt nicht. Weil ich glaube, dass die Games haben da sowieso im Wesentlichen ihre eigenen Protokolle und ihre eigenen Server und so weiter und dass Apple denen da gar nichts diktieren kann. Und dass es eigentlich nur darum geht, dass die Art und Weise, wie mit Mikrofon und Lautsprecher umgegangen wird, dass das sozusagen einheitlich supported wird. Aber, I don't know, das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden.
Ist auch ein bisschen unklar.
Okay, was noch ein richtiges Biggie ist, ist iPod Library Access. Das heißt, alle Programme können jetzt auf die iPod Library zugreifen und die... ja, keine Ahnung, was sie können. Sie können dann...
Alles.
Abspielen. Brausen.
Hoffentlich kann man auch einstellen.
Anzeigen. Einstellen inwiefern?
Dass nicht jedes Programm in allen meinen Daten rumfuschen kann.
Auslesen und nach Hause telefonieren.
Also gerade bei der iPod-Bibliothek hätte ich damit relativ wenig Probleme. Das ist mein Adressbuch, mir doch eher ein bisschen heiliger.
Und da kommen sie eh schon an, richtig?
Ja, also, na gut, da hätte ich jetzt nicht so viel Angst, weil wenn ein Programm sowas macht, dann ist es halt auch schnell aus dem Store, also von daher...
Na, es gab da doch ganz am Anfang... Das hat keiner so richtig mitbekommen. Das hat eine ganze Weile gedauert, bis es ist. Hat irgendein aufmerksamer Nutzer, glaube ich, bemerkt, dass das Adressbuch dann bei einem Spiel mitgesendet wurde.
Ja gut, aber es wurde halt bemerkt und es wurde eben auch sofort sanktioniert und jetzt sind die auch wieder brav. Das funktioniert schon ganz gut. Auf jeden Fall, das gibt es. Das wird nochmal ganz interessant sein, zu sehen, was sie können. Dann haben sie den Proximity-Sensor noch erwähnt. Das ist das, was diese Google- Voice-Eingabe-Applikation schon benutzt hat. Nämlich, dass sozusagen das Mikrofon in dem Moment eingeschaltet wird, wo du es ans Ohr hältst. Also der Sensor, der derzeit dafür sorgt, dass der Bildschirm ausgeschaltet wird und Touch ausgeschaltet wird, das ist etwas, was du jetzt abfragen kannst. Das heißt, dein Programm kann auf die Geste, ich nehme mein Telefon und halte sie ans Ohr, reagieren.
Das ist natürlich ein ganz hübscher Gest, mir fällt gerade auf, damit könnte man ja auch so tolle Sachen machen. Wenn ich mein iPhone vom Gesicht nehme, dass es dann automatisch das Mikro abschaltet.
Beziehungsweise einschaltet, wenn es ans Ohr macht.
Eigentlich eine praktische Sache.
Was meinst du, dass die normale Telefon-Applikation das machen könnte? Das hätten sie auch jetzt schon machen können.
Ja, ich weiß, dass sie das schon, aber ich fällt mir gerade auf, dass es für sowas ja taugt.
Das wäre eine interessante Option. Man macht es weg und immer wenn der Bildschirm zu sehen ist, ist man automatisch dumm. Na ja, keine Ahnung. Das will man eh selektierbar machen. Das kannst du ja, wenn du das Mikrofon ausschalten kannst.
Ist jetzt nicht das, was ich jetzt deswegen, dass man schlaglose Rechte bereitet.
Okay, I get your point. Aber da gibt es sicherlich interessante Anwendungen dafür. Ja, und dann haben sie gesagt, dass sie Core Data einbauen. Das ist natürlich eine große Änderung, weil das war derzeit noch strangely missing. Also, die iPhone Entwicklungsumgebung hat eben nicht eine der Kernfeatures, die bei Leopard dazugekommen sind, nämlich Core Data.
Von der alle so unglaublich geschwärmt haben.
Ja, Core Data ist insofern ganz sinnvoll, als dass es dir eben ein umfangreiches Framework zum Speichern von Daten und dem auch entsprechend hin und her. Also ich denke, dass das auch eine Voraussetzung war für Copy und Paste.
Nee, kann es nicht sein, weil ansonsten hätte es vor Leopard kein Copy und Paste gegeben.
Das ist nicht das Copy und Paste vom Mac. Das ist das Copy und Paste vom iPhone. Da weißt du nicht, wie das funktioniert. Sonst kann es schon sein, dass das sehr viel high-leveliger ist.
Aber wozu haben wir bei Copy und Paste Core Data?
Für komplexe Datentypen, sowie die Fotos, die du auch kopieren kannst.
Aber Core Data ist doch, wie du schon sagtest, mehr zum Speichern und so weiter, ist doch der Datentyp egal. Also ich glaube...
Der Datentyp ist egal bei Copy und Paste? Vielleicht hab ich auch nicht recht. Aber Core Data bietet auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit, eben abstrakt deine Daten zu strukturieren. Und das Betriebssystem übernimmt halt die Serialisierung, das Speichern, das Wiedereinlesen und so weiter. Und das ist auf jeden Fall für jedes Programm gut. Und das haben sie mit drin. Und ob das jetzt... Also ob Copy und Paste damit zusammenhängt, weiß ich nicht. Würde mich aber auch nicht überraschen, dass das zeitgleich kommt. So, jetzt kommen die ganzen kleinen Sachen. Da hatten sie so sinnlose Sachen wie Cell Styles. Das heißt, du kannst wahrscheinlich in den Listen und so weiter die Optik der Tabelle, die da so durchscrollt, irgendwie anpassen.
Wenn das nur so wenig ist. Nee, warte mal. Keine Ahnung.
Mehr stand da nicht.
Cell Styles gibt es wahrscheinlich. Also bisher hast du ja, wenn du mit dem Interface Builder dir so eine Zelle machst, da geht eigentlich erstmal nix weiter. Außer... Nee, du machst die gar nicht mehr mit dem Interface Builder. Na, kannst du wahrscheinlich. Jedenfalls eine normale Zelle ist erstmal nur Text und sonst nix. Und mit Cell Style hast du vielleicht so paar Templates oder so.
Aber hat man nicht gerade auf dem iPhone, hab ich mir neulich sagen lassen, gerade bei diesen durchscrollbaren Tabellen viel, viel mehr Möglichkeiten, wie dass man da sogar komplette Animationen reinschmeißen kann und so was, was auf dem Desktop nicht geht, auf dem Mac OS?
Ja, eine Zelle auf dem iPhone ist immer ein View.
Genau.
Da kannst du halt reinpacken, was du willst. Aber es ist gar nicht so easy. Das musst du ja alle selber zusammenbasteln.
Keine Ahnung, wir wissen nicht mehr, als diese zwei Worte, die da standen. Soll ich das hier noch mal ein bisschen rüber drehen, dass du jetzt nicht so ausgeschlossen fühlst? Nur weil ich wieder der einzige bin, der sich hier Notizen macht. Ich muss bloß aufpassen, dass ich die Kabel nicht abreiße. So, dann haben sie hier Bluetooth-Stereo beziehungsweise ATODP. Das unterstützen sie jetzt, dass man eben auch ein Bluetooth-Headset hat. Ich frage mich, ob es die Möglichkeit auch gibt, ein Bluetooth-Headset zu haben, was auch die Kontrolls hat. Also auch Lautstärke verändern und so weiter. Das wäre ja mal ganz interessant.
Und ein Mikro dann halt.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall cool so für Car-Stereo. Das heißt, ein Auto könnte jetzt auch Bluetooth-Lautsprecher sein.
Stimmt, das ist natürlich wirklich praktisch.
Dann bräuchst du diesen ganzen Radio-Scheiß nicht mehr, sondern um dein Telefon, Wireless, einfach nur das Audio abspielen zu lassen, bräuchst du dein Auto eigentlich nur noch einen Bluetooth-Empfänger und müsstest sagen, hallo, ich bin ein Bluetooth-Lautsprecher. Ausnahmsweise hab ich mal was gesagt, was mal ganz gut ist.
Ausnahmsweise kommt der nicht mit dem Audio-Recorder an.
Dann stand da noch Battery-API, also die Programme können offensichtlich jetzt auch den Ladezustand in irgendeiner Form monitoren, was ihnen vielleicht die Möglichkeit gibt zu warnen. Irgendwie, ich habe nur noch Akku für fünf Minuten.
Bestimmte Sachen abzuschalten.
Nehme gerade hier was Wichtiges auf. Warnung, Alert, irgendwie geänderte Hintergrundfarbe.
Data Detectors?
Ja, die Data Detectors, da bin ich ja ein großer Freund von. Die sind ja nicht so beliebt, aber ich finde das ja ganz toll. Ich benutze das auch täglich. So, wenn ich so eine Mail bekomme, wo mich jemand einlädt und dann kann man dann eine Mail ab so schön rüber hofern und sagen, ah, dann sagt er hier, das ist ja wohl ein Termin und so und dann kann ich den einfach in iCal anlegen.
So ein bisschen untergegangen, oder?
Gab es übrigens früher schon unter Mac OS 8.9. Gab es schon Data Detectors und da haben die auch schon ganz interessant funktioniert. Und jetzt kommt das wieder so langsam. Die haben sie irgendwie nochmal from the ground up neu gemacht. Wofür sie die jetzt hier benutzen, weiß ich nicht, aber ich vermute mal auch in einem E-Mail, dass wenn du jetzt eine E-Mail empfängst und da ist irgendwie absurdes Zeug drin, dass eben der Data Detector dir dabei hilft, da komplexe Daten draus zu geben.
Für Telefonnummern und SMS zum Beispiel.
Du kannst ja jetzt auch Termine erzeugen, Meeting Invitations erzeugen zum Beispiel, also sie verbessern das schon auf dem iPhone. Nee, Termine könnte man schon vorher erzeugen. Nur die Einladung kannst du das machen. Datadetektors, dann stand da noch, und ich habe nichts gefunden, worauf das hinweisen könnte, da stand GPS-Lingo. Ich habe keine Ahnung. GPS hat ja nichts mit Turn-By-Turn, so direkt. Du brauchst es aber. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe nichts gefunden. Ich habe gesucht, aber überall, wo GPS-Lingo auf Webseiten stand, da war immer nur so von der, von dem Glossar, sozusagen.
Manche Sachen waren nur so, vielleicht auch.
Highlighted Images stand da noch drauf.
Was ist das?
Keine Ahnung. Kannst wahrscheinlich Bilder, Highlighten, was auch immer. Das ist Developer-Scheiße auch. Localized Collation, ich schätze mal, dass du halt einfach mehrere Methoden hast, wie du jetzt Listen sortieren kannst. Kannst sagen, sortier das mal nach Deutsch. Dass ein äh, ein öh, ein üh auch richtig einsortiert wird. Navbars, also Navigationbars, gibt's irgendwie mehr Kontrolle darüber. Man kann URLs irgendwie öffnen. Also dafür gibt's zumindest eine API. Es gibt eine Shake-API.
Die gibt's aber jetzt auch schon. Shake-API hab ich ja. Man kann Andu machen per Shake, ne? Das ist jetzt, bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie das läuft.
Andu per Shake, ja genau. Ah ja, stimmt, bei dem Copy und Paste. Genau, mit dem, das ist auch ganz interessant. Ja, Text-Selection, das ist natürlich dasselbe wie bei Copy und Paste. Dann war noch von Toolbars die Rede.
Gibt's ja eigentlich auch schon.
Was auch immer.
Wahrscheinlich erweitert.
Dann so diverse UI-Sachen.
Gibt's alles schon, alles in Erweiterung.
Okay, da frage ich mich, was da neu ist. View-Controller stand da auch noch. Und dann stand da noch was mit kleines I, großes AP. Da habe ich überhaupt keine Ahnung, was das sein könnte. Hat der Chat da vielleicht irgendwie eine Ahnung, was das sein könnte? Kleines I, großes AP.
Ach, das wird wahrscheinlich dieses Internet Express Point sein, dass es jetzt die Möglichkeit geben.
Dieser Hotspot-Login-Geschichte?
Genau. Das man bei...
Nein, das stand aber noch mal separat bei den...
Das war doch auf der Seite, wo sie alle Features drin hatten, oder?
Da stand I, AP.
Ich weiß es nicht, du hast es aufgeschrieben.
Nein, ich glaube, da stand noch eine andere Seite. Da war das Wifi-Kram. Das war noch mal separat. Das ist ja hier noch für Developer. Das ist irgendwie ein Developer-Kram. Keine Ahnung. Naja, was auch immer.
Was sie überhaupt nicht erwähnt haben, ist der nächste Punkt auf deiner Liste. Oder willst du den erstmal auslassen?
Nein, das ist natürlich auch noch ein wichtiges Thema. Was sie da, also, ich weiß gar nicht, haben sie das da überhaupt erwähnt?
Nee, Tethering haben sie überhaupt nicht erwähnt.
Doch, aber in der Q&A danach.
Ah ja, genau.
Wir dürfen drüber reden, je.
Okay, sie haben angekündigt, dass es jetzt möglich sein wird, über das iPhone ins Internet zu gehen. Hurra! Aber... Nee, erstmal muss man sagen, und was cool ist da dran, sie machen es sowohl über Bluetooth als auch über USB. Was ich cool finde, weil manchmal finde ich USB besser, manchmal finde ich Bluetooth besser. Weil USB heißt... Strom. Wenn das Ding dransteckt, dann hast du einfach auch Stromversorgung. Und Bluetooth ist halt cooler, wenn du eben mal Rechner aufklappst, egal in welcher Tasche jetzt dein iPhone steckt, Hauptsache ist es irgendwie noch in der Nähe. Dann hast du halt mal eben ein bisschen Netz. Na Jungs, könnt ihr überhaupt noch?
Zwischen Bluetooth und USB auch noch ziemlich hin und her schalten könnte, dass du in einem Zug sitzt und noch irgendwie USB hast und dann musst du irgendwie aussteigen, ziehst ab und so und geht erstmal weiter.
Lässt deinen Rechner aufgeklappt und brauchst nicht den Pornostreet aufzubrechen, wie er den aus dem Zug ausbricht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktionieren wird. Da wird der Mac schon irgendwie... Aber sie werden auf jeden Fall den Bluetooth-Zugang nicht über PPP machen, das kann ich dir sicher sagen, sondern das geht auch über PAN. Den Support haben sie ja schon drin im Mac OS X. Und mit allen Telefonen, weißt du noch, das ging mit unserem Sony... Hast du das nicht mal ausprobiert sogar? Da taucht das Ding irgendwie auf mit Hallo, ich bin Netzzugang. Und dann routest du da einfach... Du musst dich mit deinem Telefon PPP bringen.
Das OS X ist ein normaler Leopard, kann das schon.
Ja, das ist echt großartig. Das ist quasi dein Handy, so was wie so ein Brouter.
Genau.
Und verbraucht halt viel weniger als WLAN, deswegen haben sie halt Bluetooth gemacht.
Vor allem, du hast diesen scheiß Dial-Up-State nicht. Du musst nicht anwählen und dann modem und so ein Kack, sondern du hast halt einfach ein Brouter.
Du kannst hollö, wie beliebig viele Geräte reinhängen, also kannst du auch zu zweit drauf surfen.
Wird natürlich sehr spannend sein, zu sehen, wie dieses Tethering hier in Deutschland einschlägt, weil jetzt gerade die... Vielleicht erklärt das, warum die Telekom jetzt diese Nutzung der Zweit-SIM-Karte wieder abschafft.
Na ja, so richtig glaube ich.
Jetzt kann man das sozusagen über das iPhone nutzen und jetzt geben sie nicht noch mal eine zweite Karte raus. Aber macht ja eigentlich auch keinen Zweifel.
Ich meine, das ist ja...
Es ist völlig unklar, was die Telekom macht.
Also ich meine, in dem Zusammenhang kann ja durchaus mal erwähnt werden, Skype soll ja heute bzw. morgen kommen fürs iPhone und da hat die Telekom mir ja jetzt schon gesagt...
Das sperren wir.
Nicht nur übers Funknetz, sondern möglicherweise sogar über ihre Hotspots sind sie am überlegen.
Wir haben so den Arsch offen.
Auf jeden.
Medorn! Medorn ist wieder frei. Der könnte doch jetzt zur Telekom gehen. Der hat wenigstens bis der Junge.
Ja, aber meinst du, dass der...
Ich find ja Medorn cool. Ich find ja, ich versteh ja nicht, warum die alle... Ich find das wirklich schade, dass der jetzt weggeht.
Der interessiert sich noch für seine Mitarbeiter.
Jetzt wird der Bahnservice... Der Bahnservice wird jetzt bestimmt schlechter. Und ich muss es ausbahnen.
Der interessiert sich für ihre privaten Dinge.
Du musst es ausbahnen.
Der Junge hat bis, ist das ja. Der könnte da noch was...
Auf jeden Fall hat er sich jetzt sehr an den Stuhl verbissen gehabt, das stimmt.
Kalenderfunktionen. Wir sind noch nicht am Ende, aber bald. Kalender kann jetzt CalDAF und Kalender kann jetzt Subscriptions.
Oh mein Gott!
Sie können mir jetzt die Termine sogar gleich aufs iPhone pushen.
Ich hoffe, dass das bedeutet, dass die Subscriptions, die ich in iCal habe, auch gesyncht werden. Ich vermute mal, aber wir werden es sehen. Auf jeden Fall, und CalDAF ist natürlich sehr sinnvoll, weil dadurch hast du endlich mal ein Standard-Shared-Kalender-Interface, was du auch vom iPhone aus nutzen kannst. Das würde dann auch sehr sinnvoll sein im Zusammenhang mit so einem Mac OS X Server. Weil dann hätte man wieder mal ein Incentive, sich selber aufzusetzen, ohne irgendwelchen Mobile-Me-Klimbem, kannst du dann einfach deinen eigenen Kalenderserver hosten.
Auf jeden Fall hätte sich Google das jetzt schön sparen können, Exchange extra zu lizenzieren für ihren, wie heißt es, Google Synchronize oder Google Sync? Naja, einer der Hauptgründe wird, oder einer der wichtigsten Gründe wird fürs iPhone gewesen sein, die ganzen Windows-Mobile-Geräte auch.
Könnt ihr das eigentlich? Kann Windows Mobile Geräte Exchange?
Ich gehe absolut fest davon aus.
Du gehst davon aus, aber du weißt es auch nicht.
Naja, ich hatte noch nie so ein Gerät. Ich meine, die können auch sonst nichts. Irgendwas müssen wir auch können.
Naja, wer weiß.
Also ich meine ansonsten wäre es ja, ansonsten hätte das iPhone das auch nicht gehard count.
Ja, der Chat meint, die können das. Ich finde das nicht so eine Selbstverständlichkeit, dass Microsoft seine eigenen Protokolle unterstützt.
Also ich meine, das war doch der Hauptgrund, warum Apple das gemacht hat, um in diesen Corporate-Markt reinzukommen.
Ja, aber nicht weil die Windows-Mobile-Geräte das auch können, sondern weil das einfach ein iPhone können muss, weil das die einzige Möglichkeit ist, da rauszukommen. Wie auch immer, ist ja auch egal. So, über Stocks brauchen wir glaube ich nicht zu reden. Das ist für mich völlig uninteressant. Ich meine jetzt, wo der Aktienmarkt sowieso am Ende ist, hätten sie ja auch einfach eine Flatline.
Jetzt kann man sie als feste Grafik. Jetzt kann man es besser sehen.
Und warum? Man könnte doch bei den Stocks den Beschleunigungssensor noch auslesen. Dass man die Stocks auch so drehen kann.
Automatisch verkaufen, wenn man anfängt so zu machen, verkauft man automatisch, wenn man in die andere Richtung dreht, dann kauft er.
Nee, wenn du so frustriert irgendwie nach rechts kippst und dir denkst, oh scheiße, meine Stocks gehen schon wieder nach unten und du sinkst so mit dem Körper nach unten, dann gehen sie auch gleich wieder hoch.
Das ist auch für den App Store ganz praktisch. Dann könnten Sie nämlich direkt, wollen Sie einen Serienkiller auf Sie selber ansetzen lassen für nur 500 Dollar. Brauchst du nicht mehr einen App Store für.
So, aber jetzt kommt das noch ein cooles Feature. Man kann jetzt endlich überall suchen. Ich hab das hier mal auf dem iPhone OS 3.0 gerade ausprobiert. Und jetzt kann man sogar nach Nicknames suchen. Hurra! Ich kann endlich die Namen, die ich für meine Leute sowieso im Wesentlichen verwende, auch mal benutzen, um danach zu suchen.
Aber ich finde das mal Spotlight auf dem iPhone echt ein krasses Ding. Einfach insofern. Textinterface.
Ich bin gespannt, also wie, ich frage mich, ob ein Programm in der Lage ist, seinen Content durchsuchbar zu machen.
Da hab ich gerade vorhin ein schönes Ding offen gehabt, ich suche den mal raus. Und zwar hat da jemand ein Search-Bundle geschrieben fürs iPhone OS 3.0, das heißt calculator.search-bundle. Und der hat nämlich eine Erweiterung geschrieben für das iPhone, mit dem man darüber einen kleinen Taschenrechner zur Verfügung hat.
Insofern, ja, das geht. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt das selbe ist. Was du meinst, ist ein Bundle, was in den Search reinplugt.
In die Spotlight-Suche reinplugt und auf eigene Daten aufsichtig zugreift.
Ach so, verstehe. Das heißt, ein Programmierer könnte ein eigenes Search-Bundle dazu machen, um seine eigenen Sachen durch Super zu machen. Aber auf dem Mac ist es ja derzeit so, dass du nur einen Bundle bereitstellen musst, um deine Dateien indizieren lassen zu können. Aber derzeit sind ja die Programme in so ganz eigenen Sandboxen.
Glaubst du, dass es eine echte Indizierung gibt auf dem iPhone? Da hast du doch nur eine ganz andere Problematik als auf dem Desktop.
Weil du an die Daten ja eigentlich nicht rankommst, weil die Programme voneinander isoliert sind in den Sandboxen. Deswegen meine ich, es ist knifflig.
Na ja, aber du hast doch ganz andere Daten. Also du hast doch nicht irgendwie, du hast doch nicht andere Daten. Na ja, auf einer Festplatte hast du 5000 Word-Dokumente oder so was oder irgendwelche Mails rumfliegen und so in einzelnen Dateien. Also das ist doch eine ganz klassisch gesehen eine ganz andere Struktur, wohingegen auf dem iPhone haben die meisten Programme wahrscheinlich irgendwo eine Datenbank im Hintergrund und schmeißen zum Beispiel eine SQLite-Datenbank und schmeißen die dann einfach an.
Na ja, aber warum soll ich diese lokal gespeicherten Datenbanken nicht auch durchsuchen können? Ich meine, das ist doch der Sinn einer Suche.
Ja klar, das machen sie dann in dem wahrscheinlich für SQLite-Datenbanken wird wahrscheinlich ein Search-Bundle direkt mit beim SDK beiliegen als Beispiel.
Ja, aber diese Calculator-Beispiel, das weiß ich nicht, ob das ausreicht, weil es ja nur...
Vielleicht haben sie noch die andere Variante mit drin. Aber auf jeden Fall geht das.
Der rechnet ja selber, der kommuniziert ja nicht mit der Calculator-Applikation, sondern es geht ja hier darum, dass du auch die Daten, die in einer Sandbox eines anderen Programms, was auf deinem iPhone installiert ist, zugreifst. Also, dass man das irgendwie auch indizieren und finden kann.
Na ja, aber ich meine, Spotlight muss ja Zugriffsrechte haben auf höherer Ebene. Also, das muss ja gehen.
Die rechnen da?
Wieso auf höherer Ebene?
Nee, das hat er geschrieben. Das ist so eine Erweiterung, die er geschrieben hat, damit man damit erleuchern kann.
Na ja, wir werden es sehen. Auf jeden Fall kann man nach allem, was irgendwie exposed ist, suchen. Und das scheint auch ganz gut zu funktionieren. Und ich hab auch den Eindruck, dass das ganz flink war. Aber vielleicht liegt es auch daran, dass auf diesem Telefon so wenig Daten drauf sind.
Genau. Aber wie gesagt, ich halte es für ein echtes Novum, dass Apple, die die Tastatur wirklich, eigentlich hassen wie die Pest, auf einem Gerät, was nicht mal über eine Tastatur verfügt, ein explizites Textinterface einführen. Was denn? Nein, das ist... Ja, du durchsuchst... Also ich meine, für dieses Springboard, was ja im Augenblick, sagen wir ehrlich, wenn man mehr als fünf Programme auf diesem Gerät hat, dann ist ja dieses Springboard die totale Katastrophe, weil man findet seine Programme nicht mehr.
Ihr habt einfach zu viel.
Nein, wir haben nicht zu viel.
Ihr habt hier Konsumüberfluss, ihr solltet mal darüber nachdenken.
Ich hab zu viel.
Siehst du?
Ich hab genau richtig.
Ich auch.
Bösen 6-7 Seiten voll. Aber ich finde nie, was ich suche.
Bösen 6-7 Apps.
Ich hab auch ein Problem. Man kann auch nach Applikationen suchen.
Man kann auch nach Applikationen suchen, das meine ich ja. Sie haben anstelle, sich jetzt ordentlich auszudenken, in der Richtung haben sie noch gar nichts gemacht.
Man kann nicht nach Applikationen suchen, sondern es sucht auch nach Applikationen. Man kann es ja nicht eingrenzen.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher, ob das schon alles war, was sie da genannt haben. Also ob das wirklich die einzigen Sachen sind.
Nein, bestimmt nicht.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass sie bei dem Homescreen auch noch ein Feature einbauen, wo sie jetzt aber noch nicht die Notwendigkeit sahen, das vorher zu petzen, weil das ja nun wirklich für einen Developer nicht so relevant ist.
Wo sie vielleicht selber noch gar nicht so weit sind.
Search ist wichtig für den Developer, weil das muss er wissen. Andererseits, ja, Copy und Paste ist auch wichtig, weil auch das müssen die halt berücksichtigen, weil sie Programme schreiben können, die das dann...
Na, Search ist natürlich auch...
Und es wird gleich schick zusammengefasst bei der Suche.
Zusammengefasst nach Gruppen, das heißt, alle Mails beieinander, alle Kalenderitems beieinander.
Alle Geburtstage von dem einen Typen beieinander.
Ah, das ist ja echt schick.
Geburtstage schreibt er auch gleich mit rein?
Na ja, insofern, als dass es als Kalender exportiert ist. Also zumindest zeigt das als Kalender. Ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt hier ein Kalender vom iCal noch mitgesinkt wurde oder was auch immer. Glaub ich auch. Na, okay. Ja, dann gab's noch diesen anderen Screen. Den hab ich mir auch abgelesen.
Noch ein Screen.
Ja, also erst gab's diese, hier sind die Developer-Features und dann kamen die User-Features. Und die User-Features, da hatten sie so ihre Highlights und dann gab's wieder diesen einen Slide, wo so ganz viele Sachen irgendwie in unterschiedlicher Fontgröße drin war und das konnte man auch sehr hübsch wieder abmalen.
Dann drehen wir auch mal, damit wir smulen können.
Genau, also erstmal hatten sie ja YouTube-Accounts noch groß und fett irgendwie und dazu etwas kleiner waren dann auch noch Subscriptions und Settings. Das heißt...
Da fehlt doch noch einer, oder? Seien wir ehrlich. Was soll ich mit einem YouTube-Account, wenn ich keine Videos hochladen kann?
Ich denke auch, dass sie das nächste iPhone-Video haben.
Ich glaube nämlich, das wird fürs nächste iPhone. Händle sie sich das auf wirklich?
Das glaube ich auch. Ich wäre schon ganz froh, wenn sie eine richtige Kamera drin hätten, aber die ist echt scheiße. Und sie müssen auch eine Taste hinzufügen. Aber bleiben wir erstmal bei diesen Features.
Zum Auslösen.
Genau, mit diesem Touchscreen und von hinten und so weiter.
Sie können das auf den gesamten Display einfach machen. Das würde gehen.
Ich will nicht auf dem Bildschirm touchen, den ich nicht sehe.
Und jeder benutzt automatisch den Home-Button am Anfang, oder? Also mir geht das immer so. Ich drücke außerdem auf den Home-Button.
Sie können diesen Scheiß-Slider, wo man hier stummschaltet, gegen den man immer kommt, wenn man das Ding sich in eine Rosentasche steckt, gegen irgendwas Sinnvolles austauschen.
Ich mach den total gerne.
Lass mich erstmal diese Features hier runterbeten. Diese Sendung wird sowieso viel zu lang. Wir werden hier nicht nur unseren Rekord brechen, sondern wir werden eine Länge für diesen Podcast erzeugen, von dem alle sagen werden, habt ihr sie noch alle? Wer soll denn das jemals hören? Aber wir werden am Schluss noch unseren Code für unseren Geschenk-Gutschein vorlesen. Ihr müsst bis zum Ende durchhören.
Soll ich mir bei Amazon so ein Dings machen?
So ein Dings?
Na, was man mir so schenken kann.
Was man dir schenken kann? Klar. Ich rede jetzt von etwas, was man dem Hörer schenken kann.
Fuck.
Fuck haben wir doch am Anfang des Podcasts gesagt. Das hast du doch nicht mitten im Podcast.
Oder wolltest du Fuck gerade verschenken?
Also du möchtest gerne eine Wunschliste machen.
Ja, genau die ist voll geil. Oder?
Schenken.
Also wenn mir Leute was schenken.
Kuchen für Dennis.
Ich krieg an dir irgendwie, ich will folgende Sachen haben und dann können sie loslegen.
Das ist ein interessantes...
Gibt es das auch für eBay?
Das ist ein interessantes... Bitte ersteigert mir diesen Save. Gibt es das auch für Apple Store? Das weiß ich nicht, aber du kannst ja so eine Wunschliste einfach mal machen und dann können wir mal gucken, was die Leute dir bereit sind für deine klugen Kommentare so beizusteuern. Dennis. Kuchen für Dennis. Liebe Hörer.
Genau ein selbstgepackter Kuchen.
Möchte gerne Liebe und Zuneigung empfinden von euch. Und wenn ihr Dennis lieb habt, dann findet ihr euch zusammen im Internet und dann guckt ihr mal, ob ihr Dennis was, einen schönen Lolli kaufen könnt bei Amazon. Guck mal, ob du was findest. Wir gehen derweil nochmal durch die Features. Also was ich dieser Serie, YouTube Accounts, Subscriptions und Settings entnehmen kann, ist, dass die Zusammenarbeit mit Google wächst und gedeiht. Also ich denke auch, Video Upload wird dann noch kommen. Dann stand da noch iTunes Account Creation.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, dass du ein iTunes Account erstellen kannst, ohne dafür einen Mac oder einen PC zu bauen.
Du kannst auch ohne ein iTunes Account dieses scheiß Telefon überhaupt nicht in Betrieb nehmen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich dann in Zukunft gehen.
Warum sollte das so sein?
Weil in Amerika ist es wohl relativ üblich, dass nicht nur, wie man glaubt, der gemeine Technikgeek sich ein iPhone zulegt, sondern durchaus auch Leute, die eher ärmer sind, keinen Computer haben und darum ein Gerät haben wollen, mit dem man auch ein bisschen surfen kann, ohne zu große Kosten zu haben.
Lass uns mal nachdenken, kann man iTunes-Account-Creation? Wenn man sich ein iPhone kauft, dann muss man doch ein Account bei Apple anlegen, oder nicht?
Ja, muss man.
Oder war das nur am Anfang so?
Nee, das muss man.
Warum?
Nee, aber nicht in Belgien und Italien und so weiter, oder?
Ich hab ja ein italienisches iPhone. Mit einem italienischen iPhone musst du auch ein iTunes-Account haben.
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt?
Wird das dann enforced? Beim Aktivieren, das ist der Aktivierungsprozess.
In welcher Form? Das heißt, du hast das iTunes, du schließt dein Telefon an und dann kommt das iTunes hoch und sagt, du musst dir jetzt einen Account machen.
Vielleicht ist es ja demnächst anders.
Und dann legst du den Account an und danach, nachdem du den Account angelegt hast, hast du dein iPhone. Du brauchst einen iTunes-Account, ganz zwingend.
Na dann frag ich mich noch mehr, warum.
Was warum?
Warum sie das Feature A einbauen und B benennen.
Ja, dass man auch ohne einen Computer hat.
Aber warum sollte man einen neuen Account anlegen? Warum ausgerechnet am iPhone?
Weil du kriegst das Ding, hast keinen Computer, schaltest es ein und kannst es trotzdem aktivieren, das Gerät, ohne dass du...
Achso, du meinst, dass man ein iPhone ohne Computer benutzen kann. Interessanter Punkt.
Damit die ganzen Linux-User auch endlich ein iPhone kaufen können.
Das heißt, du schaltest es ein und dann sagt es Hallo, guten Tag, ich bin's, dein iPhone. Vielen Dank, dass du mich gekauft hast. Du brauchst hier übrigens einen Login.
Gib bitte deine Daten an, oder?
Internet und gib deine Daten ein und schließ mit der Raute ab.
Genau.
Pfiffig.
Vermute ich mal, oder?
Das ist gar nicht so doof. Na, dann hast du dein iPhone einfach so gekauft und in Betrieb genommen, ohne einen Computer haben zu müssen. Dann kannst du zwar da nichts reinsinken und so, aber du kannst es halt benutzen, ohne dass du einen Computer hast. Das stimmt schon. Es gibt genug Länder, wo das nicht unbedingt so ist, dass die Leute einen Computer haben. Sehr wohl aber. Also Indien.
China.
Und in Indien läuft es scheiße. China, glaube ich, haben sie eh schon eher Computer, aber in Indien, es gibt auf jeden Fall Länder, die haben nicht das normalste, dass sie Mobiltelefone haben, aber nicht unbedingt normales, dass sie einen Computer haben.
Spandau.
Ja, genau. Schön, wir haben euch alle lieb.
Nächster Punkt.
Create Meeting Invitation stand da noch, das fand ich jetzt weniger spektakulär. iTunes Login stand da noch.
Ist ja wieder das gleiche, oder?
Genau. Dann noch ein paar Sachen. Also Livestreaming stand da noch. Dass man Notes syncen kann. Ich frage mich, wohin?
Na, ins Mailprogramm hoffentlich, oder?
Stimmt.
Genau. Geht ja auch schon in dem jetzigen Leppard hier. Was ist ein Encrypted Profiles?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Also es gibt ja die Developer Profiles. Sagen wir mal, die Developer Profiles, kriegt man ja Developer Profiles.
Encrypted Profiles stand da auch, muss man dazu sagen.
Und diese Developer Profiles, die brauchst du halt, wenn du dein Programm halt in den App Store kriegen willst oder einen Ad Hoc.
Oder Betatester.
Genau, und so weiter. Dann brauchst du diese Profiles.
Ich glaube, die meinen...
Encrypted Profiles hat damit wahrscheinlich gar nichts zu tun, oder? Die meinen damit was anderes.
Das weiß ich nicht. Aber wenn es ein Userfiche ist...
Sagen wir mal, ein Profile kann sein, dass man mehrere User auf einem iPhone haben kann, ne?
Es könnte sein, dass es damit diese Vorkonfiguration von iPhones betrifft.
Na, ich vermute mal eher, dass...
Es ist doch dieses Configuration-Utility, mit dem du sozusagen dein Telefon vorab konfigurieren kannst, an das du es verschickst oder hast, und dann können die Leute das auf ihr iPhone kopieren und dann ist dein iPhone automatisch konfiguriert. Und wenn du das halt verschlüsseln kannst, dass es irgendwie keiner auslesen kann, wie die Settings sind, naja, dass du es nur mit dem Passwort aktivieren kannst. Was denn, Max?
Ich hab mal eine tolle Theorie. Und zwar, dass es einfach darum geht... Bisher ist es ja so, dass viele Programme dazu neigen, auch Passwörter unverschlüsselt irgendwo abzuspeichern. Nach dem Auto kommt ja eh keine Sau ran. Mit einem Jailbreak kommt man aber doch ran. Jetzt ist es natürlich ein böser Fall, Kommen man oder haben die auch so ne Art Keychain? Im Augenblick machen das viele unverschlüsselt. Und es gibt jetzt von irgendeinem Open Source-Entwickler gibt es jetzt so ne Schnittstelle, mit der man sowas transparent die Daten dann doch verschlüsseln kann. Und dass dieses Encrypted Profile klingt für mich sehr danach, dass einfach alle Daten, die du eingibst, verschlüsselt sind. Und das kostet dann eben ein bisschen Rechenleistung, dann hält das Akku nicht ganz so lange.
Alle Daten, die du eingibst?
Warum nicht?
Das würden sie nicht als drittes Feature irgendwie auf dem Slide, was wir sonst noch haben, irgendwie in der kleinsten Fontgröße irgendwie mal rein zufällig hinschreiben, wenn sie auf einmal alle Daten verschlüsseln. Und wenn überhaupt, dann fehlt halt sowas wie die Keychain und davon hab ich nichts gesehen.
Safari kann in Zukunft auch Passwort erspeichern. Weil sie es gesagt haben.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie Autofill haben.
Das ist doch Passworterspeichern, oder?
Das ist nicht unbedingt Passworterspeichern. Das Autofill ist das so generell Formulare.
Ich würde sagen, es geht zusammen, dass das ein schönes Gesamtbild ergibt.
Aber warum featuren sie? Also wenn sie Keychains haben...
Wahrscheinlich wollen sie es nicht so an die große Glocke.
Du meinst, dass nur Safari das kann. Safari macht jetzt Keychains, aber alle anderen dürfen es noch nicht benutzen und müssen auf Version 4 warten?
Nee, ich nehme ein, dass es einfach so was ist wie dein Home-Folder. Im Augenblick kannst du ja auch einen Finer geben, kannst sagen, egal was das Programm macht, egal ob sie Daten verschlüsselt abspeichert oder nicht, ich hab mein verschlüsseltes Home-Verzeichnis. Bei Mac. Und da sind alle Daten drin verschlüsselt, dass du das in Zukunft auch auf dem iPhone machen kannst.
Also das aus den beiden Worten, Encrypted Profiles rauszulesen, halte ich für etwas vermessen. Ich denke, dass das eh sehr viel mehr mit dieser Konfigurations-Utility zu tun hat. Aber wir werden es rauskriegen.
Das fällt mir noch passend was ein, wenn wir schon mal bei Krypto sind. Mit dem iPhone 3.0 Beta, wenn man das an seinen iTunes ranmacht, dann kommt da eine neue Einstellung, nämlich Encrypted Backup.
Stimmt, das hatte ich auch irgendwo gelesen. Das heißt, man kann jetzt das Backup verschlüsseln.
Ach doch, das ist ja...
Weil da ist ja alles, sozusagen, alle Sandboxen liegen dann irgendwie offen rum und dann ist das auch in deinem Sport.
Stimmt, man konnte das aus dem Backup auslesen, die Daten relativ leicht, bei einigen Programmen. Ich nehme aber auch an, dass der Weg auch geht. Du könntest ja auch einfach von dem Ding einen Jailbreak machen, nachdem du es hast. Du klaust jemanden sein Telefon, machst einen Jailbreak, gehst rein per SSH und liest die ganzen Datenbanken aus. Ich glaube, es gibt schon echten Bedarf, diese ganzen Seiten zu verschlüsseln.
Ja, sie müssen einfach Keychain-Support reinbauen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich verstehe nicht, wo das bleibt. Also das kann ja nun nicht das Problem sein. Also gut, vielleicht sind sie da etwas zurückhaltend, was den Punkt betrifft, dass man User auf dem iPhone dazu zwingt, Passwörter einzugeben, was sie ja bisher so nicht haben, sondern bestenfalls eben diese Nummern kurz.
Nee, das kannst du ja mit dem Konfigurationstool umschalten auf ein Passwort.
Okay, aber auch das ist jetzt nicht so... Den Weg muss man halt erst gehen. Unklar. Naja, was haben wir noch? Languages haben sie beworben, dass sie jetzt mehr Languagesupport haben, die Tastaturen werden besser werden. Also gut, vielleicht verbessert sich irgendwas für uns.
Deutsche Umlaute, das wäre mal eine lustige Sache.
Na gut, das haben sie ja schon drin.
Naja, aber ohne dass man da irgendwie ewig lang auf der Tastatur gedrückt haben muss.
Ja, das stimmt, das ist ein bisschen... Also grundsätzlich wäre ich damit zufrieden. Das Einzige, was mich stört an der Eingabe derzeit, ist, dass man eben, wenn man erstmal in diesem Untermenü drin ist, für diese ganzen diakritischen Zeichen, dass du da auch nicht wieder rauskommst, sondern du musst dann irgendwas auswählen aus dieser Tastatur.
Ja, also das finde ich... Also ich finde, es gibt, wenn man ein jailbroken iPhone hat, dann gibt es dieses iKeyRowX oder irgendwie sowas heißt das. Und was da relativ populär geworden ist, ist das 5-Row-Keyboard, also eine 5-zeilige Tastatur, die dann oben noch eine Ziffernreihe hat.
Und was hat sich erledigt?
Dass man da was eingeben muss.
Ach so, haben Sie es verbessert? Ich hätte es ja auch gleich mal hier auf diesem 3.0-Dingsbums ausprobieren können.
Zeig mal kurz. Da kann man dann auch, was ich gar nicht... Ich brauch das gar nicht. Und wenn man ein jailbroken iPhone hat, dann kann man sich eine zusätzliche Tastatur, und da gibt es auch eine deutsche Tastatur, die dann L, Ö, Ü und S, Z hat, und eben die Tasten 1 bis 0, direkt immer auf dem Standard-Screen. Mit der fünften Zeile kam ich nicht so gut klar, aber L, Ö, Ü und S, Z hätte ich trotzdem gerne. Will nicht da mal jemand was machen, einfach nur eine deutsche Tastatur, wo ich die Umlaute auch so eingeben kann? Das scheint ja nicht so schwer zu sein. Vielleicht setze ich mich selber mal ran.
Tja, mach doch mal was. Verbessert doch mal die Situation, mein Freund.
Genau.
Das funktioniert tatsächlich wirklich besser. Das sind diese kleinen Sachen, die machen irgendwie das Leben größer. Ja, da haben wir noch so ein User-Feature, das mich wirklich überhaupt nicht interessiert. Das ist so Shake to Shuffle. Ich werde meine Podcast mir dann irgendwie geschuffelt anhören. Ich glaube, es hackt.
Da geht doch nur die Platte von kaputt.
Dann Wi-Fi-Auto-Login. Da frage ich mich, wie sie das machen. Also dieses automatisch einloggen an einem Hotspot. Da frage ich mich ja wirklich, wie das funktionieren soll. Und du meinst, da gibt es einen Standard?
Ich habe nie behauptet, dass es einen Standard gibt.
Also da bin ich wirklich gespannt, ob da die Provider noch irgendwas bieten. Ich habe mich schon immer gefragt, warum es nicht so eine Autodiscovery gibt beim Hotspot. Ich meine, sie könnten da einfach am Hotspot, können sie irgendwie mit Bonjour sagen, Hallo. Ich bin ein Hotspot. Und hier ist irgendwie die URL, über die du dich einloggen kannst.
Also, dass da in der Richtung müsste man sowieso mal eine ganze Menge machen, dass man auch nicht sieht, wie das ist.
Redirekten von Webseiten, das geht einfach gar nicht.
Zertifizierte Hotspots.
Furchtbar, und Zertifizierungen überhaupt.
Reden wir nicht drüber.
Du kannst nicht mehr.
Ja, dann haben sie noch solche Sachen wie Revoked Zerts. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, worauf sich das bezieht. Ob sich das jetzt auf Web bezieht oder so. Proxy-Support, naja Autofill hatten wir schon. Parental Controls, naja. Was gut ist, dass VPN on Demand kommt. Na derzeit, du hast VPN, aber du musst es derzeit immer wieder von Hand einschalten. Also du musst einmal konfigurieren, dann gehst du online und dann musst du es wieder einschalten. Und jetzt kannst du es so konfigurieren, dass du sagst, wenn bestimmte Domains angegangen werden, dann soll es sich automatisch einschalten. Und ich hoffe, dass sie halt auch Sternen haben, dass man sozusagen sagen kann, immer erstmal beim VPN einwählen, bevor du irgendeine Internetaktivität hast.
Kann man nicht einfach das VPN die ganze Zeit über eingeschaltet lassen?
Na in dem Moment, wo du aus dem Hotspot wieder rausmarschierst oder dein Telefon ausschaltest, ist es halt aus.
Wie so über den Hotspot?
Ich meine, man soll es doch vielleicht über 3G machen.
Was wie?
Über 3G? Also ich meine, er soll doch einfach immer über die Verbindung. Also im Augenblick ist das so, ich hab mir mal, es gab beim iPhone-Blog, gab es nämlich schon Anleitung, die leider nicht hundertprozentig gestimmt hat.
Du kannst auf deine VPN-Connection nicht über mehrere Sachen hinwegchromen.
Warum nicht?
Na weil das die andere Seite nicht mitmacht.
Nee, es soll einfach so bald...
Du bist auf einmal von einer anderen IP-Adresse. Da musst du schon wieder neu aufbauen.
Ja, macht er halt.
Dann soll er halt transparent im Hintergrund die IP aufbauen.
Ja, aber das gibt es halt derzeit nicht. Es gibt kein VPN-On-Demand. Und das bauen sie jetzt ein, haben sie gesagt.
Aber ich meine, mit Sternchen brauche ich glaube ich nicht im Zweifelsfall, weil...
Da gibt es so ein Button, einmal alles, ne?
Ich mach hier, ich mach es an und dann ist es an.
Ja, genau. Und schaltest du dein Telefon halt aus oder du gehst aus diesem WLAN raus vor die Tür und dann ist dein VPN halt aus.
Ich gehe jetzt mal kurz aus dem WLAN raus, so indem ich es abschalte. Und jetzt ist er auf 3G und ich habe weiterhin meinen VPN.
Ja, seh ich auch so.
Nee, hast du nicht.
Das hat auch gar keinen Sinn.
Jetzt hat er ausgeschaltet.
Genau, natürlich hat er es ausgeschaltet.
Wieso natürlich hat er es ausgeschaltet?
Weil du eine andere IP-Adresse hast, weil du von einer anderen Quelle kommst und dein VPN ist eine Verbindung und diese Verbindung existiert dann nicht mehr.
Dann soll er sie gefälligst wieder aufbauen.
Das bauen sie ja ein, Max. Das ist doch das, was ich sage.
Undimant VPN halte ich. Nee, das ist was anderes. Das ist, wenn ich eine bestimmte IP anwähle oder ein bestimmter Domain eingebe, das hat dann die Verbindung aufbauen.
Ja, und dieses Domain kann auch sein anything. Das ist doch das.
Nee, er baut gerade die Verbindung auf. Das dauert einfach bloß einen Moment.
Der sucht einfach seine Verbindung und findet sie nicht mehr. Das ist das, was ich sage. Nein, er wird sie einfach gleich ausschalten. Believe me, ich hab den ganzen Urlaub darüber mit diesem Problem gekämpft. Er macht es nicht automatisch.
Der baut kein VPM-Nord gerade.
Noch schlechter als Apple.
Nicht on demand, mein Gott. So, anyway, dann stand hier noch unter weitere User-Features und jetzt kommen wir wieder zu unserem Punkt mit Safari 4, den wir vorhin hatten, Audio-Slash-Video-Tags. Stand da auf diesem Slide. Er hat nicht darüber geredet. Es stand da drauf. Das Einzige, was mir da einfällt, ist HTML5 und das, was ich schon gesagt habe. Das heißt, es kann durchaus sein, muss nicht sein, kann durchaus sein, dass sie im Safari das unterstützen. Dann stand da noch was von...
Ich würde sagen, Audio-Video-Tags spricht eindeutig dafür, dass sie das unterstützen. Was unter User-Features zu packen, das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen lustig, aber okay.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Und dann gab es noch den Hinweis auf einen Media-Scrubber.
Was ist ein Media-Scrubber?
Was heißt ein Scrubber überhaupt?
Also ich kenne das nur...
Ein Scrubber ist in der Regel so ein User-Interface, wo du halt irgendwie schnell nach vorne, nach hinten sliden kannst. Und das ist halt das, was schon berichtet wurde im Web, dass sie den Podcast-Support verbessern. Genau, stimmt. Und vielleicht bedeutet das, dass das generell irgendwie geht. Vielleicht bezieht sich das jetzt auch auf etwas ganz anderes. Offensichtlich gibt es so eine Funktionalität.
Also, was mir in dem Zusammenhang einfällt, ist, wir haben ja gerade eben diesen Genius-Button erwähnt auf dem iPhone. Und der ist bei Podcasts meines Wissens nach verschwunden, weil da macht der eh keinen Sinn. Und stattdessen ist da so ein kleiner Button, der so ein Pfeil zurück hat. Da steht irgendwas von 30 dran. Ich nehme mal an, das wird so eine Funktion sein, dass du 30 Sekunden zurücksprängst.
Dieses Telefon hier ist leider... Du kannst Musik von iTunes downloaden. Vielen Dank für den Hinweis. Ja, erzähl weiter, Max.
Du kannst doch mal rasch einen Podcast runter, eigentlich einfach auf dem Ding.
Denn befindet sich hier glaube ich gerade kein Computer, der das mit dem da reinsinken kann. Mach du mal online.
Über iTunes.
Achso, iTunes ist da ja drauf. Oh man, bin ich bekloppt. Du hast so recht. Aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das... Gucken wir mal. Ich lad mal einen Podcast runter. Welchen wollen wir nehmen? Welchen soll ich nehmen? Einen, der schnell lädt, ne?
Unseren.
Satirischer Wochenrückblick von NDR. Der ist immer extrem kurz.
Deutschlandradio Hintergrund ist immer recht kompakt. Laden. Funktioniert sogar. Aber vielleicht können wir in der Zwischenzeit nochmal über Sachen reden, die hier auch noch stehen. Ah, da steht schon fast gar nichts mehr.
Ah, das ist der Media Scrubber. Damit kannst du in unterschiedlichen Geschwindigkeiten einstellen, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit du einen Podcast fahren wolltest. Ein Feature, von dem du geträumt hast.
Die Podcast-Download-Geschichte.
Könnte man auch mit diesen Audiobox auch schon machen, oder?
Aber nur dort kannst du nur einen langsamer und schneller und genauso schnell einstellen, aber du kannst nicht dynamisch das ändern. Vielleicht sollten wir jetzt auch nochmal das erzählen. Es waren ja noch ein paar andere Sachen, aber das ist irgendwie echt Kleinkram. Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal Sachen erwähnen, die nicht dabei sind und wo wir der Meinung sind, dass die ja mal eigentlich dabei sein müssten. Achso, was noch dabei ist, ist, dass Podcasts auch über OMTS Unlimited runtergeladen werden können. Das heißt, wir werden demnächst auch auf dem iPhone in voller Länge heruntergeladen werden können, selbst wenn man keinen WLAN hat.
Sehr gut, bin ich mal gespannt, ob das Feature bei allen Netzen überlebt.
Das wenn sie, ja, keine Ahnung.
Obwohl, eigentlich kann es ihnen egal sein.
Was gibt es nicht? Keychain gibt es nicht.
Irgendwie habe ich gerade was gehört von wegen, es gibt einen Keychain. Aber das taucht im Chat auf, ich habe noch keine Zeit dazu zu lesen.
Dieses Homescreen-Management, das wollen wir alle anders haben. Vielleicht gehen sie da wirklich nur auf Suche, ich weiß es nicht. Und was ich ja ganz gerne mal hätte, ist, dass man diese Rotationsautomatik ausschalten kann. Das nervt mich ja wirklich total. Das geht ja wirklich überhaupt nicht.
Kann man im Bett abends nicht seitwärts irgendwie... Jetzt kannst du nicht nur im Bett kein Safari mehr benutzen, jetzt kannst du auch kein Mail, kein Notepad und kein SMS tippen. Weil dreht jetzt alles, wenn du seitwärts liegst.
Jetzt wird es spannend hier. Großartig. Also man kann jetzt hier tatsächlich... Doppelte Geschwindigkeit, halbe Geschwindigkeit. Ah, bei mir nicht.
Nee, irgendwie muss es auch noch gehen, dass du, wenn du die Taste länger gedrückt hältst, dass du dann auch beliebig wählen kannst. Oder ich weiß nicht, irgendwie sowas in die Richtung.
Sehe ich nicht.
Doppelklick, dreifach klick, festhalten.
Warte mal. Ich habe hier so einen Screenshot, wo man das hier so sieht.
Kann man nicht hier irgendwie hoch und...
Genau, aktuell 30 Sekunden genau zurückspringen.
Dafür gibt es einen Button.
Lässt man den Finger gleichzeitig nach oben gleiten, gerät man in einen High-Screen-Speed-Scrubbing-Modus und springt weiter, weit voran.
Wenn man das wo macht? Ach da, High-Speed-Scrubbing.
Über den Knopf des Fortschritts balken.
Half-Speed-Scrubbing.
Hört sich jetzt so ein bisschen italienisch an, das heißt, die Italiener sprechen auch schon schneller, ja?
Ich glaube, Tim kriegt gerade einen Orgasmus.
Ich glaub's nicht. Heilige Maria. Das ist cool. Sie haben interessante Lösungen. Dafür liebe ich sie, dass sie dann auch wirklich auf so interessante Lösungen kommen. Also, wenn ich es mal kurz mit meinen Worten beschreiben darf.
Schreib's mal mit eigenen Worten, wie es war für dich.
Also, erstens, man kann die Abspielgeschwindigkeit von halber Geschwindigkeit auf doppelte Geschwindigkeit. Meine Erfahrung ist, dass doppelte Geschwindigkeit ist ganz schön heftig manchmal.
Eine halbfache Geschwindigkeit ist...
Eine halbfache Geschwindigkeit ist......erträglicher. Doppelte Geschwindigkeit ist ein bisschen heftig. Das könnte unter Umständen too much sein und halbe Geschwindigkeit ist dann auch zu wenig. Also da müsste man nochmal andere schrittweise machen. Aber man kann jetzt diesen kleinen Gummipunkt dann nehmen, nach rechts und nach links sliden einfach, aber mit der Höhe deines Fingers sozusagen auf dem Display kann man wählen, wie schnell man da nach vorn und nach hinten geht. Und hat man ihn ganz unten, dann ist es so im Sekundenbereich und oben ist es so im Minutenbereich. Also das, was man vorher beim iPod-Wheel mit der Geschwindigkeit der Rotationen gemacht hat, das macht man jetzt hier über Position. Das kann man nicht so in der Hosentasche machen, wie man das mit dem Wheel gemacht hat, aber immerhin, es geht. Das ist schon mal cool.
Apropos iPod-Interface, ich hab mir ein Programm runtergeladen namens ConvertBot, mit dem man so Daten umrechnen kann, und zwar als kleine Warnung vor und weg in der aktuellen Version.
Das ist aber auch ganz unten wirklich. Also hier oben ist es ja noch voll schnell. Es geht wirklich über den ganzen Bildschirm.
Was hast du da?
Dieses kleine Programm, was 79 Cent kostet und nicht richtig umrechnen, also seine Hauptaufgabe nicht erfüllt, das erinnert vom Interface her an ein sehr bekanntes Gerät. Es hat nämlich so ein Rädchen und so ein Knopf in der Mitte.
Wie heißt das?
ConvertBot. Damit kann man nur Daten konvertieren von einem Format ins andere.
Also ein hübsches User-Interface.
Hübsches User-Interface. Aber wie gesagt, im Augenblick funktioniert es überhaupt nicht. Das ist dem Entwickler schon bekannt und die neue Version ist schon im App-Store angemeldet. Ähm, mal bitte ein bisschen leiser.
Klar, ich verstehe.
Ja, du bist das.
Und, ähm, das vermisse ich ja noch so ein bisschen, so ein iPod-eskeres User-Interface auch beim iPhone. Weil eigentlich geht das relativ gut hier, das Auswählen darüber. Und das könnte man doch in einigen Programmen gebrauchen, wie zum Beispiel dem iPod, dem virtuellen. Und wir hatten irgendwann mal darüber gestritten, ob man das überhaupt vernünftig bedienen kann auf dem iPhone, dieses Interface. Und ich fand, das geht relativ gut mit diesem kleinen Programm. Mehr wollte ich gar nicht sagen.
Okay.
So, haben wir noch irgendwas auf der Liste?
Ja, ich hab da noch so eine andere Geschichte kennengelernt, die mich so ein bisschen bestürzt hat.
Wie heißt sie?
Die mir sozusagen bisher vollkommen unklar war. Und du müsstest jetzt mal auf dein iPhone schauen.
Wunderst du dich? Woher hast du das? Was ist das? Hast du sowas schon mal gesehen? Ich hab sowas schon mal gesehen, ja. Das sind also so SMS direkt. Vor ein paar Tagen. Vor ein paar Tagen. Und da hast du das erste Mal gesehen und jetzt siehst du das zweite Mal.
Exakt.
Also ich hab ein... Also soll ich vielleicht mal beschreiben? Beschreib mal, was du siehst. Ich habe einen leeren Bildschirm vor mir, auf dem drauf steht, fürchte dich nicht, ich bin dein Freund und unten drunter steht schließen. Ich hab's gar nicht wahrgenommen. Also ich hab so irgendwie das Telefon, es klingelte, weil der Wecker an war und ich drückte auf die Taste, auf die ich sonst immer drückte und hab's noch kurz so aus dem Blick, äh, war da jetzt irgendwas?
Und hab's überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen. Und hab so, nee, das musste ich geträumt haben. Was würdest du meinen, was das ist?
Du bist gerade erfolgreich in mein iPhone eingedrungen. Von außen.
Sieht auch voll hackerei-mäßig aus.
Es sieht total hackerei-mäßig aus.
Ja, vor allem du hast keine Ahnung, von wem das ist und du hast auch keine Ahnung, was es ist und warum und überhaupt.
Ich hab auch einen kurzen Schreck gekriegt in dem Moment. Ich hatte es jetzt wie gesagt für ein Traum gehalten, hab es vergessen gehabt.
Genau und da stand, hab keine Angst oder so.
Ja, ist das eine Flash-SMS?
Das ist eine Flash-SMS. Das ist etwas, was ich auch vor kurzem erst zur Kenntnis genommen habe, dass es so etwas gibt, das wusste ich noch nicht. Es gibt halt SMS und es gibt eine sogenannte Flash-SMS. Das ist einfach ein Bit in der SMS, was gesetzt ist für das Telefon und die offizielle Instruktion heißt, diese Nachricht soll sofort angezeigt werden, also ohne irgendeine Warteschleife oder eine spezialisierte Notifizierung, wie das ja normalerweise auf alles du hast eine SMS bekommen, drück hier drauf, dann siehst du alles, auch wenn du beim iPhone sozusagen schon die SMS vorher ein bisschen siehst. Flash-SMS soll sofort angezeigt werden. Und eigentlich ist das dafür gedacht, dass du, was weiß ich, dass dein Provider dir sagt, dein Handy gut haben ist jetzt gleich abgelaufen oder sowas, dass du das halt nicht überblättern kannst. Das iPhone macht das halt so, egal welches Programm du gerade benutzt, das macht so einen halbtransparenten Fullscreen darüber, zeigt die Nachricht an, zeigt den übrigens nicht an, von wem sie ist.
Ich kann so ein bisschen dran rumscrollen.
Und unten steht irgendwie ein Schließen-Button und danach ist sie weg und sie ist auch nicht gespeichert.
Ich mach mal einen Screenshot von.
Und wie konnte ich dir das jetzt verschicken? Das O2-Webinterface bietet tatsächlich die Möglichkeit, hier anzuklicken Senden als Flash-SMS von O2. Also sozusagen, als wäre das vom Netz... Hardcore, oder?
Das ist echt mal...
Das ist wirklich Hardcore und man kann das nicht ausschalten.
Ja, damit kann man schon für den Leuten Schreck einjagen, glaube ich.
Da kannst du den Leuten einen richtigen Schreck einjagen. Da kannst du wirklich sagen, irgendwie Terrorwarnung jetzt und keiner... Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie das bei anderen Telefonen aussieht, aber ich war schon ein bisschen erstaunt oder erschreckt, wie das hier jetzt beim iPhone rüberkommt. Ich meine, sie halten sich vollständig an die Spezifikation. Sofort anzeigen und so weiter. Ja, keine Speicherung möglich, aber dass man überhaupt nicht gesagt bekommt, was jetzt hier eigentlich passiert, was ja noch nicht mal, ob es nicht vielleicht das Programm ist, was gerade...
Es ist, also wie gesagt, ich dachte, dass es, dass da irgendj- also ich hatte für den Moment, ich habe wirklich einen Schreck gekriegt.
Das ist mega krass, ne?
Und ich bin nun jemand, der sich in Bezug auf Technik nicht oft erschreckt.
Ja, ja, ja, so ist das. Die Telekom-Netze, unendliche Weiten.
Learning stuff about the iPhone. Ich hab dir gerade den Screenshot gerade mal zugeschickt. Den kannst du ja vielleicht mal...
Screenshot zugeschickt? Ach so, den soll ich posten.
Den können wir dann mit einbauen.
Den bauen wir mit ein. Ja, haben wir's?
Ist noch irgendjemand?
Denn es ist durch. Denn es braucht irgendwie Behandlung. Und ich denke, wir haben jetzt hier auch schon alle Rekorde übertroffen. Obwohl ich hätte noch 107 Stunden Disk Space.
Lass doch einfach die Republika durchlaufen.
Genau. Naja, das war... war's das?
Das war's, oder?
Das war's. Dennis, du bist der Meinung, das war's.
Wir sehen uns auf der Republika. Ein Teil von euch?
Ich denke, das heißt Republika.
Ah, Republika. Mir doch wurscht. Also wir sehen uns in Berlin im Frühstattpalast.
Genau, diese Woche, wenn ihr da seid.
Ich sag's immer, wenn ich nichts anderes sage.
Genau. Wollt mir nicht noch was zu Mekheis sagen? Ja, ich kann noch was zu Mekheis sagen. Wusstest du, dass bei Mekheis, dass das so läuft, dass umso mehr Leute das kaufen, umso mehr Programme freigeschaltet werden? Das wusste ich noch nicht. Und das nächste, was freigeschaltet werden würde, wenn nochmal so, keine Ahnung, weitere 10.000 dazukommt, ist Boinx TV.
Bisher sind, glaube ich, immer alle Programme freigeschaltet worden. Also es ist, das lohnt sich echt. Dieses Bundle lohnt sich echt. Also wenn man, wenn man, es gibt, es gibt einige Programme dabei, wo dann so die normalerweise 70 Dollar kosten. Wenn man das gerade haben will, kriegt man für 40 Dollar oder was?
Den Rest brauche ich alles gar nicht.
Ich fand da ein Programm ganz hübsch.
Die spenden auch immer voll viel Geld, oder?
Ja, die spenden angeblich 25 Prozent der Summe. Aber ich weiß nie an wen.
Das kann man aussuchen. Beim Kauf kann man aussuchen, an wen man gerne spenden möchte. Was ich hier ganz hübsch fand, das ist ein Programm namens iPhone View. Und damit kann man, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das machen ohne Jailbreak. Kann man drauf zugreifen, auf das, oft kann man SMS sich angucken und Notizen und so was, dann kann man sich angucken.
Die gucken auf dein Backup, oder?
Nee, du musst das iPhone dazu anschließen. Ich hab mir die Demo-Asian runtergeladen.
Weil es dann das Backup macht. Aber World of Goo ist auch dabei.
Was ist denn das?
Ein Spiel. Little Snapper ist so ein Programm, mit dem man Fullscreen-Screenshots machen kann, von Webseiten.
Ach, wirklich?
Und Wiretap?
So in PDF oder was?
Das ist ganz easy, hab ich schon mal für ein RD geschrieben. Na, das war von der Webseite, die gerade in den RD gepostet wird. Also ich hab mich zur Datemann connected, hab ne Notify bekommen, wenn einer einen neuen RD-Eintrag gemacht hat. Dann hab ich das in so ein Webview geladen und dann als PDF abgespeichert.
Du weißt ja gerade, was ein RD-Eintrag ist, oder? Das ist so eine interne Quelle für URLs. Deswegen sagen wir das jetzt ja auch.
Und Espresso würde sich vielleicht auch noch lohnen, wenn das irgendwann freigeschaltet wird.
Dann machst du es mit Safari oder was?
Ich hab ein eigenes Programm mit einem Webview und dem Webview kann ich sagen, speichere ich mal als PDF.
Ach so, mit eigener Software.
Das ist so ein Programm, mit dem man sieht so auf den ersten Blick nicht ganz schlecht aus, zum HTML-Webdeveloper-Programm. So ein bisschen in Richtung von, wie heißt das?
Hast du eigentlich schon mal von Objective-J gehört?
Hat man denn schon darüber geredet?
Kann durchaus sein.
Oder war das das andere? Das ist so wie Objective-C, Frameworks, bloß halt für JavaScript.
Hier gibt es sogar noch einige.
Aber nicht so wie dieses, was Apple da irgendwie sich einverleibt hat für dieses Mobile-Me? Das hieß ja, wie ist das?
Genau, das ist das, worüber wir geredet haben und es hieß... Sprout Core ist ein anderer Ansatz. Das sind reine JavaScript-Frameworks und Objective-J setzt auf dieselbe Syntax wie Objective-C, richtig? Dass man da sozusagen wieder Smalltalk schreibt und man hat den ganzen JavaScript drumherum wie C.
Man kann da Objective-J in deine Webseite einbinden und es wird dann vom JavaScript ausgeführt oder wie war das?
Was jetzt?
Ja, das wird auch nicht kompiliert oder sowas. Das ist ganz merkwürdig. Sollten wir vielleicht nochmal, bevor wir darüber diskutieren und jetzt nochmal die Sendung in die Länge ziehen, uns nochmal ein bisschen schlau machen.
Lieber nochmal nachdenken. Ich habe wenig mentale Verbindungen mit diesem Mac. Heißt, ob das jetzt eine tolle Sache ist oder nicht. Es klingt so ein bisschen für Developer wie ein schlechter Deal.
Da gab es aber schon mal von irgendeinem Developer, dass es eigentlich schon ein schlechter Deal ist, weil die es ja total viel billiger rausgeben. Aber er meint, er reicht dadurch auch voll viele Leute, die er sonst überhaupt gar nie erreicht hätte.
Unter dem Strich für ihn dasselbe oder was?
Also ich glaube, Strich ist es reichlich mehr.
Also ich kenne jemand, der hat bei MacSort mal mitgemacht und hat darüber sein Programm verkauft. MacSort, das ist so ein Blog, wo jeden Tag irgendwie ein Programm günstiger ist oder so was, wenn du hast 24 Stunden Zeit, das zu kaufen. So ein bisschen wie dieses MacHeist-Ding. Ich glaube, es ist auch von denselben Machern oder zumindest von einem ähnlichen Format. Und da ist das Programm, du kriegst irgendwie, das kostet höchstens die Hälfte von dem, was es normalerweise kostet, und von dem kriegt noch die Hälfte dieser MacSort-Typ. Aber der hat wohl an einem Tag so viele Lizenzen verkauft wie sonst nicht in einem halben Jahr.
Und das sind dann auch alles, ich bewäntel, ne, der von Delicious Library war es nicht, aber irgendein Coda war das und der meinte, das sind auch alles potenzielle Kandidaten, die dann beim nächsten Upgrade auch dann wieder mit aufsteigen und so.
Oft sind die Lizenzen nicht upgradbar, genau.
Im Großen und Ganzen Lohn, genau.
Also ich bin schon bei einigen Programmen dadurch hängen geblieben, dass ich mal einen Max-Sock-Bundle gekauft habe. Und wenn mein PayPal-Account vernünftig funktionieren würde, aus einem Grundstreik der zurzeit, hätte ich es schon lange gekauft.
So, jetzt ist Schluss mit Gefasel.
Genau!
Alle anderen Themen für das nächste Mal. Und ja, wir wollen auch mal ein Treffen machen, dachte ich mir. Wollten wir das nicht mal schon immer mal machen?
Genau, wir wollten schon immer mal ein Treffen machen.
Ein kleines Hörer-Treffen, da werden wir noch mal einen Termin finden. Ich glaube, die Woche wäre jetzt ein bisschen zu kurzfristig, aber schauen wir mal. Und bleibt uns gewogen. Wir haben noch ein paar Ideen, so hier, für die nähere Zukunft. Mal schauen, was wir davon umgesetzt bekommen. Ich hoffe, wir kriegen nochmal so einen Screen-Krast raus, wie du das neulich gemacht hast.
Ja, das muss wissen.
Wenn ihr da gute Ideen habt, auch gerne, aber wir versuchen auch eigene gute Ideen zu haben, ausnahmsweise. Beim MOBA-MAX.
Und wenn ihr in Berlin seid in den nächsten Tagen, dann sag doch mal hallo und...
Genau, du meinst auf der Republika.
Auf der Republika-Republika.
Also du wirst da sein, auf jeden Fall. Ich werde auch ab und zu mal da sein, aber ich werde nicht so dauerhaft da sein können. Und Dennis?
Muss die erst mal fertig machen.
Die müssen wir noch mit schleppen, wa?
So sieht ein total begeistertes Gesicht aus.
Der muss erst mal sein Schnupfen auskurieren. So, jetzt brav Tschüss sagen.
Tschüssi.
Und bis bald.
Kann ich jetzt den Witz erzählen?
Gleich.